IN RESPONSE THE COVID
NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
DESERVE ACCESS TO LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ACADEMIA
THE TECH INDUSTRY AND
NONPROFITS ADVOCATING IN THIS
SPACE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FIRM ALL PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I GUESS THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE
THE USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. AS
OPPOSED TO ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY
RAISING YOUR HAND. EACH TIME
YOU RECOGNIZE THE SPEAK A POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE
YOURSELF. POLICE SELECTOR ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN. WHEN YOU'RE READY. TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO SPEND TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. EIGHT SIX
SEVEN SIX ONE SIX THREE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT TWO FOUR. FOR
DETAILS STRUCTURES ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER THE SENATE. JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WEBSITES PLEASE
HEARING WILL BE HEARING. ALL
THE PANELS OF WITNESSES ON THE
AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ONCE WE'VE HEARD
ALL THE WITNESSES. WILL HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE
WHO WISH O COMMENT ON THE TO
TODAY'S TOPICS- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WILL BE PROVIDED UP
TO MAKE COMMENT AND ASK
QUESTIONS PRIOR TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MOVE MOVE. YOUR DEVICE
YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE SUPPORT AND WE HEAR
FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS A MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IS CLOSE THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS TO ADJUSTING THE
NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED. PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. I WANT. THE HEARING BY
THANKING THE PANELISTS WE'VE
LINED UP TODAY FOR THEIR WORK
IN THEIR WILLINGNESS TO SHARE
THEIR EXPERTISE. AND INSIGHTS
WITH US. I WANT TO PARTICULARLY
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR STERN. CENTER
BOARD JUST FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND SENATE CORTESE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AS WELL- ISSUES
WE LOOK TO TACKLE AND BETTER
UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE BEEN
AROUND FOR SOME TIME AND GROWN.
EXPONENTIALLY OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. THIS EXPLAINS WHY SO
MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE
INTRODUCED. BILLS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
ARE FACING- LEGISLATION TO
ADDRESS THE PROMINENCE GROWING
PROMINENCE INFLUENCE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS. IN ATTENDANCE
SOCIAL ILLS SUCH AS
PROLIFERATION OF
MISINFORMATION. FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE IN A DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS SILTATION OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. NONCONSENSUAL ****
AND THE FOSTERING OF HATE
SPEECH AND VIOLENT
RADICALIZATION. I SHARE SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS AND BELIEVE THAT
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE HOWEVER.
I'M SURE THAT MANY FOLKS BE NAY
WILL MAKE CLEAR. NEITHER
IDENTIFIED NOR SOLVING THE
PROBLEM IS SIMPLE AT ALL EVEN
COMING TO THE DEFINITION OF
WHAT CONSTITUTES A QUOTE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM AND QUOTE CAN BE
COMPLEX. TODAY'S HEARING IS
INTENDED TO MAKE US A LITTLE
MORE FLUENT. IN AWARE OF BOTH
THE TECHNOLOGY AND LANGUAGE THE
LANGUAGE NEEDED TO UNDERSTAND
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES. ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES WHAT SPACE CAN
THE STATE OPERATE IN THIS
FEDERAL LAW. THOSE FIRST
AMENDMENT CONSTITUTION- THE
STATE CERTAINLY HAS A ROLE- AND
ONE OF THE THINGS WILL EXPLORE
IS WHAT THAT ROLE CAN BE
IMPRACTICAL IN LEGAL TERMS- WE
HAVE TO FIRST UNDERSTAND HOW
THE MECHANICS THESE PLATFORMS
WORK. HOW THEY'RE USED TO-
POTENTIALLY INFLICT INTENTIONAL
AND UNINTENTIONAL HARMS AND HOW
PLATFORMS THEMSELVES MAY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE PROBLEM. WE
HAVE A PANEL OF EXPERTS THE
DETAILS EXACTLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING ON THESE PLATFORMS
FROM HARASSMENT THE FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE TO MEDICAL
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION AND WHO MAY BE
RESPONSIBLE. THIS WILL HELP US
TO GRASP THE ISSUES AND HELP TO
FORM POLICY TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. WE'RE GONNA HEAR ALSO
FROM LEGAL SCHOLARS AS I
MENTIONED THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO UNDERSTAND THE SPACE WHICH
IN WITH WHICH IN WHICH WE CAN
OPERATE- THAT WILL EXPLAIN THE
RELEVANT EXISTING LEGAL
FRAMEWORKS SECTION TWO THIRTY
MANY OF HERD ALL. OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS DECENCY ACT'S
STEALS THE CENTER OF MANY OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS. IT
PROVIDES SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
IMMUNITY FROM CIVIL OR CRIMINAL
LIABILITY. THE CARD BEING KURD
BY USER STATEMENTS WHILE
EXPLICITLY AUTHORIZING
PLATFORMS TO ENGAGE IN THEIR
OWN CONTENT MODERATION. WITHOUT
RISKING THAT IMMUNITY. ARE
THERE FOR UNDERSTANDING THE LAW
IS GOING TO BE CRITICAL TO HOW
WE CAN. ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE BEFORE US
CONCERNING SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS AND THEIR CONTENT-
WHAT CAN AND SHOULD BE DONE AT
THE STATE LEVEL. GIVEN THE
PREEMPTIVE EFFECTIVE FEDERAL
LAW IT IS A QUESTION THAT WILL
BE EXPLORING. OUR FINAL PANEL
THEY WILL SCHEDULE WHAT IS
ALREADY BEING DONE TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES THE PANELISTS WILL
ADDRESS- BEST PRACTICES OF THE
INDUSTRY WERE MISTAKES HAVE
BEEN MADE. A NUMBER OF INDUSTRY
FOLKS HAVE OF PROVIDED
INFORMATION TO US ABOUT WHAT IS
BEING DONE WHAT CAN BE DONE
MOST IMPORTANT FOR OUR
CONSIDERATION- WE'VE INVITED-
MOST OF THE MAJOR PLATFORMS
MEDIA PLATFORM SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO JOIN US TODAY-
NONE OF TAKEN UP THE OFFER BUT
WE WILL HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION
SPEAK ON BEHALF. OF THE
PLATFORMS. WELL BEFORE WE OF
ALLOW THE PANELISTS TO BEGIN
I'M GOING TO- PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO JOIN
US TODAY- TO MAKE STATEMENTS IF
THEY SHOULD SO CHOOSE- SO LET
ME BEGIN ANYONE WISH TO MAKE A
STATEMENT. THE SENATE CORTESE
SUBSIDY CORTESE RECOGNIZED.
THANK THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I
JUST WANT TO- THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER FIRST OF
ALL- THE ONE BILL IN PARTICULAR
SB FOUR THIRTY FIVE THAT. I
THINK WILL BENEFIT FROM THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HEAR TODAY
AND THEN PERHAPS A QUESTION AND
ANSWERS THAT THE RESULT FROM
INTO THE PRESENTATION SO- I
DON'T KNOW HOW ELSE WE WOULD
CAN BE IN A GATHERED THIS
INFORMATION WITHOUT THE CHAIR
POINTS TOGETHER AND OBVIOUSLY.
I HAD THE BENEFIT OF- BEING
DESIGNATED TO PARTICIPATE ON
THE COMMITTEE FOR TODAY- AND I
THANK YOU FOR THAT AS WELL. BUT
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
PRESENCE PARTICIPATION AND YOUR
INPUT- SEVEN BORDERS WHICH TO
MAKE A COMMENT. I DO WOULD LIKE
TO THANK YOU CHAIR- FOR PUTTING
THIS HEARING ON I KNOW THESE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ARE A
BIT OF A CHALLENGE ESPECIALLY
IS. OUR OFFICES ARE BEING
RELOCATED TO ANOTHER. FACILITY
I HAVE A- KEEN INTEREST IN THE
SOCIAL MEDIA SPACE. ONE THING
IN PARTICULAR I DON'T KNOW IF
WE'RE GOING TO GET INTO TOO
MUCH DETAIL TODAY BUT CERTAINLY
HOPE IN THE FUTURE. IS ARE
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
POLITICAL. SPEECH OBLIGATIONS
OF DISCLOSURE THAT WE SEE AS
CANDIDATES OR AS OFFICE
HOLDERS. WE HAVE TO IDENTIFY-
TO FOLKS THAT READ MATERIAL
THAT WE PUT OUT OR LISTEN ON
THROUGH. VARIOUS OUTLETS- THE
IN THAT THE ENTITY THAT IS
PAYING FOR THIS PARTICULAR
MESSAGE SO I THINK FROM THE
SOCIAL MEDIA STANDPOINT HAVING
TO BE PARTICULARLY HELPFUL IS
FROM MY STANDPOINT- TO EXPLORE
AREAS THAT WOULD FACILITATE
FACILITATE EVEN MORE.
DISCLOSURES BY INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE PROFESSIONALS IN THIS SPACE
AND MAKING CERTAIN THAT AN
AUDIENCE WITH ME ON FACEBOOK OR
ANY OTHER SOCIAL OUTLET
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE BEING
GIVEN INFORMATION. ALL BY
INDIVIDUALS MOTIVATED WITH
PROFIT THING THAT'S PERFECTLY
HEALTHY THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
CENTER BARGES OF SENT A STERN.
BURKE THANK YOU MISTER OUT HOW
ALTHOUGH BROWN THINGS OUT VERY
BRIEFLY HERE I'M REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE PANELISTS AND
THE EXPERTISE THAT YOU MARSHALL
HERE TO A SPECIAL THANKS TO
YOUR STAFF IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER THEY'VE DONE HERE- RIGHT.
I THINK OF. SOCIAL MEDIA. LIKE
ANY GREAT INNOVATION IN
SOCIETY- TAKE FOR INSTANCE THE
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE-
USEFUL TOOL AND IT'S ALLOWED US
TO GET OURSELVES OUT OF-
PREINDUSTRIAL TIMES AND GET
OURSELVES AROUND AND- EXPANDED
THE ECONOMY AND GIVEN US.
ACCESS TO NEW MARKETS AND NEW
LIVES BUT ALSO HAS SOCIAL
EXTERNALITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
IT- POLLUTION IS BEING CAUSED
OVER MANY YEARS AND WE'VE COME
UP WITH ANSWERS TO HOW TO HAVE
USEFUL TOOLS THAT STILL HAVE
SORT OF A FULL CYCLE APPROACH
TO THE PRODUCT THEY'RE PUTTING
OUT THERE AND I THINK. THE
SOCIAL BENEFITS OF THESE
PLATFORMS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE TAKING A CLOSER LOOK AT-
WERE INITIALLY QUITE OBVIOUS TO
ME AS A FRESHMAN AND I GUESS A
SOPHOMORE IN COLLEGE WHEN WEEK
WHEN FACEBOOK WAS JUST A BOOK-
AND THEN IT BECAME A LITTLE
MORE THAN JUST A BOOK- WE
CIRCLE PICTURES OF PEOPLE'S
FACES IN THE BOOK VERSION AND
THEN WE PUT PICTURES ONLINE OF
PEOPLE AND THEN- HERE WE ARE
TODAY WHERE THAT LITTLE
OPERATION IS NOW A GLOBAL FORCE
TO HAVING SIR TO WITNESS THE
BUDDING OF A VERY SMALL THE
TIME BUT VERY BIG IDEA. WITH
MAJOR IMPLICATIONS BUT ALSO IN
A HELPFUL FOR CONNECTING PEOPLE
WHAT- WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
COMPREHENSIVELY LOOK AT. HOW
THESE PLATFORMS ARE IMPACTING
SOCIETY AND ARE WE BEING
THOROUGH IN THE STANDARDS WE
USE TO EVALUATE- THOSE
EXTERNALITIES AND ARE THERE
AREAS WHERE. SIMPLY DEFIES
QUANTIFICATION BUT-
NEVERTHELESS BEARS- BEARS
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE PLATFORMS
THEMSELVES AS OPPOSED TO JUST
THE USER SO I'M HOPING WE CAN
GET INTO SOME OF THOSE DETAILS
ALONG WITH THE- CONVERSATION
FEDERALLY ABOUT TWO THIRTY
REFORM AND WHERE THE STATE FITS
INTO THAT- BUT WE'RE MOVING
PAST PRIVACY I THINK HERE INTO
SOMETHING. THAT'S MUCH LESS SO
ABOUT- WHAT WE DO TO- PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM- INADVERTENTLY
DISCLOSING THINGS THEY DON'T
WANT TO DISCLOSE TO THE FREE
MARKET OF WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
DO WANT TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION AND WHAT EFFECT
THAT HAS- SO THANKS TO LOOK AT
FORTY TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN- AND SENT A COUPLE YEAR
OLD THANK YOU SENATE CAREER FOR
BEING HERE I KNOW THIS IS A
CHALLENGE WE WE'RE CURRENTLY-
IN- INTERIM. RECESS OF SORTS
NOT. NOT REALLY RECESS BUT
WE'RE WORKING IN OUR DISTRICTS
I APPRECIATE. ALL OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE SENATE COVER YOUR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS. OR JUST WANT TO
CHANGE THANK THE CHAIR FOR-
SCHEDULING THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO. TAKE A DEEP DIV. SOME
OF THE STUFF IS COMPLICATED
AND- AS WE LOOK AT NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE ALSO HAVE TO
LOOK AT HOW WE PROTECT PEOPLE
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART OF THIS
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE
JUST A HEADS UP TO THOSE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO COMMENT. WE'RE GOING TO-
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER THE
PANELSHAVE PRESENTED THEIR
TESTIMONY AND AFTER MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE. AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT AND QUESTION THOSE
PANELISTS- SO WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN- WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST PRESENTER. JOHN
DR JOHN DONOVAN. IS THE
RESEARCH DIRECTOR OF THE
SHORENSTEIN CENTER ON MEDIA
POLITICS AND PUBLIC POLICY AT
THE HARVARD KENNEDY SCHOOL. SHE
IS ALSO DIRECTOR OF THE
TECHNOLOGY AND SOCIAL CHANGE
PROJECTS. SHE'S HERE GIVE US
UP. BASICALLY EDITORIAL ON
MECHANICS OF SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS DR DONOVAN I HOPE
YOUR PRESENT. AND HERE. OKAY
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU QUITE WELL
THANK HER DOCTOR DONOVAN FOR
BEING HERE. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FIRST AND FOREMOST
FOR HAVING ME R. AND- THIS IS A
BIT OF AN UNCONVENTIONAL
PRESENTATION THE MECHANICS OF
SOCIAL MEDIA I'M GOING TO GO
THROUGH A LITTLE BIT OF THE
HISTORY OF THE DESIGN AND SOME
OF THESE PLATFORMS. AND KIND OF
TALK ABOUT WHAT THEIR- ACTUAL
CUSTOMERS ARE WHICH ARE
ADVERTISERS AND THEN TALK A BIT
ABOUT THE PROBLEM OF. HOW USERS
GET SUCKED INTO RABBIT HOLES ON
OUR ACROSS DIFFERENT SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS. SO I'M GONNA
TRY TO DO ALL OF THIS WITHIN
ABOUT SIX MINUTES SAUCY HOW IT
GOES- BEFORE THERE WAS MOVE
FAST AND BREAK THINGS THERE WAS
ANOTHER ANIMATING TACTIC FOR
THE TECH INDUSTRY. WAS GET BIG
FAST IT'S PHILOSOPHY IS GROUP
BE GOOD FOR THE INDUSTRY BUT
BAD FOR THE WORLD. OVER THE
LAST DECADE SOCIAL NETWORKING
THAT IS CONNECTING PEOPLE TO
PEOPLE MORE INTO SOCIAL MEDIA
WHICH IS CONNECTING PEOPLE TO
PEOPLE. AND TO CONTENT. WHICH
RESULTED. IN AN EXPONENTIAL
PROFITS AND GROWTH. I DON'T
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SO
NETWORK AND SOCIAL MEDIA BUT
THIS TRANSITION WAS SCHEME TO
PRODUCTS LIKE FACEBOOK TWITTER
AND YOUTUBE DOMINATING GLOBAL
MARKETS AND MASS COMMUNICATION.
IN SHORT NETWORK SO THE WEALTH
OF SOCIETY NETWORKS ARE WHERE
THE RICH AND POWERFUL DERIVE
THEIR IMPORTANCE AND HIGH
STATUS. I'M SAYING HERE SHE IS
CONNECTED WHEN REFERENCING
SOMEONE YOU DON'T KNOW OR DON'T
WANT TO MESS WITH YOU MIGHT
EVEN SAY THAT PERSON IS
CONNECTED WHEN SOCIAL MEDIA IS
THE VECTOR OF ATTACK AGAINST
OUR DEMOCRACY IN PUBLIC HEALTH.
A SMALL GROUP OF HIGHLY
MOTIVATED AND CONNECTED ACTORS
CAN MANIPULATE PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDING OF ANY ISSUES
SIMPLY BY USING THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PRODUCTS AS THEY ARE
DESIGNED THAT IS THEY DON'T
NEED TO. DO ANY- HIGH STAKES
HACKING THEY DON'T NEED A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
TO- CREATE A VERY POLARIZING-
PUBLIC CONVERSATION. HOW SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES GOT BIG BASS
WITH A COMBINATION OF LACKS
CONSUMER REGULATION ISSUING
RISKS BUYING OUT THE
COMPETITION WHERE POSSIBLE AND
A FOCUS ON SCALE THAT MADE VERY
POOR SECURITY DECISIONS. BEYOND
CONNECTING PEOPLE AND CONTENT
PRODUCTS LIKE FACEBOOK YOUTUBE
AND TWITTER RELY ON OTHER
COMPANIES AND INDIVIDUALS TO
BROUGHT PROVIDE THEM WITH MORE
DATA. THAT IS INCREASING THE
SCALE IN THIS MASSIVE AND
SPRAWLING DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
ACROSS THE WEB. MAPPING
TRACKING AND AGGREGATING PEOPLE
SOCIAL NETWORKS NEED SOCIAL
MEDIA A VIABLE BUSINESS BECAUSE
COMPANIES COULD SELL DATA
DERIVED FROM INTERACTIONS. OR
THEY COULD NOT MONETIZE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AS OTHER PRODUCTS
SUCH AS ADVERTISING TARGETED
POST PROMOTED MESSAGES CAME
ONLINE. SOCIAL MEDIA DATA
SHOULD LEGALLY BE DEFINED AT
SOME POINT BUT FOR NOW I'M
REFERRING TO INFORMATION ABOUT
PEOPLE HOW THEY BEHAVE ONLINE
INTERACTIONS WITH PEOPLE AND
CONTENT AND LOCATION TACTIC.
BUT IT WASN'T ENOUGH JUST TO
COLLECT DATA AND SORT DATA ON
THESE PRODUCTS TARGETED
ADVERTISING AND DATA SERVICES
ONLY BECAME USEFUL WHEN PAIRED
WITH OTHER KINDS OF DATA. FOR
EXAMPLE IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWELVE WHEN LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT MODELS FROM
MONETIZING FACEBOOK ZUCKERBERG
WROTE IN A COMPANY EMAIL THAT
ALLOWING DEVELOPERS ACCESS TO
DATA WITHOUT HAVING THESE
COMPANIES SHARE THEIR DATA WITH
FACEBOOK WOULD BE QUOTE GOOD
FOR THE WORLD BUT BAD FOR US
END QUOTE. THIS IS BECAUSE
FACEBOOK KNEW EVEN BACK THEN
THAT THEIR PRODUCTS COULD
THREATEN PRIVACY ON A SCALE
SOCIETY HAS NEVER RECKONED WITH
BEFORE NOW THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PRODUCTS THAT FAVOUR RUN AWAY
SCALE AND OPENNESS THREATEN NOT
ONLY OUR INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS BUT
ALSO THE FUTURE OF DEMOCRACY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH. BY
LEVERAGING PEOPLE'S NETWORKS
AND CONTENT AT THE SAME TIME A
BUSINESS MODEL EMERGED FOR KEY
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS
INCLUDED. ONE GROCERY DAILY AND
MONTHLY ACTIVE USERS CHU
INCREASING ENGAGEMENT METRICS
AND FREE ADVERTISING REVENUE.
ALLOW DECADE BEEN MARKED BY
THESE COMPANIES EXPANDING
EXPONENTIALLY ALL OF THESE
INDICATORS. IN PC MAGAZINE FROM
TWENTY ELEVEN ABOUT THE BEST
MOBILE APPS. FACEBOOK AND
TWITTER WERE BOTH RANKED LOWER
THAN A APP THAT TURNS YOUR
CAMERA INTO A FLASHLIGHT. IN
TWENTY ELEVEN TWITTER AT
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED MILLION
USERS FACEBOOK HAD EIGHTY.
EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
MILLION AND EUGENE HAD ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND USERS BY
TWENTY TWENTY RIVER TWITTER HAS
REPORTED THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE MILLION USERS
FACEBOOK HAS REPORTED TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION ACTIVE USERS. AND
THERE'S TWO POINT TWO NINE
BILLION FOR YOU TO ADVERTISING
REVENUE CONTINUED TO GROW
ACROSS ALL OF THESE PRODUCTS
WERE GLOBAL I WAS MAKING
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX BILLION AND FACEBOOK
IS MAKING APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
FOUR BILLION. I IN ADVERTISING
REVENUE AND THESE TWO COMPANIES
DOMINATE MOST OF THE
ADVERTISING INDUSTRY ONLINE AND
AS A RESULT THEIR PRODUCTS
REALLY DO YOU FAVOR
ADVERTISERS. OVER USER SINCE I
CANNOT QUITE A BIT OF EXTRA
DATA IN ORDER TO- MAKE THEIR
PRODUCTS- MORE INTERESTING AND
VIABLE FOR ADVERTISERS. USING
ACCOUNTS IS A KEY PERFORMANCE
INDICATOR DROVE A SHADOW
INDUSTRY OF GROWTH HACKING
WHICH WAS EVENTUALLY INTEGRATED
DIRECTLY INTO THE PRODUCTS
ALLOWING A MASSIVE ANY KNOWN
VULNERABILITY OF SOCK PUPPETS
THAT IS BIG ACCOUNTS 2% FOR
THOSE WHO UNDERSTOOD HOW TO
MANIPULATETHIS VULNERABILITY
INCREASING ENGAGEMENT.
DELIVERING MORE NOVEL AN
OUTRAGEOUS CONTENT WHICH IS WHY
FALSE NEWS HARASSMENT GET
DEFAMATION. THRIVE ON SOCIAL
MEDIA FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES DECISIONS ABOUT
PROFIT DRIVE INNOVATION NOT
HIGHER PRINCIPLES LIKE ACCESS
TO TRUTH JUSTICE OR DEMOCRACY.
AS A RESULT THESE PRODUCTS ARE
NOT ONLY A PARASITE ON OUR
SOCIAL NETWORKS FEEDING OFF
EVERY CLICK LIKE AND SHARE BUT
THEY ALSO CANNOT OPTIMIZE FOR
THE PUBLIC INTEREST. EIGHT AND
IT DIDN'T HAVE TO BE THIS WAY
BACK IN TWENTY ELEVEN MOBILE IS
DEVELOPING QUICKLY AND THERE
ARE MANY WAYS IN WHICH SOCIAL
MEDIA COULD HAVE BEEN DESIGNED
TO FOSTER COMMUNITY SAFETY. AND
TO MAXIMIZE PRIVACY INSTEAD THE
DRIVE TO MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF
USERS ENGAGEMENT AND READ AND
READ THAT NOW HAS LED US HERE.
MOST CRUCIALLY THE ENTIRE
INTERNET INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
AN OVERHAUL SO THAT COMPANIES
ARE NOT ABLE TO SIPHON DATA AND
LEVERAGE IT TO MAXIMIZE NEED
MANSIONS OVER CONSUMERS. BUT
USERS ARE NOT NECESSARILY THE
CUSTOMERS ADVERTISERS ARE
STRUCTURE OF ONLINE ADVERTISING
QUITE PLAIN SYSTEMATICALLY
ADVANTAGES THESE COMPANIES AT
THE EXPENSE OF SEVERAL OTHER
INDUSTRIES MOST IMPORTANTLY
JOURNALISM. BY BECOMING THE
GATEWAY TO MU MU'S AUDIENCES
TOP SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES FOR
ADVERTISING REVENUE THAT
BELONGS TO THOSE WHO CREATE
ENGAGING CONTENT FOR DISPLAY ON
THEIR PRODUCTS. MOST NOTABLY
JOURNALISTS. WHEN CHRIS ABOUT
THE SCHOOL THEIR PREY OF ON
YOUR- FACEBOOK AND GOOGLE WHERE
SITE THEIR VARIOUS MUSICIANS
THESE INITIATIVES PICK AND
CHOOSE PARTNERS AND THEN
CHANNEL JOURNALIST LABOR
DIRECTLY BACK INTO THEIR OWN
PRODUCTS. FACEBOOK'S FACT
CHECKING PROGRAM FOR INSTANCE
PARTNERS WITH SEVERAL REPUTABLE
NEWS OUTLETS. BUT LABELING HAS
DONE LITTLE TO DIS INCENTIVIZE
FAKE NAILS MOREOVER FACT
CHECKING IS AN ADHOC- MEASURE
AND WILL NEVER RIVAL SUPPORTING
INDEPENDENT. INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISM A BEDROCK OF THE
STRONG DEMOCRACY INSTEAD THIS
INITIATIVE EXPANDS FACEBOOK'S
EVER GROWING WEB OF INFLUENCE
OVER HERE AS IT BECOMES
INCREASINGLY MORE DIFFICULT TO
CRITICIZE THE CORPORATION FOR
FEAR OF LOSING. RESOURCES
NEVERTHELESS IS JOURNALISM
WAYNE'S SOCIAL MEDIA SERVICE
MISINFORMATION AT SCALE TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DAILY
ACTIVE USERS INSTANTANEOUSLY
ESPECIALLY ODIOUS WHEN
MISINFORMATION IS PROMOTED IN
TRENDS AND RECOMMENDATIONS. IN
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY I
TESTIFIED ABOUT CONSPIRACY AS
MISINFORMATION HAVING SIMILAR
ARTICLE SOCIETY SOCIETAL
IMPACTS AND SECONDHAND SMOKE.
POST TWENTY TWENTY WE SEE
MISINFORMATION AT SCALES DEADLY
EFFECTS IN THE U. S. AS WELL
SCAMMERS AND GRIFTERS USE
SOCIAL MEDIA TO SELL BOGUS
PRODUCTS. AND PUSH CONSPIRACIES
INCLUDING MONETIZING THE
PANDEMIC IN GROTESQUE WAYS TO
SELL SPEAKERS OR TO SCARE
MONGER. GOING INTO THE PANDEMIC
ANTI VACCINATION ACTIVISTS HAD
A HUGE ADVANTAGE OVER PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS. BECAUSE ANTI
VACCINATION ACTIVISTS WERE ABLE
TO LEVERAGE ALREADY DENSE AND
SPRAWLING NETWORKS ACROSS
SOCIAL MEDIA. AS A RESULT
RESULT IN A TAX ATTACHED
THERE'S BREAKS TO BREAKING NEWS
CYCLES BY ATTACKING PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN SCIENCE. THERE
WAS NO AND THERE WAS NOTHING
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS COULD
DO TO STOP THE TORRENT OF
MISINFORMATION. TRENDING
DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS AS
EVIDENCED BY THE REPORTING OF
BRAINTEASER DRAWN STAND BEN.
COLLINS SENIOR. SAME SITUATION
HOLD FOR PUBLIC SERVANTS LIKE
ELECT OFFICIAL WILL CONTINUE TO
BE THE COST OF ELECT DECEMBER.
AND ARE LEAVING THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE IT'S ME BECAUSE
MANAGING MISINFORMATION AT
SCALE IS COMPLETELY
UNSUSTAINABLE. FOR JOURNALISTS
RESEARCHERS AND EVERYONE TRYING
TO MITIGATE MISINFORMATION THE
EXPERIENCE IS LIKE TRYING TO
PUT YOUR HANDS UP AGAINST THE
GROWING OCEAN SWELL AS IT
WASHES OVER YOU. JOURNALIST
UNIVERSITIES PUBLIC SERVICE AND
ARE HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
TAKE ON THE TRUE COST OF
MISINFORMATION SCALE WHICH IS-
WHICH ISN'T JUST AN EXISTENTIAL
STATEMENT. THE END OF RESOURCES
LOS TO MITIGATING
MISINFORMATION AT SCALE WHERE
THE COST OF DOING NOTHING IT'S
EVEN WORSE FOR EXAMPLE TAKE A
BLATANT LIE THAT VACCINES HAVE
MICROCHIPS TO COUNTER IT
JOURNALIST. TRADED OFF COVERING
OTHER STORIES WERE PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS CONTINUE
EXPLAINED THAT THERE ARE NO
MICROCHIPS I IN THE VACCINE.
THE ONLY WAY TO FIX A PROBLEM
LIKE MOTIVATED MISINFORMATION
XSCALE INVOLVES CLAPBOARDS AND
BURRITT ENFORCING EARNED
SIXTEEN POLICIES. RESEARCHERS
AND JOURNALISTS WORKING
TOGETHER IT'S TECH WATCHDOGS
AND POLICY MAKING YOUR- OPENING
AWAY FOR A PUBLIC INTEREST
INTERNET. REGULATOR SHOULD
INTRODUCE PUBLIC INTEREST
OBLIGATIONS TO SOCIAL MEDIA
NEWSFEEDS AND TIMELINES SO THAT
TIMELY LOCAL RELEVANT AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION REACHES
THE MASSES. SCALE TOGETHER WE
MUST MAKE A PUBLIC INTEREST
INTERNET A WHOLE OF SOCIETY-
PRIORITY. BUT WHAT I'VE LEARNED
ABOUT STUDYING THE INTERNET
OVER THE LAST DECADE IS FAIRLY
SIMPLE EVERYTHING OPEN WILL BE
EXPLOITED THERE'S NOTHING
PARTICULARLY NEW ABOUT
MISINFORMATION CONSPIRACIES
CIRCULATING AFTER ALL THERE'S
NO COMMUNICATION WITHOUT
MISINFORMATION. HOWEVER OVER
THE LAST DECADE THE DESIGN OF
SOCIAL MEDIA ITSELF CREATED
FAVORABLE CONDITIONS FOR
REACHING MILLIONS
INSTANTANEOUSLY WHILE ALSO
INCORPORATING FINANCIAL AND
POLITICAL EXEMPTION. FOR
CONDUCTING MASSIVE MEDIA
MANIPULATION CAMPAIGNS THE MOST
DANGEROUS ASPECTS OF THESE
PRODUCTS COME TO LIGHT WHEN WE
ANALYZED- JAMES AN ADVANTAGE
WHEN OPENNESS NEED SCALE- WELL
SOME MAY DEBATE THE D.
EXISTENCE OF THE RABBIT HOLE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA OUR RESEARCH UNIT
SHORENSTEIN HAS BEEN LOOKING
DEEPER AT THIS PHENOMENON.
GOING DOWN THE RABBIT HOLE
MEANS GETTING PULLED INTO
ONLINE COMMUNITIES ARE SUB
CULTURES WHERE THE SLAYING
VALUES NORMS AND PRACTICES ARE
UNFAMILIAR BUT NEVERTHELESS
COMPLETELY ENGROSSING.
THEREFORE ASPECTS OF THE DESIGN
OF SOCIAL MEDIA THAT LEADS
SOMEONE DOWN THE RABBIT HOLE.
INCLUDING ABOUT A MINUTE-
REPUTATION WHICH IS A KEY
FEATURE THAT RELATES TO SEEING
THE SAME THING OVER AND OVER ON
A SINGLE PRODUCT. REDUNDANCY IS
SEEING THE SAME THING ACROSS
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS
RESPONSIVENESS IS HOW SOCIAL
MEDIA AND SEARCH ENGINES ALWAYS
PROVIDES SOME ANSWER UNLIKE
OTHER FORMS OF MEDIA SO IF YOU
ASK YOUR- SEARCH ENGINE WHAT IS
Q. AN HONOR WHAT IS-
ELECTROMAGNETIC VACCINES. YOU
REINFORCEMENT IS THE WAY THAT
ALGORITHMS WORK TO CONNECT
PEOPLE AND CONTENT SO THAT ONCE
YOU SEARCH FOR A SLOGAN OR
KEYWORD ALGORITHMS WILL
REINFORCE THESE INTERESTS. SO
REPETITION REDUNDANCY
RESPONSIVENESS AND
REINFORCEMENT ARE KEY ASPECTS
OF THE DESIGN OF SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS MAKE KEEP PEOPLE.
STUCK IN THESE RABBIT HOLES
WHERE THEY ARE I CONSISTENTLY
RE INTRODUCED TO- NOXIOUS
CONSPIRACY THEORIES IDEAS ARE
MEANS LIKE CRACKING VACCINES
CAUSE AUTISM OR OUT WILD AND
OUTLANDISH CLAIMS. BY C.
COMMUNITIES LIKE YOU AND I THE
ACT I JFK GONNA RIDE FROM THE
DEAD AND SCREENS DAHLE TRUMP-
BUT WHAT'S AND- HERE IS ABOUT
THE WAY IN WHICH THE RABBIT
HOLE WAS USED TO. BUILD OUR
FIRST TOP THE STEEL AND WHAT'S
REALLY AREN'T THAT IMPORTANT IS
THAT WE KNOW THAT FACEBOOK ALSO
KNEW. THAT THEIR STOCK THE
STEEL GROUPS WERE GROWING
EXPONENTIALLY ON THEIR
PLATFORMS AND ADDS SOME OF THIS
CONTENT TO WAS VIOLENT AND
EXCITING AND FACEBOOK
STRUGGLED. TO REMOVE THAT
CONTENT BECAUSE OF THIS SHEER
SCALE AND VOLUME AT WHICH IT
WAS ARE CURRENTLY.
MISINFORMATION IS A SCARE AT
SCALE IS A FEATURE OF FACEBOOK
SOUND DESIGN AND IT'S NOT
EASILY ROUTED OUT. AND BECAUSE
FACEBOOK DEFINES THE PROBLEM OF
MISINFORMATION AT SCALE IS ONE
OF COORDINATED INAUTHENTIC
BEHAVIOR THEY WERE WOEFULLY
UNPREPARED TO HANDLE THE
THREATS POSED BY THEIR OWN
PRODUCTS. BUT I'M HOPEFUL THAT
ANOTHER FUTURE IS POSSIBLE IF
TECH COMPANIES REGULATORS
RESEARCHERS AND ADVOCACY IN THE
WORK TOGETHER TO BUILD THE
PUBLIC INTEREST INTERNET
MODELED ON THE PRINCIPLES THAT
THE PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT ACCESS.
ACCURATE INFORMATION ON DEMAND.%
MAN I DO BELIEVE THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO BRING THE SCOURGE OF
MISINFORMATION AT SCALE. TO AN
END THANK YOU. THANK YOU- DR
DON. FONG QUESTIONS COME. SAYS.
THANK YOU MISTER EIGHT I WANTED
NOTED THAT SENATOR PAN- ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES IS TUNING IN
LIVE HERE IT WAS IN ABLE TO
JOIN US IN PERSON BUT- HAS BEEN
WORKING ON. MISINFORMATION
ISSUES AND DISINFORMATION
ISSUES FOR NUMBER YEARS- SO IF
I CAN CHANNEL ONE OF HIS
QUESTIONS HERE TO THE PANELIST-
SHOULD POLICY MAKERS EXPECT
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES TO
DETERMINE WHAT OUR CONSPIRACIES
OR MISINFORMATION PROMOTED ON
THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA FEEDS-
SHOULD THIS BE A SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY IN YOUR VIEW. OR
EVEN AN INDUSTRY IT HAS TO BE A
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY I'LL TELL
YOU ARE WE FOLLOWING THE Q.
ANON COMMENT ON FOR QUITE A
LONG TIME BEFORE IT. WE BECAME
A MASSIVE PHENOMENON. AND STILL
THERE ARE POINTS ALONG THE WAY
THAT IT IF YOU DO SPECIALIZE IN
UNDERSTANDING THESE DIFFERENT
SUBCULTURES YOU CAN UNDERSTAND.
THE MOMENTS WHEN THEY BEGIN TO
GROW THE MOMENTS WHEN THEY
START TO GET MORE AND MORE
ATTENTION- BUTTE COUNTY MAN-
FIGURE OUT TO SOME DEGREE
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE PLANNING
FOR MASS VIOLENT EVENTS. IT WAS
NO SURPRISE TO ANY RESEARCHER
JOURNALIST THAT WAS COVERING-
MAGGA AFTER THE ELECTION THAT
THERE WAS GOING TO BE AN
INCIDENT AT THE CAPITOL PEOPLE
KNEW THAT THE CAPITAL WAS GONNA
BE STORMED- BUT IT DOES TAKE A
VERY STATUS ACTUALIZED OF
KNOWLEDGE WHERE PEOPLE ARE.
RESEARCHING AND WATCHING THESE-
THESE THESE PHENOMENON
DEVELOPED AND IT'S REALLY A
PROBLEM OF SCALE THAT IF YOU
THINK ABOUT SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS THERE REALLY LIKE-
BOOMBOXES. THE CONTENT IS THE
CASSETTE TAPE THAT GOES IN THEM
AND THEN OUR ALGORITHMS ON THE
VOLUME THAT DRIVES. HOW MANY
PEOPLE END UP HEARING IT SUIT
YOU SHOULD REALLY THINK ABOUT
THEM. I IN THAT WAY AND THINK
ABOUT WELL WHO TURNS THE VOLUME
AND RIGHT NOW IT'S PLATFORM
COMPANIES. WHO TEND TO TURN THE
VOLUME UP ON THINGS THAT ARE
NOT WHEN OUTRAGEOUS- WHICH NOW
WE CAN TELL MOBILIZES PEOPLE TO
DO THINGS OFF PLATFORM BUT SO
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM YOU IS-
WHEN I WHEN YOU SAY IT SHOULD
BE BORNE BY SOCIETY AND LARGER
SOCIAL COST. ARE YOU SAYING BY-
BY THE COMPANIES THEMSELVES-
BECAUSE THERE THE VOLUME
CONTROLLERS ARE YOU SAYING BY.
BY GOVERNMENT OR SOME OTHER
PUBLIC KIND OF INSTITUTION. I
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE- A
PUBLIC AGENCY THAT LOOKS OUT
FOR THIS. KIND OF CONTENT
WHETHER IT'S RUN BY THE
GOVERNMENTS ARE. CONTRACTED IN
SOME WAY TO HAVE CIVIL SOCIETY.
OUR WORK ON THAT ASPECT. BY AND
LARGE LOOKING MEANS LIABILITY
WITHIN THESE COMPANIES SO THERE
ARE NO WAY INCENTIVIZE TO SEEK
OUT. THE BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY IS WE SAW A FAIR AMOUNT
OF- DOMESTIC. DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS IN TWENTY TWENTY
WHERE IS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN- WE
SAW MORE FOREIGN INFLUENCE AN
ANONYMOUS. I TAX AND SO I DO
THINK THAT THIS. DATE THE IT IS
THE TIME NOW FOR SOME FORM OF
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT ESPECIALLY
WHEN. THESE THESE MANIPULATORS
ARE USING FAKE ACCOUNTS ARE
THERE USING ADVERTISING THAT'S
BUILT INTO THE PLATFORM. THERE
ARE USING LOOKALIKE AUDIENCES
IN ORDER TO TARGET- VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IT'S REALLY A DUTY
OF CARE THAT THE GOVERNMENT
AND- MEASURES FOR YOU WE ALSO
HAVE TO HAVE REGULATION THAT.
HAS SOME KIND OF MEASURES OF
TRANSPARENCY ANNOUNCER THERE'S
THESE COMPANIES STARTED JUMPING
BUT I DID WANT TO PULL ON ONE
THREAD YOU SAID LOOKING MEANS
LIABILITY CAN YOU CAN YOU
EXPLAIN FURTHER WHAT YOU MEAN
BY THAT. WELL YOU CAN SEE WITH
THE FACEBOOK WHISTLEBLOWER
LEAKS THESE ARE MASSIVE TROVE
OF DOCUMENTS THAT THEY DID NOT
WANT THE PUBLIC TO SEE. AND
MADE CERTAINLY DID NOT WANT THE
SEC OR THE FTC TO BE LOOKING AT
THESE DOCUMENTS BECAUSE THEY
ARE FOR IT PROVIDES THE BASIS
OF SHARED BACK. IN ONE OF THOSE
DOCUMENTS WHERE THEY ARE
FACEBOOK ITSELF SET UP A DUMMY
ACCOUNT NAMED CAROL WITHIN A
COUPLE OF DAYS SHE'S GETTING
SERVED. AT CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AND THEN- WITHIN A WEEK SHE WAS
GETTING Q. ONE ON CONTENT AND
ALL THAT ACCOUNT TO DONE WAS
LIKE CONSERVATIVE ACCOUNTS. AND
LIKE CONSERVATIVE NEWS
ORGANIZATION. AND THE ALGORITHM-
FACEBOOK ARRAY. SYSTEM WHAT IN
SAN. I THE SPREAD OF THIS-
THESE CONSPIRACY THEORIES TO
THIS VERY UNIQUE POPULATION
AND- DO YOU THINK THERE'S THEIR
ACTUAL COULD BEAR LEGAL
LIABILITY UNDER SOME NEGLIGENCE
OR- SOME OTHER SORT OF. CLASS
ACTION HORROR MOVIE- IF THEY'RE
SHOWING SORT OF A WILLFUL
DISREGARD FOR. THE FORESEEABLE
RISKS TO THEIR USERS. YOU
MENTION OKAY IT MIGHT NOT
NECESSARILY BE THEIR CONSPIRACY
CONTENT BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
SUICIDE AND SELF HARM. I THEY
DO COMPANIES DO WORK VERY HARD
TO MAKE SURE THAT- EATING
DISORDER CONTENT IS NOT. SHOWN
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE LOOKING FOR A
AS WELL AS SUICIDE IS SOMETHING
THAT PEOPLE WILL NOT LOOK UP
ONLINE OR DIFFERENT METHODS ARE
AHEAD OF TIME SO. THE COMPANIES
ARE PARTICULARLY FACEBOOK AND
TRIED TO- REMEDY THAT
SITUATION- BUT IT'S NOT ALWAYS
PERFECT ESPECIALLY ON INSTAGRAM
AND SO THE MORE WE KNOW ABOUT
HOW THESE ALGORITHMS WORK AND
HOW THEY- AND- INSPIRE CERTAIN
KINDS OF BEHAVIOR AND SITE
CERTAIN KINDS OF PUBLIC
UPRISINGS. THE BETTER OFF WE'RE
GOING TO BE AS A SOCIETY IF WE
CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE HOSE
HARMS COME FROM AND- AND IF THE
PENALTIES DON'T ALREADY EXIST
ARE. THEY MAY HAVE TO BE- YOU
KNOW- LOADED ON DOWN THE LINE
THE OTHER THING I'LL SAY IS THE
ADVERTISING ON THERE'S A
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF. ADVERTISING
THROUGH THESE PLATFORMS BUT IN
PARTICULAR FACEBOOK THE
BEGINNING OF A PANDEMIC WE SAW
A LOT OF- AND PVDF MASKS AND
OUR LOTS IN OUR HAND SANITIZER.
INSURANCE AND A LOT OF THESE
WERE BOGUS ADVERTISING. I AND
SO WHAT. WE KNOW NOW IS THAT
THE BECAUSE FACEBOOK DOESN'T
REALLY WORK MY IN THE WAY OF
THEIR- OF WHO ARE. ARE WHAT
YOUR BUSINESS IS AND IN ORDER
TO. DO ADVERTISING WE ALSO NEED
TO HAVE MUCH MORE TRANSPARENCY.
ON THAT END AS WELL. I'LL JUST
RAPPERS CHURNED IN DEFERRED
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE BUT- I
DID WANT TO NOTE AND SEE IN IN
YOUR IN YOUR FURTHER COMMENTS
AND ASSURANCE DEAN THE CENTER
YOU YOU'RE PART OF PUT OUT. A
NUMBER OF REPORTS ON-
QUANTIFYING THE SOCIAL
EXTERNALITIES SO YOU'RE SAYING
YOU KNOW WHERE THESE HARMS COME
FROM BUT HOW MUCH HARM. AND
GETTING TO SOME KIND OF
QUANTIFIABLE OR QUALITATIVE
METRICS FOR- WHAT THE ACTUAL
NEGATIVE EXTERNALITIES OF THESE
NETWORK EFFECTS ARE IF YOU
WILL- THINK DELIVER ME OR ONE
OF YOUR COLLEAGUES. WROTE THAT
IT WAS A FORMER OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT DO YOU HAVE.
IT EITHER NOW WERE IN FUTURE
COMMENTS ANY- THOUGHTS ON THIS
ENDEAVOR OF ACTUALLY STARTING
TO HAVE SOME COMMON ACCOUNTING
STANDARDS FOR WHAT SOCIAL
EXTERNALITIES ARE AND TRYING TO
GET DISCLOSURE IN THAT WAY A
LITTLE MORE UNIFORMS SO THAT WE
CAN. KIND OF APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARECARDS PLATFORMS OR EVEN
ACROSS FARMS- AND HEAVY DEBT
DEAL BETTER WITH CHILD ****
THAN THEY HAVE FOR POLITICAL
DISINFORMATION IF THEY
STRUGGLED MORE WITH- Q. AND ON
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES BUT
DONE A BETTER JOB AT- HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ISSUES OR- ACTIVE
YOU KNOW- IT INSTANCES OF
GENOCIDE THAT WE'VE SEEN- DOWN
IN. WITH THE ROHINGYA THEY'VE
HAVE THEY STARTED TO FERRET OUT
THOSE SORT OF ACTIVE CALLS FOR
VIOLENCE I DON'T HAVE A SENSE
OF SORT OF HOW THE PLATFORMS
ARE ASSESSING THOSE RISKS BUT
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU ALL. HAVE
DONE SOME WORK IN THAT REGARD
SO WOULD LOVE YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT NOW WE'RE
GOING FORWARD. THANK YEAH SO
WE'RE STARTING TO WRITE ABOUT
THAT WE HAVE A CONFERENCE
COMING UP IN MARCH WE'RE GONNA
BRING IN CLIMATE. SCIENTISTS
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT HOW DO YOU
YOU WANT. THE COST ACCORDING
CHANGE AND- GOOD FOR BURKE-
BURKE DISEASE FOR FRAMEWORK
THAT WERE LOOK INTO ONES LIKE
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE COST OF
CANCER. AREN'T TO SOCIETY AND
TO THE LABOR FORCE AND WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT IT PER SECTOR
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE COST OF
MISINFORMATION AT SCALE WHEN
MANY- LARGE NEWS RENTS HAVE TO
BRING ON A DISINFORMATION
REPORTER OR TWO OR THREE. I AND
YOU SEE THAT OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS IT'S POPPED UP IN A BUNCH
OF DIFFERENT. ART NEWS ROUNDS
AND THEN OF COURSE LOCAL NEWS
OPERATIONS ARE NOT ABLE TO
FULLY ARMED BRING ON
DISINFORMATION. REPORTERS BY.
THE MORE WE SEE DISINFORMATION
TARGETING LOCAL ELECTIONS AND
HAPPENING ON A- VERY SMALL
SCALE LIKE KERN THE CASE OF
WHAT HAPPENED TO MICHAEL TUBBS
IN STOCKTON WHERE THERE WAS A-
A FACEBOOK PAGE THAT WAS REALLY
DRIVING THIS IDEA THAT HE WAS A
VERY CORRUPT. PERSON BUT WE
HAVE TO DO MORE RESEARCH ON
THAT AND WE ARE REALLY. AT THE
FOREFRONT OF BEGINNING- TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WATER THE
QUANTITATIVE MEASURES THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO USE ARE
IN ORDER TO ENGAGE IN SURVEY
FOR INSTANCE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS. RIGHT NOW WHAT WE
KNOW IS EVERYBODY'S QUITTING.
ALEXION OFFICIALS ARE QUITTING.
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE
QUITTING AND ONE OF THE BIG
REASONS IS THAT THEY CAN'T KEEP
UP WITH THE FLOW-
MISINFORMATION. AND AS WELL IT
TAKES A IN OUR PERSONAL TOLL ON
THEM ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE
BEING TARGETED WE ALSO SEE A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE- RESIGNING FROM
POSITIONS ON SCHOOL BOARDS FOR
INSTANCE BECAUSE OF THE
TARGETING. AROUND JOHN CRITICAL
RACE THEORY AND TEACHING BRINGS
AND RACISM ARE TEACHING
CHILDREN ABOUT RACE AND RACISM.
AND SAID THESE ARE BIG SOCIETY
WIDE STRUGGLES AREN'T THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE SOLVED BY
CREATING NEW TECHNOLOGY THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE SOLVED. BY-
FIXING. BUT WE DO HAVE TO HAVE
THE TECH SECTOR- SB WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THE TECH SECTOR MUCH
BETTER AND WE HAVE TO EVEN
EXPLORE IDEAS LIKE ANTI TRUST
IN A WAY THAT- MAY SPLIT
ADVERTISING FROM THE OTHER
FUNCTIONS OF TECH COMPANIES.
AREN'T SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT OUR ADVERTISING COMPANY IS
ARE SPREADING THE WEALTH AROUND
TOO I IN PARTICULAR JOURNALISM
OROTHER WEB PAGES. AND SO ON
IN SHORT WE DON'T QUITE KNOW
YET WHAT THE TRUE COST OF
MISINFORMATION ARE BUT IT IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
AND I'M HOPEFUL BY EARLY NEXT
YEAR WE'LL HAVE. A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT MODELS AND FRAMEWORKS
THAT WE CAN WORK WITH. I AND
THEY'LL BE CALLED POLICE AND
DISSERTATIONS AND WHAT NOT TO
TAKE UP THAT. PROBLEM THANK YOU
OTHER COMMENTS THIS CYNICAL
EURO. WHAT I WANTED- THANK THE-
THANK THE DOCTOR FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND FOR HER HER TESTIMONY
I WHAT STRUCK ME WAS THE
STATEMENT THAT THE CUSTOMERS A
FACEBOOK AND- THESE THAT.
SOCIAL PLATFORMS ARE THE COST
ARE THE ADVERTISERS BECAUSE
THAT TOTALLY CHEFS- THE WAY
THAT I THINK OF- OF REGULATION
AND HOW WE WOULD LOOK AT. THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
CONTENT AND HOW IT'S BEING
PERVADE- SO THAT THAT WAS
REALLY VERY INTERESTING AND
THEN I AM I THE ONLY QUESTION I
HAVE. IS THAT- IF HE YOU KNOW
IT IT IT APPEARS THAT AND THERE
HAS BEEN SOME DISCUSSION AROUND
THE ALGORITHMS AND SHARING
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THOSE
ALGORITHMS ARE CREATED FROM AT
THE STATE LEVEL- WE HIRED A
COMPANY WITH A CONTRACT TO DO
SMALL BUSINESS. GRANTS AND IT
WAS BASED ON AN ALGORITHM AND
IT WAS TRUST ME WE'RE GOING TO
GET TO THE RIGHT. BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED AND-
AND I THINK THAT IT'S PROVEN TO
BE THE CASE BUT I THE QUESTION
I HAVE IS. IS THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT GETTING MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THE
ALGORITHMS ARE ARE CREATED. AND
AND THAT THEIR PROPRIETARY SO
WE CAN'T REALLY TELL YOU BUT
TRUST US YOU KNOW IT'S GOING TO
WORK OKAY AND IT IT APPEARS TO
ME THAT. THAT IT THAT IT'S THE
ALGORITHMS THAT CREATED THIS
CONTENT THAT SHOWED UP ON THE
CAROL SIDE I GUESS WAS THE NAME
OF THE OF THE PERSON THAT THEY
CREATED. AND THEN I JUST.
WONDER IF YOU CAN COMMENT ON.
ON HOW WE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT ALGORITHMS AND WILL BE IN
A WEEK WE WHICH I TEND TO GIVE
GREAT DEFERENCE TO- TO
CONFIDENCE INTO THINGS THAT ARE
PART OF THE PROPRIETY IN FOR
INFORMATION THAT THE COMPANY'S
USE BUT IT MAY BE THAT WE NEED
TO LOOK AT THIS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY AS WELL. YES SO THE
ALGORITHMS YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT. YOU KNOW STATE SPOKE
NICK CLEGG RECENTLY CAME OUT
AND SAID THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
ALGORITHMS RUNNING ACROSS
FACEBOOK. INTO IT'S NOT A CASE
THAT IN. AN ALGORITHM DOES THIS
YOU KNOW ALL OF THE THINGS WHAT
WE EAT WHAT YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
IS THE FACT THAT. MANY
DIFFERENT I TECHNOLOGICAL
PIECES LIKE CAST. MEMBER THE
OLD STEREOS WE USED TO HAVE THE
OF THE RECEIVER IN THE RECORD
PLAYER YOU HAVE THAT CONSENT
ACT. SO THINK ABOUT IT LIKE A
COMPONENT SYSTEM. AND DIFFERENT
ALGORITHMS ARE GOING. OUT RAINY
CONTENTS AND SORT CONTENT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. AND WHAT THE
RANKING IS BASED ON IS ARE.
THESE LITTLE DIALS OR KNOBS
THAT THEY TURN. WHERE FOR
INSTANCE AT FACEBOOK THEY-
AFTER JANUARY SIXTH. TURNED OUT
THE KNOB THAT- ON NEWS QUALITY.
AND SO IT'S NOT THE CASE THAT
THE ALGORITHM WAS READING EVERY
PIECE OF NEWS BECAUSE
ALGORITHMS CAN'T TELL YOU
WHAT'S TRUE OR FALSE OR WHAT'S
LEFT OR RIGHT. BUT WHAT IT DID
WAS IT IT TOOK INTO ACCOUNT.
HOW ARE REPUTABLE IS THIS NEWS
ORGANIZATION IS IT WIDELY
TRUSTED DOES IT. HAVE AN OFFICE
SPACES A HABIT SUBSCRIBERS IS
IT- LET YOU KNOW ARE THERE ARE
ITS ADVERTISERS ON THE UP AND
UP. ON AND IT INCREASED NEWS
QUALITY AND THROUGHOUT THE SITE
WHAT YOU SAW. WAS THAT IT LOST
BASED BURKE ENGAGEMENT BECAUSE
THE CONTENT WASN'T AS
CONTROVERSIAL. PEOPLE WEREN'T
SHARING SOME OF THE CONTENT
BECAUSE- FOR INSTANCE THE NEW
YORK TIMES IS A PAY WALL SO WHY
WOULD YOU SHARE THEIR ARTICLES.
IF YOU'RE NOT SURE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO GET
THEM CAN EVEN SEE THEM. AND SO
IT TENDS TO DO REALLY WELL ON
THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS IS
THINGS THAT ARE FREE. AND
THINGS THAT ARE OUTRAGEOUS. AND
SO- IT TIME FOR BUT ONE THAT
YOU MAY THINK OF RELATED TO THE
POWER ABOUT BUT- HERE. IS A MAN
ON YOU CRANSTON'S IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I WAS INVOLVED IN THE
STUDY OUR STATE AND SOCIETY ON
THE ALTERNATIVE INFLUENCE
NETWORK WHAT WE SHOWED WAS
BASICALLY THAT. A VERY SMALL
PROPORTION OF WHITE
SUPREMACISTS WERE GETTING. A
LOT OF ATTENTION ACROSS THE
APPS AND MORE MANAGING TO GET
ON OTHER PEOPLE'S. LIVE STREAMS
AND WE'RE MAKING QUITE A BIT OF
MONEY BY BEING COMPLETELY
OUTRAGEOUS AND TALKING ABOUT
YOU KNOW- WHITE GENOCIDE IN THE
BRAIN THE COMING OF AGE. NO
STATE. AND SO WE SHOWED THEM
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE
CHARACTERISTICS WERE AND WHO
THESE ACCOUNTS WORK AND THEN
OVER TIME WHAT THEY DID WAS
THEY DEVISED A WAY WHERE THEY
STARTED TO BAN. WHITE
SUPREMACIST CONTENTS AND BUT A
BIG FACTOR WASN'T NECESSARILY
THAT THE RESEARCH WAS STOCK.
WHICH IS PART OF IT BUT THE
ADVERTISERS LIKE CISCO DID NOT
WANT THEIR PRODUCTS. BEING
SHOWN OVER WHITE SUPREMACIST
CONTENT AND SO ARE THE
ADVERTISERS REALLY HAD QUITE A
SAY IN HOW THE TECHNOLOGY
OPERATE IT. AND SAY YOU HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT WELL IF THE
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO REACT TO
ADVERTISING BOYCOTTS. BUT
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY GONNA
REACT TO OUR COMMUNITY PRESSURE
OR PEOPLE SAYING YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT AT. EIGHT FOUR
CONTENT ON HERE LOTS OF LIKE
ANTI TRANS OR ANTI LGBT
CONTENT. AND YOU KNOW LIVED
SANTA CLARA FARMS IS OFFERING
AND- IT'S AWFUL BUT LAWFUL. BUT
ONE STEP FURTHER FROM THAT IF
ADVERTISERS SAY HEY I DON'T
WANT COCOA KRISPIES TO BE
HONEST CONTENT. I AND- THEY DO
CHANGE THE PRODUCT AND SO
THAT'S WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT YOU THINK ABOUT
THE WEIGHT OF ADVERTISING HERE
AND HOW MUCH SWAY. THEY HAVE
OVER THE DESIGN AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THESE
ALGORITHMS. MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT THE WITH THAT BINGS UP
THAN IT IS ACCEPTED COMMUNITY.
TO MAKE CLEAR WHAT OUR VALUES
AND WHAT OUR CONCERNS ARE
BECAUSE WE WANT TO PUSHTHE-
THE ADVERTISERS TO BE MORE
SENSITIVE TO THAT COMMUNITY
NEEDS AND THAT WHAT THE
COMMUNITY THINKS ABOUT. CERTAIN
CONTENT- THAT'S A LOT THAT'S A
LOT HARDER BUT IT'S AN ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS. IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT A
IT'S NOT A LEGAL ANALYSIS IT'S
AN ECONOMIC ANALYSIS. THANK
YOU- OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SO A DOCTOR DONNA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
EXPERTISE I'M GOING TO ASK. FOR
A FAVOR ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE IS DEFINING WHAT A
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM IS AND
THAT MAY SEEM LIKE A SIMPLE.
DEFINITION BUT IT IS NOT- AND
TO THE EXTENT THE THAN I KNOW
YOU'VE WRITTEN AND THOUGHT
ABOUT THESE ISSUES VERY DEEPLY
TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU HAVE- A
DEFINITION OR THOUGHTS ON THE
DEFINITION I'D BE GRATEFUL IF
YOU WOULD SEND THAT TO US. AND
THEN SECONDLY YOU WOULD SAID
THAT SOME SORT OF GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITY TO. BOB PROVIDE SOME
CONTENT MODERATION. I'M
CONFIDENT THAT THAT I COULD
DECIDE WHAT IS MISINFORMATION
WAS NOT MISINFORMATION BUT SO
MY COLLEAGUES MAY DISAGREE WITH
ME AS TO WHAT. I MIGHT THINK IS
MISINFORMATION AND SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE HAVE A
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY THAT DOES
SUCH A THING. WHAT GUARDRAILS
DO WE PUT ON THAT GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITY TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
DOESN'T BECOME BASED ON
WHATEVER ADMINISTRATION MIGHT
BE. THE APPOINTING AUTHORITY OF
A VEHICLE FOR- PROMULGATION OF
WHAT I MIGHT THINK IS
MISINFORMATION ANY OF IT SO
THANK YOU MUCH IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND IF YOU'VE GOT THOUGHTS ON
THOSE TWO SUBJECTS. THAT WOULD
BE GREAT AND THEN WE'VE GOT
ANOTHER PANEL COMING UP AND I'M
AN ASSET PANEL THE SAME
QUESTIONS THE NEXT PANELS ON
UNDERSTANDING LEGAL FRAMEWORKS
WITH RESPECT TO. SOCIAL MEDIA
SO DOCTOR DONOVAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
REAL PLEASURE THANKS AND THEN
IT BUT I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
GENEROUSLY IF YOU'VE GOT
THOUGHTS ON THOSE TWO SUBJECTS
WE WELCOME THEM. THANKS ALL
RIGHT OUR NEXT PANEL. WILL
DISCUSS THE EXISTING LEGAL
FRAMEWORK AND HOW THEY IMPACT
CURRENT EFFORTS ITS CONTENT
MODERATION REGULATION AND WHAT
CONSTRAINTS THEY PLACE ON
FURTHER REGULATION. OUR FIRST
PRESENTER WILL BE PROFESSOR
DAPHNE KELLER. PROFESSOR KELLER
DIRECTS THE PROGRAM ON PLATFORM
REGULATION STANFORD'S CYBER
POLICY CENTER PROGRAM. RECENT
WORK FOCUSES ON LEGAL
PROTECTIONS FOR USERS FREE
EXPRESSION RIGHTS WHEN STATE
AND PRIVATE POWER INTERSECT.
PARTICULARLY THROUGH PLATFORMS
ENFORCEMENT OF TERMS OF SERVICE
OR USE OF ALGORITHMIC RANKING
AND RECOMMENDATIONS SHE
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS ASSOCIATE
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR GOOGLE OUR
SECOND PRESENTER ON THE
RELEVANT LEGAL FRAMEWORK IS
PROFESSOR ERIC GOLDMAN
PROFESSOR GOLDMAN IS A
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT SANTA CLARA
UNIVERSITY. IN IS THE CO
DIRECTOR OF THE HIGH TECH LAW
INSTITUTE WELCOME PROFESSORS
KELLER YEAH PROFESSOR KELLER IN
BOB PROFESSOR GOLDMAN A
PROFESSOR KELLER IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE WE'D LOVE TO HEAR
FROM YOU. RIGHT I AM RIGHT HERE
UNLESS YOU SAY OTHERWISE WE CAN
HELP YOU QUITE CLEARLY THANK
YOU. EXCELLENT UP MANY THANKS
FOR INCLUDING ME IN THIS
IMPORTANT SESSION IN MY
PREPARED TESTIMONY TODAY I WILL
TALK ABOUT FIVE FIRST AMENDMENT
HURDLES TO PLATFORM REGULATION
I HAVE A WRITTEN PIECE ON THIS
THAT SOME PEOPLE MAY HAVE SEEN
I'M ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT LIST TODAY.
IF YOU ADD THEM UP IT'S MORE
LIKE NINE HURDLES- BECAUSE
THINGS GET VERY MESSY IN THE
WORLD OF PASSED OUT FROM
REGULATION ON THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. MY MESSAGE TODAY IS
NOT THAT THE FIRST. SEVERABLE
ROOM FOR NEW. PARTICULARLY IN
THE SPHERE OF PRIVACY
COMPETITION AND I THINK WE NEED
THOSE LAWS. LAWS EMPOWERING
INDIVIDUAL USERS OUR CONSUMERS
MAY HELP ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
ABOUT SPEECH IN PUBLIC
DISCOURSE THAT MOTIVATED THIS
HEARING. IF WE HAD DOZENS OF
SOCIAL NETWORKS FOR EXAMPLE NO
ONE OF THEM WOULD BE SO
THOROUGHLY SHAPE PUBLIC
DISCOURSE THROUGH ALGORITHMS
ARE CONTENT MODERATION CHOICES.
NOR IS MY MESSAGE THAT COURTS
CURRENT INTERPRETATION OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IS MORALLY
RIGHT OR THE BEST POLICY OR
EVEN THE INEVITABLE LEGAL
STANDARDS THAT WILL GOVERN US
FOREVER. INTERPRETATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION CHANGES OVER TIME
THE PRINCIPLES I DESCRIBE TODAY
COULD SHIFT OR EVOLVE AND
PERHAPS THEY SHOULD. BUT THAT
WILL ONLY HAPPEN WITH THE
AGREEMENT OF THE MAJORITY OF
THE PEOPLE ON THE SUPREME
COURT. SO I AM HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE BARRIERS THAT NEED TO
BE NAVIGATED LIFE IN LIGHT OF
THAT PRACTICAL AND LEGAL
REALITY. ACOSTA COUNTRIES
LEGISLATORS ARE SPENDING TIME
CRAFTING LEGISLATION THAT IS
CLEARLY CONTRARY TO THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT'S CURRENT
JURISPRUDENCE. OTHERS ARE
PROPOSING LAWS THAT FALL IN
GRAY AREAS BUT THAT STILL HAVE
HIGH ODDS OF BEING STRUCK DOWN
ON CONSTITUTIONAL GROUNDS. SO I
WOULD URGE LAWMAKERS TO BE VERY
CLEAR SIGHTED ABOUT WITH THAT
MEETS- AND ABOUT WHERE AND HOW
TO SPEND TIME AND TAXPAYER
MONEY. AND POLITICAL CAPITAL ON
PROPOSALS THAT MAY AT BEST BE
GAMBLES AT WORST BE A WASTE OF
THAT TIME AND TAXPAYER MONEY
AND POLITICAL CAPITAL. THE
FIRST OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT
BARRIERS AND IT IS THE SIMPLEST
IT IS THAT LAWMAKERS CAN'T
PROHIBIT SPEECH THAT IS
PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. IN THE U. S. THAT
INCLUDES SOME HORRIFIC THINGS
IT INCLUDES THINGS THAT MANY
PEOPLE FIND MORALLY ABORTS THE
VIDEO OF THE TERRIBLE MASKER IN
CHRISTCHURCH NEW ZEALAND FOR
EXAMPLE- IS LEGAL TO SHARE IT
IN MANY PROBABLY MOST CONTACTS
ONLINE. THE SUPREME COURT HAS
EXPLICITLY SAID HE RECENTLY IT
BUT HATE SPEECH IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED WE
ALSO KNOW THAT LIES INCLUDING
DANGEROUS LIGHTS ARE OFF AND
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED. A
LAW THAT PROHIBITS THIS LAWFUL
BUT AWFUL SPEECH IS LIKELY TO
VIOLATE THE COUPLE WILL HAVE A
THE CONSTITUTION UNDER CURRENT
SUPREME COURT CASE LAW. THE
SECOND POINT IS ALSO PRETTY
OBVIOUS BUT MAYBE WHAT SPELLING
OUT IF THE GOVERNMENT CAN'T
RESTRICT CERTAIN SPEECH IT ALSO
CAN'T HELP PLATFORMS TO
RESTRICT THAT SPEECH AND I
EXPLAINED IN A RECENT PAPER
THIS INCLUDES LAWS TELLING
PLATFORMS TO TAKE DOWN LAWFUL
SPEECH. IT ALSO INCLUDES LAWS
TELLING THEM TO CHANGE
ALGORITHMS IN ORDER TO PROMOTE
OR SUPPRESS OR MAKE LESS
VISIBLE THAT SAME LAWFUL BUT
PERHAPS MORALLY TERRIBLE SPEECH
ALL OF THESE ARE THINGS
PLATFORMS MAY DO VOLUNTARILY
AND OFTEN DO AND I THINK SHOULD
DO. BUT THEY LIE OUTSIDE THE
POWER OF GOVERNMENT. WELL HERE
IS AN IMPORTANT ONE. CAN I HELP
ON THAT THAT WE SHOULD ALL
AGREE ON WHICH IS THAT
LAWMAKERS CAN'T CIRCUMVENT THE
CONSTITUTION BY OUTSOURCING
GOVERNANCE TO PRIVATE PLATFORMS.
GOOD THING NONE OF US WOULD
WANT TO LIVE IN A WORLD THAT
BYPASSES BILL OF RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS THROUGH PRIVATIZED
GOVERNANCE WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SPEECH ON
PLATFORMS POLICING OR ANYTHING
ELSE THAT AFFECTS ALL RIGHT. MY
THIRD POINT IS MORE COMPLICATED.
LAWMAKERS CAN'T CRAFT RULES BUT
LOOK CONSTITUTIONAL ON THEIR
FACE BUT THAT PREDICTABLY IN
THE FACT THAT ARE GOING TO LEAD
PLATFORMS TO ERR MASSIVELY ON
THE SIDE OF REMOVING LAWFUL
SPEECH. THIS IS THE LESSON FROM
A SUPREME COURT CASE FROM THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES VERSUS
CALIFORNIA IN WHICH THE COURT
STRUCK DOWN A LAW HOLDING A LOS
ANGELES BOOKSELLER LIABLE FOR
BOOKS ON HIS SHELVES. ALTHOUGH
THE LESSON OF A LARGE BODY OF
HUMAN RIGHTS LITERATURE WARNING
AGAINST LEGAL OBLIGATIONS THAT
INCENTIVIZE PLATFORMS TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES BY TAKING
DOWN THEIR USERS. BUT ACTUALLY
LEGAL SPEECH WE KNOW THAT RULES
LIKE THIS ARE ABUSE OF THE
GOVERNMENT ACT OF ECUADOR FOR
EXAMPLE SEEMINGLY USED FALSE
LEGAL ALLEGATIONS TO GET
YOUTUBE FACEBOOK AND OTHER
PLATFORMS TO REMOVE VIDEO
FOOTAGE OF POLICE BRUTALITY AND
CRITICAL JOURNALISM. THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE A LOT OF MY RESEARCH
FOCUSES ON THAT YES I'M HAPPY
TO TALK MORE ABOUT THAT THE
DETAIL CARE AND CLEANING HOW
NOT JUST SPEECH RIGHTS THAT
RIGHTS TO PRIVACY AND EQUAL
PROTECTION CAN BE ON THE LINE.
WITH LAWS LIKE THIS. THE FOURTH
OF MY FIVE POINT GETS INTO
TERRITORY THAT IS A LESSON TO
IT. AND WHILE THE FIRST THREE
POINTS MORE MOST RELEVANT FOR
PROPOSALS CURRENTLY COMING MORE
FROM THE POLITICAL LEFT. THIS
ONE RELATES TO PROPOSALS THAT
TEND TO COME TODAY FROM THE
POLITICAL RIGHT. TO BE CLEAR I
DON'T ACTUALLY THINK ANY OF
THINGS THESE THINGS ARE
INNATELY POLITICAL OR LEFT
RIGHT ISSUES- BUT THIS IS HOW
THE POLITICS IN AMERICA TODAY
HAPPENS TO LINE UP. THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE IS THIS
LAWMAKERS CAN'T TELL PLATFORMS
WHAT EDITORIAL STANDARDS TO SAT
OR DICTATE THEIR CONTENT
MODERATION OR BANKING
STANDARDS. JUST AS GOVERNMENT
CAN'T TELL THEM WHAT LAWFUL
SPEECH THEY MUST TAKE DOWN.
THEY ALSO CAN'T TELL THEM WHAT
LAWFUL SPEECH THEY MUST CARRY.
THIS IS WHY IT DISTRICT COURT
RECENTLY STRUCK DOWN A FLORIDA
LAW THAT ATTEMPTED TO DO
JUSTICE THANK THAT POPCORN'S
HAD TO LEAVE UP CERTAIN
ACCOUNTS OR POSTS RELATING TO
ELECTIONS AND POLITICAL
DISCUSSION. AND TO BE CLEAR THE
CASE LAW HERE ISN'T ABOUT
INTERNET USERS SPEECH RIGHT SO
MUCH. THIS IS ABOUT PLATFORM
SPEECH RIGHT. FOR BETTER OR FOR
WORSE THERE IS A LONG OF
SUPREME COURT PRECEDENT
IDENTIFYING EDITORIAL RATES FOR
COMPANIES THAT SELECTIVELY
CHERRY THIRD PARTY SPEECH.
INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE CABLE
COMPANIES AND JUDGES INCLUDING
BRETT KAVANAUGH TWENTY SADDAM
THAT THE- DC. CIRCUIT COURT I
HAVE POINTED OUT THESE
PRESIDENTS AS CLEAR BARRIERS TO
HAVING SIMILAR MUST CARRY
OBLIGATIONS FOR PLATFORMS LIKE
YOUTUBE OR TWITTER. THIS TOO IS
AN AREA I HAVE A LONG ARTICLE
ABOUT AND I AM HAPPY TO TALK
MORE ABOUT IT IF PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED IN DOING SO. MY
FINAL POINT AND THIS IS ONE I
HAVE TRULY MIXED FEELINGS ABOUT
IS THAT THERE ARE POTENTIALLY
VERY STEEP CONSTITUTIONAL
BARRIERS. EVEN TOO MANY FORMS
OF COMPELLED TRANSPARENCY
REPORTING FOR COMPANIES. ERIC
GOLDMAN HIS TESTIFYING AFTER ME
HAS DONE MORE RESEARCH ON THIS
TOPIC AND CAN SPEAK MORE TO THE
LAW BUT THE BASIC ISSUE AS LAID
OUT IN A RECENT CASE THAT
STRUCK DOWN A MARYLAND LAW
REQUIRING TRANSPARENCY ABOUT
CAMPAIGN ADS. GETS BACK TO THIS
IDEA THAT PLATFORMS ARE
FUNCTIONING OF PUBLISHERS AND
THAT COMPELLING A PLATFORM TO
STATE WHAT SPEECH AT REJECTED
AND WHY IT IS SIMILAR TO
FORCING THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
TO SAY WHAT ARTICLES IT MAN.
AND WHY AND SHOULD EXPLAIN ITS
PROCESS FOR DECISION MAKING. I
DON'T LOVE THAT OUTCOME I
CONSIDER MYSELF AN ADVOCACY FOR
BETTER TRANSPARENCY AND I AM
HAPPY THAT PENDING EUROPEAN
UNION LAWS ARE LIKELY TO GET IT
FOR US. I SPEND MOST OF MY TIME
THINKING ABOUT WHAT GOOD
TRANSPARENCY LOOKS LIKE ABOUT
HOW TO DO TRANSPARENCY AND NOT
WHETHER THE CONSTITUTIONAL.
CONSTITUTION PROHIBITS IT AS A
LEGAL OBLIGATION. THAT SAID I
WOULD ALSO BE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT HAVING FIFTY DIFFERENT
TRANSPARENCY MANDATES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. AS I DISCUSSED IN
A RECENT BLOG POST THE
COMPLEXITY AND EXPENSE OF
TRANSPARENCY REPORTING ARE VERY
REAL PARTICULARLY FOR SMALLER
COMPANIES IF WE'RE GOING TO
IMPOSE THAT COST AND ACCEPT THE
BURDEN THAT MAY PLACE ON
COMPETITION AND ON THAT
DIVERSITY OF ONLINE SPEECH
ECOSYSTEMS. WE SHOULD HAVE A
CLEAR IDEA OF WHAT BENEFITS
WE'RE GETTING AND WHAT
PARTICULAR KINDS OF DISCLOSURES
ARE LIKELIEST TO GET US THERE.
ALL CLOSE BY BRIEFLY MENTIONING
A COUPLE OF OTHER PARTS OF THE
CONSTITUTION. SOME LIKE THIS
THE PRIMACY AND DORMANT
COMMERCE CLAUSE IS FUNCTION TO
AVOID THE KIND OF
FRAGMENTATION- THAT I WAS JUST
REFERRING TO BY RESERVING
CERTAIN POWERS TO FEDERAL
CONGRESS AND- I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE HOW FRUSTRATING THAT
MUST BE TO YOU AS YOU WATCH THE
GRIDLOCK. AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
OTHERS LIKE THE TAKINGS CLAUSE
WOULD BE RELEVANT FOR LAWS ON
THIS SORT OF UTILITY OR COMMON
CARRIAGE OR PUBLIC
ACCOMMODATIONS MODEL. THAT
WOULD TAKE AWAY PLATFORMS
ABILITY TO ENFORCE CONTENT
POLICIES OPENING THEM UP TO A
GLUT OF OFFENSIVE OR USELESS
CONTENT DRIVING AWAY USERS AND
ADVERTISERS AND GREATLY
DEVALUING. THE PROPERTY THAT
THEY HAVE DEVELOPED. AS I SAID
AT THE START MY MESSAGE IS NOT
ONE OF PARALYSIS BOB WHAT CAN
AND SHOULD BE REGULATED I'VE
WRITTEN AT LENGTH ABOUT MODELS
FROM AROUND THE WORLD
PARTICULARLY FROM THE EUROPEAN
UNION AND LATIN AMERICA. I'M
HOPEFUL FOR CHANGE FROM
COMPETITION OR PRIVACY LAW IN
THE U. S. AND AS I SAID I THINK
THAT CHANGE CAN HELP ADDRESS
MANY OF THESE SPEECH PUBLIC
DISCOURSE. AND SUPPORT ISSUES
THAT THAT WE ARE SEEING TODAY.
BUT WE WILL NOT MAKE THAT
PROGRESS YOU KNOW AS LAWYERS-
THAT. ARE YOU YOU KNOW YOU
WOULD LAWMAKERS WON'T MAKE THAT
PROGRESS BY CHARGING OFF IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION CONSTITUTIONAL
CASE LAW PROVIDES US A MAC- AND
THE MAP INCLUDE SOME THAT SO WE
NEED TO NAVIGATE ACCORDINGLY-
SORRY I KEEP SAYING WE THE
SEEMS ARROGANT WHEN I'M
SPEAKING TO ACTUAL LAWMAKERS
THE LAWMAKING COMMUNITY. THE
LAWYER COMMUNITY NEEDS TO LOOK
CAREFULLY AT THE LAW NAVIGATE
ACCORDINGLY AND- SORT OUT
PRODUCTIVE WAYS FORWARD THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK. I THANK YOU PROFESSOR
KELLER NEXT MISTER GOLDMAN
MISTER GOLDMAN. YEAH GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME OK WE
CAN HEAR YOU PERFECTLY THANK
YOU AWESOME TERRIFIC THANK YOU.
YES SO- I MIRACLE MAN I'M A
PROFESSOR OF LAW AND ASSOCIATE
DEAN FOR RESEARCH AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW. IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA I'VE BEEN
TEACHING AND RESEARCHING
INTERNET LAW ESPECIALLY SECTION
TWO THIRTY FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS I STARTED ADVISING
INTERNET SERVICES ABOUT HOW TO
BUILD AND OPERATE THEIR
COMMUNITIES. BEFORE SECTION TWO
THIRTY WAS ENACTED- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY JUST
BECAUSE HEARING THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE CHANCE. BUT GIVEN
THAT THE- LEGISLATURE'S
JURISDICTION INCLUDES AND
SILICON VALLEY. IT MAKES SENSE
TO LIVE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURES WOULD ESTABLISHED
RULES FOR ENOUGH SERVICES IT
WOULD BE THIS LEGISLATURE.
UNFORTUNATELY STATE
LEGISLATURES HAVE LIMITED OR NO
ROLE TO PLAY IN TELLING
INTERNET SERVICES HOW TO MANAGE
THEIR EDITORIAL OPERATIONS. THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AS- MISS KELLER
EXPLAINED SEVERELY RESTRICTS
ANY LEGISLATIVE MANDATES ABOUT
INTERNET SERVICES EDITORIAL
DECISIONS. AND THE DAHMER
DORMANT COMMERCE CLAUSE FURTHER
RESTRICTS THE LET CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
REGULATE GLOBAL MEDIA OF LIKE
INTERNET SERVICE SINCE. SHARKS
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO WHY SECTION
TO ALSO READ THE LEGISLATURE
DISCRETION- AND CERTAINLY IN
THE INNER AT ANY REGULATORY
EFFORT UNDERTAKEN BY THIS
LEGISLATURE MUST ACCOUNT FOR
SECTION TWO THIRTY. HOWEVER IT
NAVIGATE AROUND SECTION TWO
THIRTY WON'T BE ENOUGH TO SOLVE
ALL THE ISSUES BECAUSE
CONSTITUTIONAL CONSIDERATIONS
WHEN VERY LARGE IN ANY EFFORT
TO REGULATE OR CONTROL SOCIAL
MEDIA. I'LL START BY PROVIDING
AN OVERVIEW OF SECTION TWO
THIRTY CONGRESS ENACTED THE LAW
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX WITH THE
EXPRESS INTENT OF PROVIDING
GREATER EDITORIAL DISCRETION TO
INTERNET SERVICES. CONGRESS
ACCOMPLISH THIS GOAL BY
REDUCING GOVERNMENT REGULATION
INCLUDING LIABILITY FOR HOW
INTERNET SERVICES MANAGE THIRD
PARTY CONTENT. THE STATUTE
EXPRESSLY NOTES THAT AMERICANS
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM QUOTE A
MINIMUM OF GOVERNMENT
REGULATION OF THE INTERNET.
ESSENTIAL TAKEAWAY TELL
CONGRESS SOUGHT TO QUOTE
RESERVE THE VIBRANT INDEPENDENT
FREE MARKET THAT PRESENTLY
EXIST FOR THE INTERNET AND
OTHER INTERACTIVE COMPUTER
SERVICES UNFETTERED BY FEDERAL
OR STATE REGULATION. THAT
SECTION TWO THIRDS ARE FOR V.
SAYS THAT WEBSITES AREN'T FOR
THIRD PARTY CONTACT. THIS BASIC
LEGAL PRINCIPLE HAS SPURRED A
REVOLUTION AND HOW MEMBERS OF
OUR SOCIETY COMMUNICATE WITH
EACH OTHER AND WE IN CALIFORNIA
HERE BENEFITTED GREATLY FROM
DOT REVOLUTION. SECTION TODAY
PROVIDES A LEGAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR AN INDUSTRY THAT POWERS THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND HELP
CALIFORNIANS DO THEIR WORK
ADVANCE OUR EDUCATION
PERFORMANCE CENTRAL SERVICES
AND ENJOY THEIR LEISURE TIME.
SECTION TWO THIRTY ELIMINATE
SOME TYPES OF LIABILITY BASED
ON THIRD PARTY CONTENT BUT IT
LEAVES OTHER REGULATORY TOOLS
IN PLACE. FOR THIS REASON I'M
BAFFLED I SEE SECTION TWO
THIRTY CHARACTERIZED AS TRADING
QUOTE A LAWLESS NO MAN'S LAND
ON THE INTERNET OR A QUOTE WILD
WEST. INSTEAD I'LL MENTION
THREE WAYS IN WHICH SECTION TWO
THIRTY. PRESERVES REGULATORY
EFFORTS. FIRST SECTION TO
THIRTIES LIABILITY MODEL
ENCOURAGES INTERNET SERVICES TO
UNDERTAKE SOCIALLY VALUABLE
EDITORIAL SERVICES THAT THEY
WOULD OTHERWISE ISSUE IF THEY-
FACE LIABILITY FOR THEIR
EDITORIAL JUDGMENT CALLS WERE
ERRORS. WITHOUT SECTION TWO
THIRDS PROTECTION AND I BELIEVE
A STELLAR MENTIONED AS INTERNET
SERVICES. MIGHT TURN INTO AN
ANYTHING GOES FREE FOR ALL
SPEECH VENUES- AN OUTCOME THAT
NO ONE WOULD FIND VALUABLE. I
THINK THE OTHER MORE LIKELY
START IS THAT WITHOUT SECTION
TWO THIRTY ERRANT'S SERVICES
WOULD FIND USER GENERATED
CONTENT TO RISKING AND SIMPLY.
SHUT DOWN OUR ABILITY TO TALK
TO EACH OTHER. BUT SECOND
RECORD F. IS SET THE ORIGINAL
OF ILLEGAL CONTENT NEVER
QUALIFIES FOR SECTION TWO
THIRTY IMMUNITY. THERE'S ALWAYS
AT LEAST ONE PERSON LEGALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERY LEGAL
VIOLATION ONLINE. AND THE THIRD
WAY- THE CONGRESS RESERVED
REGULATORY EFFORTS IS THAT
CONGRESS. CREATED SEVERAL
CATEGORIES WERE INTERNET
SERVICES REMAINED LIABLE FOR
THIRD PARTY CONTENT WITHOUT
RUNNING AFOUL SECTION TWO
THIRTY. FROM THE BEGINNING
SECTION TO THEIR EXCLUDED THREE
TYPES OF CLAIMS ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS PRIVACY ACT OF
ECPA AND STATE LAW COMPLIANCE-
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY CLAIMS
AND FEDERAL CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN CONGRESS ADDED A
FOURTH INSTRUCTION AS PART OF
FOSTER. BECAUSE SECTION TWO
THERE IS NEVER PROVIDE A
BLANKET IMMUNITY THE EXCEPTIONS
HAVE BEEN ON THE BOOKS THAT
SINCE SECTION TWO THIRTY ALL
WITHIN ACTED CONGRESS IS ALWAYS
LEFT ROOM FOR SOME ROOM FOR
PLAINTIFFS TO SEEK. LEGAL
REDRESS FOR THIRD PARTY CONTENT.
FROM THE OUTSET CONGRESS
MAILING RESERVED IN THE
REGULATION OF LIABILITY FOR
THIRD PARTY CONTENT TO ITSELF
NOT TO THE STATE. THE DRAFTERS
GOAL WAS GENERALLY TO ENSURE
THAT INTERNET SERVICES ONLY
NEED TO COMPLY WITH A SINGLE
NATIONAL STANDARD NOT THE
CACOPHONY OF DIFFERENT
REGULATORY APPROACHES AT THE
STATE LEVEL. TO WHICH HE- THIS
GOAL PROGRESS. SAYS THAT
SECTION TO DURING PRAMS-
INCONSISTENT STATE LAWS.
CONGRESS ALSO HIGHLIGHTED THE
PRIMACY OF FEDERAL LAW OVER
STATE LAW BY EXCLUDING OF
FEDERAL CRIMINAL PROSECUTIONS
FROM SECTION TWO THIRTY BUT NOT
EXCITING STATE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS. CONGRESS SLIGHTLY
LICENSE LESS THAN THAT AND
FOSTER. ETHNOLOGY THE PROBLEMS
WITH HEADED ST LOS CIRCA HAS
ALSO CONCLUDED THAT THE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY EXCEPTION
TO SECTION TWO THIRTY ONLY
APPLIES TO FEDERAL ID CLAIMS-
AND OTHER SECTION TO THE
REPLIES TO STATE IP CLAIMS.
THAT IS REALLY FRUSTRATING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE THAT
CONGRESS HAS LIMITS UNLIMITED
SOUTH RD. CONGRESS IS NOT
COMPLETELY ELIMINATE THE
STATE'S REGULATORY AUTHORITY
OVER THE PUBLICATION THIRD
PARTY CONTENT. COPIED
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT RUN AFOUL
OF SECTION TWO THIRTY FOR LAWS
THAT IMPOSE LIABILITY SIMILAR
TO THE EPA. OR THE RESTRICT
FROM PERSONAL SEX FOR MOTIONS
HOWEVER I REITERATE THAT ANY
EFFORTS TO IMPOSE LIABILITY FOR
THIRD PARTY CONTENT INVESTORS
WILL HAVE TO NAVIGATE- THE-
CONSTITUTIONAL HURDLES LIKE THE
ONES THAT MISS KELLER MENTIONED.
A CALIFORNIA IS ALSO FREE TO
IMPOSE LIABILITY FOR TOPICS
UNRELATED TO THE PUBLICATION
THIRD PARTY CONTENT. SECTION TO
THEIR DOES NOT PERMIT THE
LEGISLATURE TO INDIRECTLY CHIEF
WHAT IT CANNOT DO DIRECTLY. BUT
WAS JUST FOR WAS A- ABOUT A
DECADE AGO WITH YOU STATES I
TRIED REGULATE THE- OF ONLINE
AS FOR COME SEX. RATHER THE
BAND THERE PUBLISHING DIRECTOR
THE STATE'S REQUIRE AND THAT'S-
TO VERIFY THAT A DEPICTED TO
WERE ADULTS. AND UNLESS THIS
INTERNET SERVICES DA. PROOF OF
EACH AGE FOR. THE LOSS SAID THE
SERVER HAVE THE RECORD C. A.
FROM. A THREE TO COURTS STRUCK
TO. THESE LAWS STUDENTS TWO. S.
ONE CORTEX. THE LAW SCHOOL. IF
THE LOG IT'S INCOMES WITH FACTS
TWO THIRTY IT CRIMINALIZE THE
NO PUBLIC. IS DISPLAY OF
SPECIFIED CONTACT IN SO DOING
IT CREATES AN INCENTIVE FOR ALL
MY SERVICE ARE NOT TO MONITOR
THE CONTENT THAT. THE SECTION
TODAY WAS ENACTED TO REMEDY AND
QUOTE. THAT'S A DIFFERENT WAY
OF TRYING TO WORK AROUND
SECTION TWO THIRTY SOME STATE
LEGISLATURES HAVE BEEN
INSPIRING QUOTE TRANSPARENCY
OBLIGATIONS THAT REQUIRE AND
SERVICES TO PUBLISH INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR EDITORIAL
OPERATIONS SUCH AS PUBLISHING
THEIR EDITORIAL POLICIES IN
THEIR TERMS OF SERVICE OR
STATISTICS ABOUT THEIR
EDITORIAL DECISIONS. TO THE
EXTENT THESE TRANSPARENCY
OBLIGATIONS DO NOT RESTRICT THE
INTERNET SERVICES DECISIONS
ABOUT PUBLISHING THIRD PARTY
CONTENT THAT SECTION TWO THIRTY
MAY NOT ADDRESS THAT. NEVER
LAST AND DISCARDED MENTION
THIS- MANDATORY TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT EDITORIAL
OPERATIONS CAN RAISE SERIOUS
CONSTITUTIONAL PROBLEMS AND I
DO HAVE A FORTHCOMING PAPER
THAT LAYS OUT THESE CONCERNS
WHICH I'M HAPPY JUST PASSED. IN
THE CULINARY- RATHER THAN
ATTEMPT A CONTROLLER SUPERVISE
THE EDITORIAL DECISIONS OF
INTERNET SERVICES THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE MIGHT
CONSIDER HOW IT CONSULTED KIND
OF PRO SOCIAL INTERACTIONS AND
HOPES TO SEE THREE
POSSIBILITIES FIRST AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM NEEDS TO TEACH STUDENTS
HOW TO BE SMART AND CARING
DIGITAL CITIZENS NO MATTER HOW
MUCH INTEREST SERVICES ARE
REGULATED WILL NEVER ACHIEVE
THE KIND OF ONLINE WORLD WE
WANT WITHOUT EDUCATING PEOPLE
HOW TO BE GOOD COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BOTH ONLINE AND OFF.
SECOND THE LEGISLATURE FIND
RESEARCH INTO BEST PRACTICES
FOR BUILDING PRO SOCIAL ONLINE
COMMUNITY. LEGISLATURE COULD
ALSO HELP A VANDALIZED THE
FINDINGS FROM THAT RESEARCH TO
HELP UP WITH THE PRACTICES
ACROSS THE BOARD. ESPECIALLY IF
SPONSORS THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO DO THIS KIND OF RESEARCH
THEMSELVES. FOR A THIRD IF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE BELIEVES
THAT THE MARKET IS A PROVIDING
US CONSTITUENTS WITH THE KIND
OF INTERNET SERVICES- THAT IT
WANTS THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER BUILDING AN OPERATIONS
ON SERVICES. I'M GIVE ME
ANALOGY GOVERNMENT PROVIDE
PHYSICAL WORLD PARKS TO GIVE
CITIZENS A PLACE TO PAY PLAY
AND SOCIALIZE. THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE COULD CREATE A
PUBLIC OFFICIAL PARKS TO PLAY A
SIMILAR. PROSOCIAL WALL ONLINE.
OKAY BY NOW THE AND OF THE
LEGISLATURE CLOSE ATTENTION TO
THE NEEDS OF THE START UP
ECOSYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT
CURRENT AND FUTURE ON TURNER'S
CAN'T LAUNCH SERVICES THAT CAN
OUT INNOVATE. AND OUT COMPETE
THE EXISTING INTERNET
INCUMBENTS. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY SURE THESE FROM THE
MARCH SUNDAY- AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONVERSATION
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
PROFESSOR GOLDMAN OF QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SENATE CORTESE. YES
SIR THANK YOU MISTER HI.
ASSEMBLY LISTENED AND TOOK
COPIOUS NOTES SOME. HERE ROLLED
WITH THE LAST TWO SPEAKERS
PROFESSOR KELLERMANN AND
PROFESSOR GOLDMAN WHAT IT CAN
APPRECIATE. THE ENUMERATION OF
THE ENUMERATION OF- YOU KNOW
PROTECTING WHAT CAN AND CAN'T
BE DONE. THE FIVE ITEMS SAID
THE PROFESSOR KILLER LAID OUT.
IT DIDN'T SEEM TO MENTION THOSE
FIVE ITEMS PROTOCOLS OF ACTION-
IN TERMS OF ANY CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUES- FIVE RIGHT HANDER STEM
THE FIVE HURDLES WERE REALLY.
ELISE'S I'D LISTEN TO- COMING
FROM A REGULATORY LANDS WHAT
CAN YOU REGULATE WE CANNOT
REGULATE BUT SHORT OF
REGULATIONS. OF IN THE COURSE
IS QUESTION COULD BE FOR
PROFESSOR KILLER OR PROFESSOR
GOLDMAN- IT'S I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHETHER
CONSTITUTIONALLY STRAIGHT UP
CONSTITUTIONALLY OR THROUGH TWO
THIRTY. WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
YOUR OPINION. THAT THE CONGRESS
IS ACTUALLY STEPPED INTO THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS SPACE IT
SAID THAT THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
CONTROL LONGER. HARM CAN NO
LONGER ADJUDICATE. I'M STATE.
CLAIMS OF STATE RESIDENTS OF
FOR SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
FOLKS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
HE TOUCHED UPON HIM BY ALICIA
PRIVACY RIGHTS- WURSTEN
VIOLATION OF PRIVACY RIGHTS
PERHAPS- TRAFFICKING OF. OF
IMAGES OF MINORS IN.
COMPROMISING SITUATIONS. AND SO
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND- YOU
BECAUSE I DID HER PRESS
RIGGLEMAN SAY THE CONGRESS LEFT
THE CENTER LEFT NO ROOM FOR
PRIVATE PARTIES TWO HE SAID HE
LOOKED AT CONGRESS LEFT ROOM
FOR PRIVATE PARTIES TO BE TO
MAKE CIVIL CLAIMS. BUT KEPT
FIFTY CENTURY THAT JURISDICTION
TO THEMSELVES WHAT WILL
CONGRESS. IS DOES NOT HAVE
JUDICIAL POWERS SO I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND. AGAIN A PICTURE
POSITION THE. THE KIND OF
LEGISLATION THAT STATES
TYPICALLY A DEAL WITH IN TERMS
OF CIVIL CLAIMS QUANTIFYING
PENALTIES OR REMEDIES OR
DAMAGES- OR CIVIL PROCEDURE
AROUND WHEN. HUMP WHEN IT CAME
COULD BE BROUGHT. HOME HEALTH
THINGS LIKE INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
HI- HIM- ARE ARE. HOME
INSTALLED INVINCIBLE PROCEDURE
AROUND CERTAIN KINDS OF CLAIMS
YOU KNOW THESE ARE ALL AREAS
UNDER THE JURISDICTION.
TYPICALLY OF STATES TO ALLOW
THEIR RESIDENTS HELLO TO BRING
CLAIMS FORD FOR DAMAGES AND I'M
JUST NOT CLEAR ON. AGAIN A WHAT
YOUR OPINION IS AS TO. OUR
ABILITY TO DO THAT- REQUIRING-
ONCE NOTICE HAS BEEN ONCE AGAIN
INTERNET. A POPCORN HAS BEEN
PUT ON NOTICE- THAT. HELLO
THERE'S AN ALLEGED VIOLATION
FROM A SIMPLE STANDPOINT- WHAT
REMEDIES ARE AVAILABLE IF THEY
DON'T CARE IN IN IN I GUESS
WHAT I'M ASKING ONE MORE TIME
IS ARE YOU SAYING NONE-
FINANCIAL JUST WONDERING HOW
HOW THAT'S CONSTITUTIONAL.
THANK YOU SECRETARY ZINKE OF.
MISS KELLER MAYBE I CAN SPEAK
TO THE CONSTITUTIONAL CASE- AND
PROFESSOR GOLDMAN CAN SPEAK TO
THAT SORT OF TWO THIRTY
LEGISLATIVE NEEDS AS A
CONSTITUTIONAL MATTER- LAWS
THAT CREATE A PRIVATE CAUSE OF
ACTION ARE LIMITED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IN THE SAME WAY THAT
YOU KNOW DIRECT FEDERAL
PROSECUTION OF REGULATION WOULD
BE SO IF YOU THINK FOR EXAMPLE
OF SOMETHING LIKE- THE FAMOUS
NEW YORK TIMES VERSUS SULLIVAN
DEFAMATION CASE WHERE THAT THE
SUPREME COURT SAID BECAUSE OF
THE FIRST AMENDMENT WE HAVE TO
PLACE THESE LIMITS ON HOW EASY
IT IS TO BRING A DEFAMATION
CLAIM AGAINST THE NEWSPAPER-
TALKING ABOUT A PUBLIC FIGURE.
THAT WAS ABOUT EIGHT I BELIEVE
THIS ALABAMA STATE DEFAMATION
CAUSE OF ACTION- AND THE POINTS
OF THAT RULING AND MANY OTHER
BUILDINGS IS THAT ULTIMATELY
THE CONSTITUTION IS A IS A
CONSTRAINT ON THE STATE CAUSES
OF ACTION WHEN THEY RUN INTO
CONFLICT WITH FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS SO THAT THAT'S- PART OF
THE CONSTITUTIONAL PIECE UNDER
THE FIRST AMENDMENT- AND THEN
THE OTHER PIECE OF THE QUESTION
I THINK AND THIS MIGHT BE
SOMETHING ERA CAN SPEAK TO
MORE- IS ABOUT. CONGRESS
STEPPING IN AND PREVENTING
STATES FROM CREATING CAUSES OF
ACTION YOU KNOW CITING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT ASIDE ASSUMING
THAT THOSE CAUSES OF ACTION-
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE FIRST
AMENDMENT- YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
IS CONGRESS'S ROLE IN IN
DISPLACING ABOUT THREE SETTING
CONSISTENT NATIONWIDE RULES AND
THAT ARE YOU KNOW GOES BACK
MORE TO THE COMMERCE CLAUSE AND
SHOOT THE POWERS THAT CONGRESS
HAS EXERCISED IN SETTING UP
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS LAW
GENERALLY FEDERAL LAW FOR
BROADCAST FOR CABLE. AND
COMMUNICATIONS DECENCY ACT'S SO
CALLED CDA TWO THIRTY- AS AS
ERIC SPOKE TO- THERE IS THAT
YOU KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING I'VE
I'VE WRITTEN ABOUT YOU KNOW IF
THERE WERE NO TWO THIRTY THEN
THERE WOULD BE FIRST AMENDMENT
LIMITS TO WHAT. OUR LIABILITY
COULD BE PUT ON TOP REYES AND
HOW BACK WORK- YOU KNOW THAT
THE IS AGAIN WE KNOW THIS FROM
THE CASE ABOUT OF SAN. AND AND
FOR OTHER CASE. AND IT'S THAT
NO CLASS COULD BE LIKE IN WE
KNOW NOW THAT FORM SPACE
LIABILITY FOR. UNDER FEDERAL
CRIMINAL LAW JUST LIKE ANYBODY
ELSE DOES FOR EXAMPLE FOR
THINGS LIKE CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE
MATERIAL. IT IS RATHER THAT YOU
CAN'T DESIGN LAWS THAT
FORESEEABLY ARE GOING TO HAVE
THIS HUGE COLLATERAL DAMAGE
AFFECT WITH PLATFORMS TAKING
DOWN A BUNCH OF LAWFUL SPEECH
ARE POTENTIALLY DOING SO USING
TOOLS THAT. VIOLATE USERS
PRIVACY USING TOOLS LIKE- HATE
SPEECH FOLK SO CALLED HATE
SPEECH VOTERS THAT HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO HAVE DISPARATE IMPACT
ON BLACK AMERICAN ENGLISH
SPEAKERS YEAH THEY'RE JUST A
BUNCH OF- COLLATERAL DAMAGE
CONSTRAINTS YOU HAVE TO START
CONTROLLING FOR- AND THAT THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES
CONTROLLING FOR ONCE YOU'RE-
OUTSIDE. THE CURRENT WORLD OF
CD EIGHT T. THIRTY. THANK YOU
PAUL SURE ALL OF THE THREE TOUR
AND I THINK FILL- SOME THINGS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
REGULATORY. FOR CONTENT.
REGULATION STRAIGHT UP PER SE
WHAT I'M REALLY ASKING HIS-
WHETHER NOT YOU'RE SAYING. IS
THAT CONGRESS HAS ESSENTIALLY
USURPED THE RIGHT OF PLAINTIFFS
COUNSEL TO BRING- THE CLAIM FOR
A REQUEST FOR INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
ON SOMETHING LIKE FOR
TRAFFICKING IN IN CON. IMAGES
OF CHILDREN. ONCE IT'S ALREADY
BEEN PUBLISHED IT'S AN M.
WALLETS ON GOING. BEING
PUBLISHED AS PART OF THE
PLATFORM WHERE THE HARM IS
OCCURRING EVERY SECOND OF EVERY
DAY FOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS TODAY
AND TOMORROW AND THE NEXT DAY.
YOU SEEM TO BE SAYING THAT.
CONGRESS HAS RESERVE TO ITSELF.
THE RIGHT TO CREATE REMEDIES OR
NOT- HUH FOR A PATH FOR
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF TO GET THE-
IMAGE TAKEN DOWN. IN IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THERE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE THEY'RE IN
AND OF ITSELF AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT CONGRESS UNDER UNDER. A
SEPARATION OF POWERS HAS A
RIGHT TO GO IN AND PRECLUDE.
I'M A CITIZEN OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. OF FOR
BRINGING A CLAIM. HI TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES OR THEIR THEIR OWN
CHILDREN. FROM TRAFFICKING
ONLINE TRAFFICKING THAT'S
ONGOING- FOR WORK YOU SEEM TO
BE SAYING IS. THAT THE PARENT
OR GUARDIAN. OR THE COUNSELOR
THEREFORE WOULD WOULD HAVE TO
SIT ON THEIR HANDS IN AND WAIT
FOR POLARIZED CONGRESS. HI TO
COME FORWARD WITH THOSE
REMEDIES WHICH THEY HAVE YET TO
DO. MAINTENANCE AND I'M HAVING
A HARD TIME WITH THE LATTER
SCENARIO. IN OF ITSELF BEING
CONSTITUTIONAL I DON'T THINK
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH COULD DO
THAT EITHER I THINK THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH. UNDER OUR
CONSTITUTION- IS CREATES A
SEPARATE. BECAUSE OF ACTION
NOTE WHETHER OR NOT THE CAUSE
OF ACTION- WHAT DO NOT THAT
PLEASE THAT PLEASE WOULD BE
UPHELD BY THE COURT. HUNDREDS
BASED ON FACTS WERE BASED ON
TWO THIRTY- I THINK IS A IS A
DIFFERENT ISSUE BUT WHAT I'M
HEARING YOU SAYING THESE.
LEGISLATURE CANNOT CREATE THE
CAUSE OF ACTION IN THE FIRST
PLACE IN HAVE COMMANDED A HARD
TIME WITH. SPEAK BRIEFLY TO
THAT I THINK ERIC'S SORT OF IS
THE RIGHT PERSON FOR MOST OF
THE ANSWER BUT I MEAN ONE PIECE
IS THAT STATE LEGISLATURES
ABSOLUTELY CAN AND DO CREATE
CAUSES OF ACTION AGAINST
PLATFORMS. UP FOR THINGS THAT
ARE NOT ABOUT THE SPEECH
TRANSMITTED BY THE PLATFORM'S
USERS SO FOR EXAMPLE THERE ARE
SEVERAL RECENT- CASES ON CD TWO
THIRTY- SAYING IT BETTER CLAIM
CAN PROCEED FOR EXAMPLE-
AGAINST SNAP. BASED ON A BAD
PIECE OF INFORMATION THAT SNAP
ITSELF WAS GENERATING OR
AGAINST AIRBNB- BASED ON-
TRANSACTIONS AND LOCAL HOUSING
REGULATION- BUT- WHERE THE
CLAIM IS BASED ON SPEECH THAT
USERS POST TO PLATFORMS THAT
DOES MOVE INTO THE SPACE THAT
CONGRESS HAS OCCUPIED. THROUGH
ITS CDA TWO THIRTY NOW FOR THE
SPECIFIC ISSUE THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING UP THE TRAFFICKING
CLAIMS. THERE WAS A- CHANGE TO
THE FEDERAL LEGISLATION A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THROUGH
THAT SESTA FOSTA LEGISLATION
THAT WAS INTENDED TO TARGET
PRECISELY THAT AND WHICH DID
OPEN UP ROOM FOR ADDITIONAL
CLAIMS- THAT HADN'T EXISTED
BEFORE. AND I SHOULD BE VERY
CLEAR WITH YOU THAT I AM
INVOLVED IN A CONSTITUTIONAL
CHALLENGE TO SESTA FOSTA I
THINK THAT- BEAT MERRICK'S.
CHALLENGE HAVE BECOME MORE AND
MORE EVIDENCE AS THE YEARS HAVE
GONE BY SINCE THE LAW PASSED AS
THERE IS INCREASING EVIDENCE OF
BAD LAWS FAILURE TO ACHIEVE ITS
PURPOSES IN AND THE INCREASE IN
RISK AND HARMS TO- TAKE PEOPLE.
INVOLVED IN COMMERCIAL SEX WORK
SO I DO THINK THERE'S GREAT
COMPLEXITY IN WHAT A
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW COULD LOOK
LIKE ON THAT SPECIFIC ISSUE BUT
I THINK THAT IS. YOU KNOW OFF
TO THE SIDE AND I'M NOT THE
SAME AS THE QUESTION YOU'RE
ASKING ABOUT THE ROLE OF THAT
FEDERAL LEGISLATURE VERSUS THE
STATE LEGISLATURES- ERIC DO.
YOU WANT TO SPEAK MORE TO THIS
ONE. BUT WITH THE CHURCH.
ASSURE YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER FOR REYES- THE ISSUE AND
ASKING I THINK SERIES OF IN
QUESTIONS- EVERY OTHER FOCUSED
ON SEX TWO THIRTY I THINK
BESTSELLERS OR TALKED SOME OF
THE- LIMITS- TRUCKS TWO THIRTY
APPLY TO. ALL THE DIFFERENT
WAYS WHICH A MIGHT BE STRUCTURE
WHETHER IT'S AS A- A SAID
REACHED WITH DAMAGE AS A SIMPLE
RESTRICTION WITH- IN. RELIEF
AVAILABLE A SECTION TWO THIRTY
APPLIES TO ALL THE DIFFERENT
WAYS TO WHICH- THE LIABILITY
MIGHT ATTACH- THAT TO BE CLEAR
AND WE DO NEED TO REITERATE ITS
SECTION TWO THIRTY DOESN'T
RESTRICT ANY CLAIMS AGAINST
ACTUAL WRONG TO WORKERS.
CAUSING THE HARM TO CHOOSE-
REFERENCED- DOES NEVER BEEN
COVERED BY SECTION TWO THIRTY
SO WE'RE ONLY TALKING NOW ABOUT
THE INTERMEDIARY SERVICES
LIABILITY- AND IN THAT SECTION
TO HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR THAT
THINGS LIKE NOTICE AND TAKEDOWN
I SCHEMES ARE ARE INCONSISTENT
WITH SECTION TWO THIRTIES
PROHIBITIONS- SO- THE FACT THAT
NOTICES MIGHT WORK IN OTHER
CONTEXTS SAY THE COPPERY
CONTACTS- THAT DOESN'T
TRANSLATE INTO THE SECTION TO
THEIR ENVIRONMENT. THERE HAVE
BEEN OCCASIONAL CHALLENGES TO
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF
SECTION TWO THIRTY THERE ARE
BELIEVE PENDING CHARGES- IN
COURT TODAY- THOSE CHALLENGES
HAVE GONE GONE ANYWHERE- I
THINK THAT THIS IS FAIRLY
WITHIN CONGRESS'S. AUTHORITY ON
TO US STRUCTURE OF THE KIND OF-
SPEECH ENVIRONMENT SAID IT
WANTS AND THAT'S SINCE WHEN I
THINK ABOUT SECTION TWO THERE
IS A SUPPLEMENT TO THE FIRST
AMENDMENT THE FIRST AMENDMENT
SAYS THE FLOOR ABOUT THE TIME
DISTRICTS FROM IT IN OUR
SOCIETY. BUT CONGRESS CAN AND
IN SOME CASES HIGHS AHEAD
DOCTORS SPEECH ENHANCING LAWS
AND YOU MIGHT LOOK AT SECTIONS
THERE IS IN THAT CATEGORY
WITHIN CONGRESS'S PURVIEW TO DO
SO- THE LAST. I'M JUST GONNA
MENTION ABOUT- PRIOR RIGHTS OF
ACTION WE SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE
THE POSSIBILITY THAT- PRIVATE
RIGHTS OF ACTION WOULD BE-
BROUGHT IF ENABLED I JUST FEEL
THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE IN
HUMAN HISTORY- AND IN
PARTICULAR- THE LOSS IN FLORIDA
ANTI X. I HAVE INCLUDED. RIGHTS
ACTION FOR. CONTENT MODERATION
DECISION. FOR SERVICE THAT
MAKES BILLION TO. A DAY ABOUT
CONTENT IN THEORY EACH PERSON
TO GET WHAT THEY WANT- THAT TO
SEE TO FOR LIKE THIS SERVICE
TODAY UNDER. THE PURSE. IF IT
HAD PLAN OF WE COULD LIVE.
BILLIONS OF LAWSUITS. PER DAY-
AND I DON'T KNOW THE WORK. TO
HANDLE THAT I DON'T KNOW WHAT A
SOLUTION BEYOND ABOUT
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU
PROFESSOR GOLDMAN OTHER COMPANY
HAS CENTER STERN. THANKS IS
CHAIR WE DROVE DOWN ON ON ONE
UNDERLYING POINT AROUND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT I THINK MIGHT
BE HELPFUL FOR FRAMING THE
CONVERSATION I- THE IRAQ IT
GETS AT THE ALSO THE SAFE
HARBOR PROVISIONS IN SECTION
TWO THIRTY BUT- TO BE CLEAR.
CERTAIN KINDS OF SPEECH ARE NOT
PROTECTED WE'VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THE SPEECH THE A POOR
INTER AWFUL SPEECH THAT IS
LAWFUL- BUT- THREATS OF
VIOLENCE. ARE NOT
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED- I
CAN CAN YOU ELABORATE A LITTLE
BIT MORE IN IN JUST IN THAT
PARTICULAR CONTEXT- WHAT
CONSTITUTES- AT BOND AB RIGHT
SPEECH THAT ISN'T
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED IN
THAT CONTEXT. WHAT KIND OF
THREAT IT HAS TO BE TO BE
CONSIDERED- UNPROTECTED SPEECH.
SO I CAN SPEAK TO THIS I MEAN
THAT THE- UNDERLYING-
BRANDENBURG STANDARD FROM THE
SUPREME COURT INVOLVES ASKING
QUITE THERE THE THREATS CREATES
AN IMMINENT RISK OF HARM- AND-
I AM I AM NOT AN EXPERT IN THE
DETAILS OF THAT SORT OF
SUBSEQUENT CASE LAW
INTERPRETING THAT BUT SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS REALLY RELEVANT
FOR. THIS DISCUSSION AND WHICH
I THOUGHT ABOUT A GREAT DEAL IS
YOU KNOW THE IDEA THAT EIGHT
THE RATS THAT IS LEGAL WHEN
MADE MAYBE IN A BAR BECAUSE
NOBODY BELIEVES THE SPEAKER'S
GOING TO ACT ON IT MIGHT BECOME
ILLEGAL ARE CONSTITUTIONALLY
PERMISSIBLE TO RESTRICT WHEN
DISSEMINATED ON THE INTERNET IN
A WAY THAT MIGHT LEAD TO MOB
VIOLENCE OR LEAD TO- I'M
MENTALLY UNSTABLE PEOPLE THE
PERSON BEING MOTIVATED BAITED
BY IT AND TAKING ACTION.
THERE'S A PROFESSOR NAMED
LARISSA LET'S SEE WHO'S WHO'S
WRITTEN REALLY. ON ON THIS
QUESTION- AND I THINK THE
BOTTOM LINE IS. MAYBE I. GOT TO
BOTTOM LINE AND I APOLOGIZE
BUT- I THINK IT IS QUITE
POSSIBLE THAT AND SORT OF CASE
BY CASE BASIS- COURTS COULD
LOOK AT INSTANCES OF ONLINE
THREATS- AND- RESTRICT THE MORE
THAN THEY MIGHT HAVE RESTRICTED
THAT THREAT IN A BAR ROOMS. BUT
I DON'T THINK THAT TRANSLATES
TO IT LIKE A CONSTITUTIONALLY
PERMISSIBLE STRUCTURE WHERE-
PLATFORMS WRITTEN LARGE ARE
REQUIRED TO PROHIBIT A WHOLE
CLASS OF SPEECH THAT CURRENTLY
LEGAL YOU KNOW BEFORE WE MOVE
THE LINE FROM WHAT THE LAW
PROHIBIT RIGHT NOW. YES WHICH
IS WHAT THE U. K. IS TRYING TO
SPEND THAT KIND OF THING AND
WHEN I HEARD MY COLLEAGUES TALK
ABOUT SPECIFIC INSTANCES OF
INJURIES OF KNOWN YOU KNOW
ONGOING INCIDENTS AYE I THINK
OF YOU KNOW. AT A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL FOR INSTANCE GIVING A
SPEECH IN A PARK AND- PEOPLE IN
THAT PARK- THREATENING AT
PUBLIC OFFICIALS LIFE NOT
SAYING YOU KNOW. KICK THIS GUY
OUT OF OFFICE BUT LET'S GO GET
THIS GUY- THAT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT IS. UNPROTECTED SPEECH
AND IT CAN BE YOU CAN BE
RELIABLE FOR ASSAULTER AMONGST
A NUMBER OF OTHER CRIMINAL
CHARGES BUT WE DON'T HAVE.
NECESSARILY THE SAME STANDARD
ONLINE ESPECIALLY BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T ALWAYS FIND THE PERSON
WHO'S MAKING THAT THREAT. AND
SO WHEN YOU HAVE SORT OF
ANONYMOUS THREATS OR ANONYMOUS
POSTINGS IN THAT WAY THE
LIABILITY FRAMEWORK SHIFTS AND.
YEAH I THINK. IT DID BUT BUT
NEVER THE CONSTITUTIONAL LIMITS
ON- OUR ABILITY TO REGULATE
THAT KIND OF SPEECH JUST TO BE
CLEAR TODAY DO NOT SOUND
PRESCRIBED. I APPRECIATE THE
POINTS ABOUT COMMERCE BUT MY-
MY MAKING THAT. BY MAKING THAT
DISTINCTION PROPERLY HERE. AT
LEAST IN THEORY. EIGHT IF I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE QUESTION
CORRECTLY I THINK THAT. YOU
KNOW EVERY FIRST AMENDMENT
QUESTION IS THIS PROTRACTED
CASE BY CASE ANALYSIS ARE YOU
KNOW EVERYTHING THAT'S IN A
GRAY AREA- IT IS RESULT CASE BY
CASE BY COURTS AND SO- I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE. YOU KNOW I GO TO
THE THING THAT TELLS US EXACTLY
WHAT SPEECH IS LEGAL OR ILLEGAL
IN IN WHAT CONTEXT DOES THAT
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION OR I
APOLOGIZE I MEAN IT'S HARD
BECAUSE IT IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
FIND A FRAMEWORK LIKE YOU SAID
YOU DON'T TO DO CLASS BASED
REGULATION OF ALL ONE TYPE OF
CONTENT BUT AT LEAST THAT.
CLARIFICATION FOR WHAT COULD BE
PROSECUTED IN THEORY ON A CASE
BY CASE BASIS RIGHT TO THAT D.
A. EASIER CITY ATTORNEYS OR-
YOU KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS THAT THE PUBLIC COULD
ACTUALLY SEEK RECOURSE FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT RIGHT FOR. FOR
POTENTIAL CLAIMS NOT JUST IN
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION BUT IN
CRIMINAL. CASES IT SOUNDS LIKE.
IF PEOPLE THINK ANYTHING GOES
ONLINE. AND I THINK WE PASSED A
LAW HERE IN THE SENATE
ELECTIONS. COMMITTEE AT TWO
YEARS BACK THAT MADE IT
CRIMINAL NOT JUST TO PUT FOR
INSTANCE MISINFORMATION ABOUT
AN ELECTION- INTO SOMEONE'S
MAILBOX BUT ALSO TO TWEAK THAT
INFORMATION. RIGHT AND THAT
THAT ACT ITSELF WITH A WAS
OTHERWISE A VIOLATION OF STATE
ELECTION LAW RIGHT TO PUT OUT
MISINFORMATION ABOUT ELECTION
IN DELIBERATELY INTENDED TO
DEFRAUD A VOTER. ID THAT THAT'S
THE CONTENT OF THAT SPEECH IS
NOT CHANGE JUST BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN TWEETED AS OPPOSED TO- PUT
IN SOMEONE'S MAILBOX ON A
POSTER AND SO. I GUESS I'M JUST
I'M WRESTLING WITH. HOW TO
PROVIDE MORE CLARITY IN LAW
ABOUT THOSE BOUNDARIES OR LACK
THERE OF IN THAT IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE WE HAVE NOT BEEN
CHALLENGED CONSTITUTIONALLY
THERE. MISS KELLER PROFESSOR
GOLDMAN YOU CAN RESPOND. WELL
DO WE LOSE THE. EACH OTHER
WHO'S GOING TO GO FOR PLEASE
COME I HAVE A FEW THAT MAYBE
YOU SHOULD GO PLEASE. GET OUT
OF SO I MEAN FOR I WOULD SAY. I
THINK THERE'S A NAY FOR MORE
RESEARCH AND A- TOWARD YOU KNOW
WHEN THERE'S SOMEBODY WHO KNOWS
WHO IS A- THEM ONLINE YOU HAS
THE STOCK FOR X. IS BEING-
HAVING. WEEDS FOR THEM TO GET
SUPPORT- FROM POLICE- AND YOU
KNOW AND SO FORTH IT IS
IMPORTANT WAY FORWARD I WOULD
STATE IN PARTICULARLY. WHEN
THIS IS SORT OF LIKE AN UGLY
TRUTH ABOUT THE CONTENT
MODERATION WORLD FOR CHILD
SEXUAL ABUSE MATERIAL THERE
ARE. MASSIVELY IN ADEQUATE
FEDERAL RESOURCES- IN CASE OF
WHAT PLATFORMS DO REMOVE THIS
CONTENT AND REPORT IT TO
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES AND THAT NO
ACTION IS TAKEN. I THINK IN THE
WORLD OF GOING YOU KNOW HOLDING
SPEAKERS LIABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS THERE THERE IS ROOM FOR
MOTION- THAT SAID I'M I DIDN'T.
PUT IN MIND OF A SUPREME COURT
CASE FROM A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
CALLED ALONENESS- WHICH WAS-
PROSECUTING A MAN WHO POSTED
THREATS TO HIS EX WIFE ON
FACEBOOK- INCLUDE IN THE FORM
OF RAP LYRICS AND- BEING
COLLUDED THINGS. LIKE AND
PARAPHRASING BUT- FULL UP THAT
TEMPER RISK ORDER PUT IT IN
EUROPE. DO YOU THINK IT WILL
STOP A BULLET- AND STATEMENTS
ABOUT- GOING AND SHOOTING
PEOPLE AT SCHOOLS REALLY REALLY
SCARY YOU KNOW AS A PARENT.
REALLY SCARY STUFF AND THE
SUPREME COURT SAID NO IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL TO PROSECUTE
THIS GUY FOR SAYING THESE
THINGS AND SO THE LIMITS. YOU
KNOW ON WHAT. BUT THE LIMITS
THERE ARE ARE DIFFICULT. I'LL
JUST ADD- THAT- THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ABOUT WIND SOME
STATEMENT ONLINE IT CONSTITUTES
A TRUE THREAT- THAT SIGNALS A
PANIC IMMINENT ACTIONS THAT
SUPPORT CRIMINAL PROSECUTION IS
REALLY REALLY DIFFICULT TO
DETERMINE AND I THINK YOUR
ANALOGY ABOUT- WHAT SOME MIGHT
SAY IN A PARK- TO SOMEONE IN
PHYSICAL SPACE- THERE'S AN
IMMINENT- POSSIBILITY OF
VIOLENCE IS THE PEOPLE ARE
PHYSICALLY IN THE SAME SPACE
TOGETHER- THAT ISN'T SHOWING
THE ONLINE WORLD- AND SO- WHAT.
WHENEVER WE SEE THAT LEVEL OF
EMINENCE THE NUMBER ONE
RECOURSE ALWAYS HAS TO BE WHAT
IS LAW ENFORCEMENT IN A JUNE TO
PROTECT THE TARGETS OF THIS-
POTENTIALLY IMMINENT VIOLENCE-
AND IF WE THINK THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT STOP TAKING THOSE
CASES IF WE THINK THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM THEN I THINK WE
NEED TO ADDRESS IT ON THOSE
TERMS. BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
VERY MUCH HAND CUFFED IN THIS
AREA BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
SPEAKERS HAVE FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS TO ESPOUSE ARE VIEWED
SEN SO THE EXAMPLE THAT MISS
TAYLOR GAVE ABOUT THESE RAP
LYRICS BEING QUOTED THAT COULD
VERY WELL BE THE KIND OF THING
THAT STARTS TO VIRGIN TO FIRST
AMENDMENT PROTECTED. SPEECH AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN BE
PARALYZED BY THE FACT THAT THEY
HAVE TO GET A RIGHT THEY HAVE
TO- ABOUT PROTECT- CITIZENS
FROM VIOLENCE BUT THEY ALSO
HAVE TO RESPECT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS TO SPEAKERS-
SO I THINK THERE'S NO EASY
SOLUTIONS HERE IN PART BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT THIS WILL
ALWAYS BE FACT SPECIFIC AND THE
FACT THAT THINGS ARE TAKING
PLACE ONLINE REDUCES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF SOME IMMINENT
VIOLENCE IN A WAY THAT MAY NOT
BE TRUE. IF PEOPLE ARE JUST ARE
LEGALLY WITH AND- YOU KNOW THE
SWINGING RADIUS OF THEIR FEST-
HAVING SAID THAT THOUGH- IF WE
THINK THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMITMENT
TO THIS ISSUE I THINK WE. NEED
TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE ON ITS
OWN TERMS. THANK YOU ARM. DOES
THE FOLLOWING TO SEND CORTEZ.
QUESTION SO THE EASING EXAM
FROM A VERY OLD CASE. IF ARM.
AN INDIVIDUAL POSTS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA HEY EVERYBODY COME TO THE
ABC THEATRE AND MIDWAY THROUGH
THE SHOW OR CONCERT. YELL FIRE.
AND THAT BECOMES A TREND THAT
BECOMES A THING AND- SOMEONE
TRIES TO ENJOYING THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM FROM POP
PROMULGATING THIS ACTIVITY-
ISRAELI BE DONE CAN THEY BE
ENJOINED. I'LL START WITH MISS
KELLER THAT'LL TURN TO
PROFESSOR GOLDMAN. I'LL.
SETTING ASIDE THE MUCH INTERNET
DEBATED QUESTION ABOUT THE
SPEECH IN A CROWDED THEATER
EXAMPLE- I THINK YOU KNOW THE
CORE OF THIS QUESTION IS IF
THERE ARE PEOPLE ORGANIZING
DANGEROUS THINGS ON ON A
PLATFORM- WHAT CAN BE DONE
ABOUT BASS WHAT LIABILITY CAN
BE IMPOSED ON THEM I'M NOT THEM
IF THEY ARE ORGANIZING
SOMETHING THAT WILL FORESEEABLY
YOU KNOW BECAUSE REAL WORLD
VIOLENCE AND DAMAGING- AND-
THERE'S AN ACADEMIC THEM SUSAN
BENESCH WHO HAS WHAT I THINK IS
A REALLY USEFUL FRAMEWORK FOR
THIS. I WAS BECAUSE THAT
DANGEROUS SPEECH LOOKING LIKE
VERY INCORRECTLY AT WHAT SPEECH
FORESEEABLY- IS LIKELY TO LEAD
TO REAL WORLD VIOLENCE- I THINK
AGAIN SORT OF TO GO BACK TO THE
POINTS THAT BET ERIC AND I WERE
BOTH RAISING AND- IN RESPONSE
TO THE PREVIOUS SET OF
QUESTIONS. THE CONSTITUTIONAL
THRESHOLD FOR PLAN- I'M LAWS
CAN ACT BECAUSE IT LOOKS REALLY
REALISTIC THAT SOMETHING REALLY
DANGEROUS IS GOING TO HAPPEN
VERY SOON- THOSE. ARE VERY VERY
HIGH- AND THEN BEYOND THAT IF
THE IDEA IS TO PUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE FACEBOOK-
OR TWITTER OR YOUTUBE TO
IDENTIFY WHEN PARTICULAR SPEECH
HAS REACHED THAT THRESHOLD.
WHERE IT COULD IN FACT BE
LEGALLY PROHIBITED- IT IS.
UNREALISTIC I THINK TO EXPECT
THAT THEY WILL DO A GOOD JOB
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE I
THINK WE CAN PREDICT WITH
COMPLETE CERTAINTY THAT THEY
WILL DO WHAT THEY DO IN
RESPONSE TO THINGS LIKE
COPYRIGHT TAKEDOWN NOTICES
WHICH IS JUST TO ERR. VASTLY ON
THE SIDE OF TAKING DOWN MORE
CONTENT THAN THE LAW REQUIRES-
AND WE MIGHT YOU KNOW TAKING
OFF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYER
HACKS AND PUTTING ON. YOU KNOW
FOR THE PUBLIC. HATS WE MIGHT
SAY THAT'S FINE. WHAT THE A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT CONSTANT
PROTECTED SPEECH- BUT AP YOU
KNOW THAT THE LAW ISN'T ALLOWED
TO TAKE OFFICE CONSTITUTIONAL
LAWYER HAT- BUT B. YOU KNOW I
THINK UNDER THOSE STANDARDS YOU
WOULD LOSE BOTH- RIGHT WING AND
LEFT WING PROTESTS YOU WOULD
LOSE. PRO TRUMP HOPE PROTESTS
AND BLACK LIVES MATTER PROTEST
YOU WOULD LOSE- POLITICAL
ACTIVITY. ARE POTENTIALLY FROM
ALL ACROSS THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM AND REALLY AFFECT THE
ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO ORGANIZE
ONLINE WHICH SEEMS APPEALING IF
YOU DON'T LIKE THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ORGANIZING ONLINE OR OR
THINK THEY'RE DANGEROUS- AND
DISTURBING. IF YOU THINK IT IS
AN IMPORTANT EXERCISE OF RIGHTS
AND POLITICAL PARTICIPATION THE
ABILITY OF PLATFORMS IF THEY'RE
GIVEN THAT THE OBLIGATION OF
FIGURING OUT WHICH IS WHICH
THEY THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GET
THAT RIGHT WHATEVER YOU THINK
RIGHT IS YOU KNOW WHATEVER ONE
THINKS RIGHT AS THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO GET IT RIGHT- THEY
WILL JUST ERR ON THE SIDE OF
TAKING DOWN. A LOT. SO BUT THAT
THAT'S NOT QUITE MY QUESTION MY
QUESTION IS. IT IMAGINE IF WE
ENACT A LAW THAT SAYS WHEN YOU.
HAVE KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS A-
A RISK OF SERIOUS DANGER- AND
YOUR INFORMED YOU'RE THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM YOUR TOLD HEY.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE AGAIN USING THE
EXAMPLE PEOPLE ARE NOW SHOUTING
FIRES IN SHOUTING FIRE IN
THEATERS. AND WE THINK YOU
SHOULD TAKE THAT DOWN IF YOU
DON'T TAKE THAT DOWN. THEN
YOU'RE GOING TO BE HELD CIVILLY
LIABLE I THINK YOUR ANSWER IS
WE CAN'T. THE RIGHT. I THINK
UNDER CITY A TWO THIRTY YOU
CAN'T- I HAD I THINK UNDER THE
AND THAT YOU KNOW AS ERIC
MENTIONED THERE AS BECAUSE OF
ALL THE MENTIONED THAT THERE
ARE CASES THAT THAT SPEAKS OF
THIS THE IDEA OF YOU KNOW
NOTICE SPACE THE LIABILITY OR
TAKING THINGS DOWN WHEN YOU
KNOW ABOUT IT- AND COURTS HAVE
HAVE REJECTED THE IMPOSITION OF
THAT KIND OF LIABILITY. UNDER
CDA TWO THIRTY THEN YOU KNOW
SETTING TO THIRTY ASIDE IF THIS
IS PURELY A FIRST AMENDMENT
QUESTION- I THINK ULTIMATELY
WOULD HINGE ON WHAT KIND OF
KNOWLEDGE- CAN REASONABLY BE
ATTRIBUTED TO THE PLATFORM IF
WE HAVE A SYSTEM WHERE WE THINK
PLATFORMS CAN RELIABLY AND
ACCURATELY KNOW WHAT SPEECH IS
ACTUALLY ILLEGAL AND ACT
AGAINST THAT SPEECH. THAT
PUSHES YOU CLOSER TO BEING IN
THE WORLD OF A LAW THAT MIGHT
BE CONSIDERED NARROWLY TALORED
ENOUGH TO. YOU KNOW. TO ACHIEVE
A COMPELLING INTEREST WITHOUT
HAVING A BUNCH OF COLLATERAL
DAMAGE IF INSTEAD OR IF YOU'RE
A CO PRODUCTION IS THAT
PLATFORMS WON'T HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO DO A GOOD JOB
DISCERNING. LEGAL SPEECH FROM
ILLEGAL SPEECH AND YOU KNOW
ACTING ACCORDINGLY THAT GETS
YOU FARTHER AWAY FROM THE WORLD
OF YOU KNOW WHAT CONCEIVABLY A
COURT CONSIDER COULD CONSIDER
TO BE NARROWLY TAILORED- AND
THIS IS KIND OF THE LESSON OF
THIS MYTH PERSISTS CALIFORNIA
CASE THAT I MENTIONED. IT SAID
YOU CAN'T HAVE STRICT LIABILITY
BECAUSE YOU CANNOT ASSUME THAT
A BOOKSELLER IS GOING TO GO OUT
AND READ EVERYTHING ON ITS
SHELVES AND THEN THE QUESTION
IS OKAY AND YOU KNOW AT WHAT
POINT TERM. KNOWING OR BEING
CAPABLE OF KNOWING ABOUT
ILLEGAL ACTION CAN YOU IMPOSE
LIABILITY THE CLOSEST WE HAVE
TO AN INTERNET CASE ON THIS AS
A DISTRICT COURT CASE FROM THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS CALLED CDTV
PACK HURTS. IT STRUCK DOWN A I
THINK PENNSYLVANIA LAW THAT WAS
REQUIRING ISPS. TO TAKE DOWN-
TRULY HORRIFIC CONTENT TO TAKE
ON- A BLOCK SEX ABUSE. BUT THE
LAW WAS DRAFTED IN A WAY THAT
THE COURT SAID FOR SIMPLY WAS
GOING TO BE THE I ASK YOU TO GO
OUT AND WALK A BUNCH OF
INNOCUOUS CONTENT TO. AND SO IT
WAS STRUCK DOWN ON THOSE
PHONES. ALREADY THANK YOU- I
APPRECIATE IT AND AN
UNFORTUNATE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PANEL- BUT
MISS KELLER AND- PROFESSOR
GOLDMAN QUITE- INFORMATIVE. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ASSESSING THE PROBLEM. THIS
PANEL ASSESSED THE PROBLEMS
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT MORE
DETAIL OUR FIRST SPEAKER DAVE'S
A FREE- IS THEY SUFFER YOU
MISTER SURFER IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CENTER FOR.
TECHNOLOGY AND SOCIETY AT THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE KNOWN AS
THE DL HIS EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE IN THE TECH SECTOR
INCLUDING. FOUNDING MULTIPLE
START UPS AND SERVING IN
EXECUTIVE ROLES AT OTHER
ESTABLISHED TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES- AFTER. MISTER SEA
FREE THEN- SOPHIE CHONG- THE-
FORMER DATA SCIENTIST. AT OF
FACEBOOK WELL WILL TESTIFY SHE
PREVIOUSLY TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
BRITISH PARLIAMENT. AND THE
THIRD AND FINAL SPEAKER. FOR
THIS PANEL IS. DR SYLVIA CHAU.
DOCTOR SHOW IS THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF THE HEALTH
COMMUNICATION AND INFORMATICS
RESEARCH BRANCH AT THE NATIONAL
CANCER INSTITUTE. SHE'S LED A
NUMBER OF NIH INITIATIVES ON
THE ROLE OF TECHNOLOGY AND
SOCIAL MEDIA IN VARIOUS AREAS
OF HEALTH. IS MORE THAN FIFTY
SCIENTIFIC PUBLICATIONS MANY
WHICH BEEN DOCUMENTED. MANY OF
WHICH HAVE DOCUMENTED HEALTH
RELATED INTERNET USE AND ITS
IMPACT. ON INDIVIDUALS. SO LET
LET US BEGIN WITH MR FREE. ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. I AM CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
PERFECTLY. EXCELLENT MISTER
CHAIRMAN VICE CHAIR ABOARD HIS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS DAVID
SEPARATE AND I SERVED AS VICE
PRESIDENT OF MEDIAL CENTER FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND SOCIETY AND IT'S
MY PLEASURE TO SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ABOUT THE
URGENT NEED TO ADDRESS
EXTREMISM AND RADICALIZATION
THAT OCCURS ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS. FOR MORE THAN A
CENTURY DEALS MISSION HAS BEEN
TO STOP THE DEFAMATION OF THE
JEWISH PEOPLE AND TO SECURE
JUSTICE AND FAIR TREATMENT TO
ALL. WE ARE A LEADING VOICE IN
FIGHTING HATE IN ALL FORMS. MY
TEAM AT EDL WORKS TO PROTECT
VICTIMS AND TARGETS OF ONLINE
HE AND TO HOLD SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS AND DELIBERATE
INACTION. IN FOSTERING HATE AND
FERMENTING EXTREMISM AND
VIOLENCE. WE PUBLISH DATA
DRIVEN APPLIED RESEARCH BILL
TECHNICAL TOOLS THAT MEASURE
AND ANALYZE IDENTITY BASED
ONLINE HATE. AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO POLICYMAKERS
FOR CREATING A SAFER AND MORE
EQUITABLE INTERNET. BEFORE ADL
IN TWENTY NINETEEN I SPENT MY
CAREER IS AN ENTREPRENEUR AND
EXECUTIVE IN THE TECH SECTOR. A
TRAINED COMPUTER SCIENTIST I
FOUNDED IT SIX TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES AND SERVED AS AN
EXECUTIVE AT LIFT AND READ IT.
I HAVE BEEN ON THE INSIDE AND I
KNOW FIRST HAND HOW TECH
COMPANIES WORK AND HOW BUSINESS
INCENTIVES DRIVE PRODUCT POLICY
AND STRATEGY. IT'S NO SECRET.
BIG SOCIAL MEDIA COME STRUGGLE
TO MY CON WHEN THEY PLATFORMS.
AND USERS ARE AS A- OKAY TO OUR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE NASH RANKED.
SURVEY OF INTERNET USER IN THE
U. S. 41% OF RISK. HAVING SOME
SORT OF A HARASSMENT AND 27%
REPORTED EXPIRY. SOME ONLINE.
INCLUDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
STALKING AND PHYSICAL THREATS.
THAT'S MORE THAN ONE FOUR OF
YOUR FRIENDS AND COWORKERS. AND%
ONLY 14% OF THOSE WHO
EXPERIENCED PHYSICAL THREAT AND
THEN REPORTED IT SAID THE
PLATFORM TO LEAD THE
FRIGHTENING CONTENT. THE
BUSINESS MODELS OF SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES ARE BUILT IN A WAY
THAT AMPLIFIES HE- THESE
PLATFORMS MAXIMIZE PROFITS BY
PROVIDING HYPER TARGETED
ADVERTISEMENTS TO AN AUDIENCE
US. IT'S BEEN LARGE PARTS OF
OUR LIVES ONLINE. CORE PRODUCT
MECHANICS MAKE MY REALITY AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE BUILT
AROUND KEEPING YOU YOUR FRIENDS
AND YOUR FAMILY ENGAGED
TOGETHER EVEN MORE. AND SELL
EVEN MORE ASK. THE PROBLEM IS
THAT MISINFORMATION AND HATE
FILLED AND POLARIZING CONTENT
IS HIGHLY ENGAGING SO THOSE
ALGORITHMS PROMOTE THAT CONTENT.
AND IS THE DEALS ON RESEARCH
HAS LONG SUGGESTED IN FACEBOOK
WEEKS CONFIRM THESE PLATFORMS
EXPLOIT PEOPLE'S PROCLIVITY TO
INTERACT MORE WITH INCENDIARY
CONTENT AND TECH COMPANIES DO
SO WITH THE FULL KNOWLEDGE OF
THE HARMS THAT RESULT.
ULTIMATELY THESE COMPANIES TO
COLLECT OUR SAFETY AND SECURITY
BECAUSE IT'S GOOD FOR THEIR
BOTTOM LINE. LET ME TELL YOU
THAT IT'S TOO DIFFICULT TO FIX
IT OUTSIDE OF YOUR LEGAL
JURISDICTION. NONSENSE WITH NO
ACCOUNTABILITY NO REGULATION
AND NO INCENTIVES BEYOND GROWTH
AND INCREASING IN REVENUE
THEY'RE CREATING A HAVEN FOR
EXTREMISTS TO REACH RECRUIT AND
RADICALIZE. FOUR MILLIGRAMS
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE
BEHAVIORS ESPECIALLY OUR
TRACTION TO CONTROVERSIAL
EXTREMISTNARRATIVES AND AS A
RESULT SOME USERS GET TRAPPED
IN A RABBIT HOLE OF TOXIC
CONTENT PUSHING THEM TOWARDS
EXTREMISM. MICHAEL GOOD SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES IN A POSITION
WHERE THEY PLAN UNPRECEDENTED
ROLE HOSTING AND PROMOTING HATE
RACISM DISINFORMATION AND
EXTREMISM. AND THE RESEARCH
BEARS THAT OUT ACCORDING TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN STUDY FROM MIT
FALSE NEWS STORIES ON TWITTER
WERE 70% MORE LIKELY TO BE
SHARED THAN TRUE ONES. ONCE
FRINGE IDEOLOGIES THAT EXISTED
WITHIN A MINORITY ARE NOW BEING
IMPOLITE NORMALIZING RACIST
HATEFUL EXTREMIST CONTENT AS IT
SHOWS UP RIGHT NEXT TO POSTS
FROM FRIENDS AND FAMILY. MAIN
STREAM PLATFORM SERVES AS A
GATEWAY FOR EXTREMISTS TO
RECRUIT CURIOUS AND DISAFFECTED
INDIVIDUALS WITH GREAT IMPACT.
WITH BILLIONS OF USERS
ORLDWIDE THE INFLUENCE CANNOT
BE UNDERSTATED. THE EXISTENCE
AND VIRAL AMPLIFICATION OF HATE
CONTENT IN DISINFORMATION IS A
FEATURE NOT A BUG OF SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS. YOU'RE JUST A
FEW EXAMPLES OF THE HARMS THAT
HAVE RESULTED FROM ALLOWING
SOCIAL MEDIA TO GO UNCHECKED.
JUST LAST MONTH WHISTLE BLOWER
FRANCES HAUGEN MADE IT CLEAR
THAT FACEBOOK WAS AWARE BOTH.
OF BOTH OF THE ROLE ITS
PLATFORM PLAYED IN THE JANUARY
SIX INSURRECTION AND THE
BROADER ROLL THE PLATINUM
PLATES IN THE SPREAD OF
DISINFORMATION EXTREMISM AND
HATE. FACEBOOK DOCUMENTS STATED
THAT THIS COMPANY HAD EVIDENCE
THAT HE SPEECH DIVISIVE
POLITICAL SPEECH AND
MISINFORMATION ON FACEBOOK AND
ITS OTHER PRODUCTS WORK
FRACTURING SOCIETIES AROUND THE
WORLD. THIS IS NOT A SURPRISE.
SOME OF THE SITE AGREED HAVE
BEEN RECORDING FOR YEARS ON THE
IRRESPONSIBLE CHOICES THAT
THESE PLATFORMS ARE TAKING BUT
OUR SAFETY. LET ME BE CLEAR
ACADEMIC EXCUSE ME ANTI SEMITIC.
RACIST AND HATEFUL IMAGES
REVERBERATING ON BIG SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS RESULT IN
OFFLINE HEAT AND VIOLENCE
DIRECTED OF MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES IN THE UNITED
STATES CALLS TO VIOLENCE IN THE
NAME OF WHITE SUPREMACY AND THE
GREAT REPLACEMENT INSPIRED
FATAL SHOOTINGS LIKE THOSE IN
POWER WAY OF PASO IN PITTSBURGH
AND LEAD TO INJURIES AND DEATH
AT THE WHITE SUPREMACIST ATTACK
IN CHARLOTTESVILLE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. WE'VE SEEN HEALTHY
APPLICATION RECOMMENDATIONS OF
EXTREMIST GROUPS LIKE BOOGALOO.
HAS LED DIRECTLY TO OFFLINE
VIOLENCE INCLUDING RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. IN MAY TWENTY
TWENTY DAYS PATRICK UNDERWOOD
OF FEDERAL PROTECTIVE SERVICES
OFFICER FROM OAKLAND WAS KILLED
IN A DRIVE BY SHOOTING
ALLEGEDLY CARRIED OUT BY TWO
PUBLIC HEARINGS. CONNECTED
THROUGH FACEBOOK AND DISCUSSED
THE IDEA TO COMMIT THE CRIME IN
A FACEBOOK GROUP. THESE WERE
NOT LOS OUR STUDENTS FROM THE
SAME HIGH SCHOOL FACEBOOK
HELPED REUNITE THE WAY MANY OF
US HAVE REIGNITED OLD
CONNECTIONS. THE ALLEGED
ASSAILANTS HAD NEVER MET PRIOR
TO BEING CONNECTED ONLINE.
FACEBOOK PROPPANT TOGETHER
BECAUSE OF THEIR SHARED
ATTRACTION TO EXTREMIST CONTENT.
FINALLY WHEN MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR
TARGETED ONLINE WE CONSISTENTLY
SEE OFFLINE IMPLICATIONS ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
ARE STILL BEING BLAMED FOR
CREATING AND SPREADING THE
CORONA VIRUS RESULTING IN AN
UPTICK OF BOTH ONLINE
HARASSMENT AND PHYSICAL
ASSAULTS. VIDEOS ONLINE HEATING
HARASSMENT SURVEY FOUND THAT
ASIANAMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS EXPERIENCED THE
LARGEST SINGLE RISE IN SEVERE
ONLINE HARASSMENT YEAR OVER
YEAR IN COMPARISON TO OTHER
GROUPS. SIMILARLY ACCORDING TO
STOP PHD IT BEEN OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED PHYSICAL ASSAULTS
AGAINST AAPI INDIVIDUALS
NATIONWIDE SINCE MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY. ALL MY HEART AND ALL
PLAYING VIOLENCE ARE ONLY DENY
BILLION HER TWICE ESPECIALLY
FOR OUR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
SENATORS SELF REGULATION IS
CLEARLY NOT WORKING HE'S
BILLION AND TRILLION DOLLAR
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO IMPROVE SYSTEMS HI
REGIONAL STAFF AND PROVIDE REAL
TRANSPARENCY. GET THE CLAIMANTS
TO BURDENSOME WITHOUT A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS REALLY
GOING ON INSIDE OF THESE
COMPANIES WE CANNOT BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THE REAL DANGER POSED
TO THE PUBLIC WITHOUT CHANGES
TO THEIR INCENTIVE SYSTEMS WE
WILL CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
GENERATING RECORD PROFITS AT
THE EXPENSE OF OUR SAFETY AND
THE SECURITY OF OUR REPUBLIC.
SO MANY- ADVOCATES. FOR
TRANSPARENCY HAD A WHOLE
GOVERNMENT WHOLE OF SOCIETY
APPROACH INCLUDING ESTABLISHED
INITIATIVES LIKE STOPPING FOR
PROFIT BACKSPACE HE AND THE
REPAIR PLAN SO THAT WE CAN ALL
LIVE SAFELY IN ONLINE AND
OFFLINE SPACES. TRANSPARENCY
WILL SERVE AT LEAST TWO
IMPORTANT PURPOSES FIRST IT
ACTS AS A DETERRENT. ENSURING
THAT THESE PLATFORMS DON'T
CREATE HIDDEN SYSTEMS POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES AND THEN HIDE
THEM FROM THE PUBLIC. AND
SECOND IT ALLOWS POLICYMAKERS
AND THE PUBLIC DEEPER INSIGHT
INTO WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON SO
WE CAN MAKE BETTER INFORMED
POLICY. I CAME TO EDL FROM THE
TECH INDUSTRY BECAUSE I BECAME
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE NORMALIZATION OF EXTREMIST
AND BIGOTED NARRATIVES
HAPPENING IN OUR SOCIETY AND
BEING AMPLIFIED BY SOCIAL MEDIA
ALGORITHMS. KEEPING US ENGAGED
CLICKING SHARING AND COMMENTING
IN OUR NEWS FEEDS IS AT THE
HEART OF MOST OF THESE
PLATFORMS BUSINESS MODELS HAVE
SINCE MISINFORMATION AND
INCENDIARY CONTENT GETS THAT
ENGAGEMENT WE SEE THE
AMPLIFICATION OF FRENCH
IDEOLOGIES ALONGSIDE PICTURES
OF OUR KIDS. ON MAINSTREAM
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS. I'M THE
SON OF A HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR. MY
FAMILY KNOWS FIRST HAND HOW
HATE BIGOTRY AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES HAVE HORRIFIC
CONSEQUENCES WE KNOW THAT
GENOCIDES DON'T COME OUT OF
NOWHERE. AS IT'S BEEN FAMOUSLY
SAID HISTORY DOESN'T REPEAT
ITSELF BUT IT SURE DOES RHYME.
WELL THE PLATFORM STATED
INTENTION MAY BE DIFFERENT THE
IMPACT IS REAL AND MEASURABLE
AND THE STAKES COULDN'T BE
HIGHER. WE CANNOT MAKE THE SAME
MISTAKE AGAIN WE NEED
TRANSPARENCY FROM THESE
PLATFORMS ON THEIR POLICIES
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES TO BRING
AN END TO THE CYCLE OF
EXTREMISM AND WE NEED YOUR HELP
TO DO THIS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND WORKING ON A
SOLUTION TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THANK YOU MISTER
SEPARATE ALL RIGHT NEXT US
SOPHIE- JOHN. HELLO THANK YOU
EVERYONE SAKE I DO HAVE A
PRESENTATION THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO TRY SHARE RIGHT HERE JUST TO
CHECK IT'S A RENTS SEEN THIS.
WE CAN WE CAN SEE IT THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK THIS IS
ACTION I'VE ACTUALLY TESTIFIED
I'M A FACEBOOK WHISTLEBLOWER I
TESTIFIED A YEAR AGO TO THE
EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT AND A FEW
WEEKS AGO TO THE BRITISH
PARLIAMENT BUT I WAS BORN IN
CALIFORNIA I'VE LIVED IN THE
BAY FOR THE BEST SIX SIX. YEARS
SENSE I CAN SO THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO ME. AS
A CITIZEN OF THE GOLDEN STATE.
S. AND SO A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE GIVEN YOU GENERALITIES
ABOUT THE HOMES BEING DAMAGED
BY SOCIAL MEDIA I'M GOING TO
GIVE A VERY SPECIFIC THANK.
BASED ON MY OWN CLIMATE TO
FACEBOOK THAT THEY HAD
PERSONAL. EXPERIENCE AND SO I
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR FIRST
ABOUT WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT I
WORKED ON AN AUTHENTIC ACTIVITY
THE USE OF FAKE ACCOUNTS TO
SPREAD MESSAGES. TO THE AVERAGE
LAYPERSON THIS MAY SOUND
SIMILAR TO MISINFORMATION IN
FACT THEY ARE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT. IF I SAY THAT CATS
AND DOGS IT SEEMS SPECIES IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHO STATES IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S A
SCIENTIST- IT'S TEN YEAR OLD
CHILD OR- DOG PRETTY TO BE A
PERSON ON THE INTERNET IT'S
STILL MISINFORMATION. AND
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE CAN RECOGNIZE
THAT. IN A SENTENCE IN A
SENTENCE THAT IS. BY ON. SAY IF
I SET UP TWO THOUSAND TAKE
ACCOUNT. TO SAY THAT CUTS ARE
DORA. THE IS FAKE REGARDLESS OF
THE FACT THAT THERE IS NOTHING
WRONG WITH ST STE. AND FACEBOOK
WOULD BE CORRECT TO TAKE THE
STOCKTON NO MATTER HOW MUCH THE
AYE YA AFTERWARDS THAT FACEBOOK
IS CENSORING UP ACUTE CATCH
MESSAGE. AND SO PEOPLE A RIGHT
TO FREEDOM OF SPEECH A CONSTANT
OUT THERE ARE GENUINE QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHERE TO DRAW THE LINE I.
MISS REGARDS TO MISINFORMATION
AND HATE SPEECH. BUT TAKEN DOWN
TAKE A CONCERT A RAM BY A
GOVERNMENTS TO SPREAD THEIR
MESSAGE IT'S NOT ABOUT A
SNIPPET THAT SPEECH IT IS
IMPACT NECESSARY TO PROTECT
THAT FREEDOM. JUSTICE STOPPING
BALLOT BOX STUFFING IS
NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE RIGHT
TO VOTE AND THE SANCTITY OF
DEMOCRACY. I HOPE THIS IS CLEAR
AND MAKE SENSE. AND SO AND SO
AND SO ULTIMATELY THE
DICTATORSHIPS OF TODAY ARE
USING ARE USING THIS ACTIVITY
TO REPRESS THE CITIZENRY IN THE
SAME WAY THAT THE WARSAW PACT
COMMUNIST DICTATORSHIPS.
BUSTING CROWDS TO STICK
DETECTIVES WE COULDN'T
THEMSELVES AS HAVING FAR MORE
SUPPORT THAN THE ACTUALLY THAT.
GOING TO BE FOCUSING ON A VERY
SPECIFIC. THAT THEY WORKED OUT.
AND SO THIS IS IN AZERBAIJAN
SMALL NATION. IN IN THE
CAUCASUS BUT IT'S OFFICIALLY AT
THE MOXIE AND SO DEMOCRATIC
THEY MANAGED TO REDUCE ELECTION
RESULTS THE DAY BEFORE THE
ACTUAL ELECTION IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN. IT'S DEMOCRATIC IN
THE SAME WAY THAT NORTH KOREA
IS THE DEMOCRATIC PEOPLE'S
REPUBLIC. AND SOAK IN THE AND
SO. AND SO IN IN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN I DISCOVERED AT. A
DISCOVERED AN OPERATION BY THE
AS EVERY GOVERNMENT IS TO USE
FAKE ACCOUNTS TO HARASS THE AND
EVERY OPPOSITION ON MASS. SINCE
THAT TIME THE AND EVERY
GOVERNMENT STEPPED UP. ITS STEP
UP TO ARREST HIM PROTESTS. BY
THE OPPOSITION ON MASS
ARRESTING UP A STRIP PUT.
POLITICIANS ON BASS AND
EVENTUALLY WHICH IS FIGHTING
THE WAR IT RESPECT BATES AYE
MANIA. AYE UNDERSTANDS THAT ARE
AT IT BUT IN ADDITION TO THE
WAR OVER THE DISPUTED
TERRITORY. NAGORNO KARABAKH
AZERBAIJAN IS CURRENTLY ALSO
OCCUPIED INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED. THE ARMENIAN
TERRITORY. AND SO AND SO AND SO
AND SO HERE ARE SOME KEY ABOUT
HOW THIS ALL. TO END I HAVE
YOUR SCREEN FROM DOING BEST.
THIS IS THAT BY MY FOR OF THE
CAN SCREENS UP. FOR THE POOR.
AND THE IS ACTIVITY OVER TIME
IN THE BUT- IN BACK- TIME AND
SO THEY STE AND SO THE STARTED-
AND THE STARTED IN A MY NAME.
IN THE STRUCK YOU CAN SEE HOW
THEY WITH THE WITH BASIC NO ACT.
AT UNTIL THE DEATH KNELL STARTS
TIME THE STOCK FOR LUNCH AND
FROM P. ON THE PETER AT LEAST
AT IN THE EVENING THAT PERHAPS.
SIX SIX PM. TWIKI STATE WORKS.
IN THE DENSE WITH NATIONAL SUCH
AS YOUR AND NO THREATS WHICH IS
FAR. IT DIFFER FROM HIGH NORMAL.
PEOPLE BECAUSE- ACCORDING TO
THE ACT INCREASED BECAUSE
GROUPS. AND THE HER AND THE
FOCUS ENTIRE ON HER. THAT READ
MASTIC POSITION WITH. IF COLOR
YOU MAKE THE RIGHT COMMENTS
EACH MAX. AND EVEN HAS READ
QUEST SINCE THAT. IT IF YOU
WANT TO WRITE MONTHS ON THE
SAME LINE IF NOT TOO HIGH FOR
YOU RIGHT CONTAINS IT'S NOT TOO
DIFFERENT. YOUR RIGHT HAND
INSTALL. TRYING TO THEM UNIQUE.
BUT AROUND- THAT'S THING THAT'S
THAT'S THE- TRAFFIC. AS BECAUSE-
AND SENSE OF THE- GO UPDATE
WITH TO. CREATE AN OP SCORE
GREAT TO SEE. EVEN ON SOCIAL.
THAT GREW AT THE TOP. WHICH
USED TO COME. FOR BE TRONG
ABOUT BY THE VOICES OF
GOVERNMENT TROLLS WHO WAS IT
WHO ARE. NATIONAL MIGHT JUST
WORKS THE OP. OF CONTRACT AND
SAYING THAT THE GOVERNMENT WAS
NOT THE TO PAY. PROTECT AS A BY
CHUNK FROM I MEAN. WHAT SOME
RUBBISH LIKE THAT. AND SO I'VE
GIVEN THE DETACHED. OF HERE.
AND I DISCOVER THIS NOT FOR IN
IN AUGUST OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
FACEBOOK REFER. TO ACT KILL. AT
UNTIL OCTOBER TWENTY CA BY THE
TIME I GOING FOR. AND BY THE
TIME THE NECK MCCORMACK.
WACKSTAR BECAUSE OF FACEBOOK
DELAY THIS WE EFFECTIVE THE
ACCOUNTS. IN KIND BY FE. COULD
IT ALSO. GOVERNMENT OF AS A
BASE. BECAUSE THEY WITH THE
THEY CAN THE RULES OF THE TOUCH.
FACEBOOK'S BE. TO TAKE IT DOWN
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR. FOR BY
THE BY THE YOU TO THE FACTS
THEY WAITED UNTIL THE WAR. IS
DEDUCTED EVERY GOVERNMENT TO
COURT IT THE AS EVERY. THAT'S
TRUE OF THE F. F. THE NATIONAL.
ARE I DO TOO. THE IMPACT OF THE
DELIGHT I DO CAN IMPACT OF THE
TAKE. AT AT AND FACE I
UNDERSTAND THAT FACEBOOK HAS
NOT. HAS NOT DISPUTED OF THESE.
THE ARE THEY- WILL TELL YOU
THAT AIM TO THAT THAT. I AM
THEM OUT OF CONTACT. HELLO AND
SO THIS IS STILL IN UNCLE TO
DATE THE- PICKED UP FACEBOOK
HAS NOTHING THIS FROM RECURRING
AND THIS IS CRAZY. THAT I TOOK
THAT THE THEY TOOK BEST NIGHT.
AND SO YOU CAN SEE HERE THAT
STATES POSTED BY RADIO FREE
EUROPE AZERBAIJAN. WITH ARMS AT
THE MIDWEST JUST A NEWS UPDATE
ON THE SITUATION IN AZERBAIJAN.
IT RECEIVED FIVE HUNDRED AND
TEN COMMENTS SPOKE ALMOST ALL
OF WHICH WERE IN AUTHENTIC. AND
WE GENERALLY. JINGOISTIC PRO
PRO AT THAT RECOMMITMENT COULD.
AND IF YOU LOOK TO THE RIGHT
YOU CAN SEE THAT ALL OF THESE.
BY FROM IN THE THAT LOOKS LIKE
TO KEEP BUT THEY ARE NOT
ACTUALLY. DOUBT PRETENDING TO
BE YOUR- PATRIOTS IT'S A
FACEBOOK. FOR INSTANCE THE FOR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THE
NAME HAVE THE PERSON FACEBOOK
BUT PROBABLY. ALSO KIND OF.
PAGE IN FOR THEY PUT. INTENDED
FOR THE THAT AT TICO AND PER.
THE AT FACEBOOK THERE WAS
NOTHING. IT AND SOMEONE FOR
FIFTY SEVEN FACED PER TO BE WHO
DOES EXIST GIVEN ITS NAMES.
PICTURE THAT COULD BE A PERSON
I CALL THIS OF THE X. EXCEPT BY
NOW IT'S MORE THE THAT ONCE ALL.
EXPORT. AND SURFACED AND SO.
AND SO IT. AND SO. THE YEAR
THAT YOU THERE GOD. OFFICE TOOK.
IT'S NOT TO DO KEEP IT FROM
COMING BACK. IT WAS ESSENTIALLY
BACK. S. AND SO THAT WAS THE
CITY IN NATION AS A BECAUSE OF
COURSE ALSO THE UNITED STATES
AMERICANS ARE ALSO DEEPLY
DISTRESSED OF ABILITY TO STOP
THIS FOR COMMITTEE INTERFERE.
AND SO I'VE HIGHLIGHTED MAKES
THEM FROM FEBRUARY OF YEAR
IMAGE INMATES AND NORTH
CAROLINA FACED PAGE WHAT WHAT'S
WHAT'S AT THE TO KEEP FOREIGN
INTERFERE PRESENT RUSSIAN
INTERFERE BECAUSE THE THIS PAGE
WITH SPREAD WITH SPREADING
MISINFORMATION AND UNTIL
SOMETIME RESP TO PEOPLE MS
INDIA IN THE TROUT RESTAURANTS
REDICK. AND I WAS ONE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO MUST THIS THIS WAS
NOT A CASE OF RUSSIAN. THIS WAS
THE CASE OF AN NORTH CAROLINA
IN GROUP OF THE IT WILL BE A
FUNNY TO PROTECT TO BE BACK
DISCUSS RUSSIAN. TO MAKE PEOPLE
OF IT WOULD BE FUN IF IT
WEREN'T SO SAD. BUT BUT BECAUSE
OF BECAUSE IT. TEN THIS THIS
CAUSED A- TO. NOT TURN URGENT
INVESTIGATION. IN CONTRAST.
WITH BATCH. TO ACT
SIMULTANEOUSLY CASE. OF THE
CORRECTION BUT SUCH A FOR THE-
HE GUYS PUT. I WANT TO BE BUT
RECOUP. AT AT THE CASH. THAT
THAT'S THAT THIS CASE WITH AND
WE- TO THE REST GOVERNMENT. TO
KNOW SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. BUT
IT'S STILL VERY TELLING THAT
FACEBOOK'S CHOSE TO FOCUS ON
THE FIKRET. ACTIVITY OPPOSED TO
THE ACTUAL RESCUE. COMMITTEE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE THOUGHT OF
MAKES PRIORITIES IT'S PRECISELY
BY. ARE SO CONCERNED THE FOR
PLACE. AND SO AND SO AND THIS
GETS TO THE HEART OF THE
AUTOMATIC PROP THEM TO LAUNCH
THE BUT SPLIT DESPITE
FACEBOOK'S ADDRESSING IT. THE
FIRST ONE AS OTHERS HAVE THIS
IN MY EXTERNAL. THE DAMAGE TO
CREATE BY SUCH A FIVE. WE DON'T
EXPECT AND POOREST ITSELF
TOBACCO ADDICTION WE DON'T
EXPECT EQUIFAX TO STOP KIDS. IF
PERSONAL INFORMATION BREACH.
AND IN OTHER AREAS. FOR
EXTERNAL PROBLEM THE FOR THE IS
BY DOWN COULD. AND WORKERS MAKE
A DECISIONS GOVERNMENTS CAN
STEP IN. BUT THE PROBLEM IS HE
DOESN'T TAKE ACTIVITY IT'S A
QUICK PROCESS CANNOT BE SEEN
AND FAKE ACCOUNTS AND MOST
EFFECTIVE WHEN THEY'LL BE STUCK
WITH THE BILL. FACEBOOK
NATURALLY FOCUSES ON WHAT GETS
ATTENTION. IT FAKE ACTIVE BUT
GETS ATTENTION IT'S THE MOST
COMPETENT IF YOU'RE A SPY AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHO YOU ARE YOU
ARE NOT A VERY GOOD SPY AND
THAT'S WHAT JAMES BOND FOR SOME
REASON. AND SO THAT AND SO THAT
IS PRECISELY WHY IN THE IN IN
THE BEST LIGHT FACEBOOK CHOSE
TO FOCUS ON A CASE A FAKE. FAKE
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE AND
IGNORED ACTUAL PLAN BECAUSE IT
FOCUSED ON WHAT GOT CAUGHT
ATTENTION. IN ORDER TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND
IT AND RECOGNIZE IT BUT RIGHT
NOW THE ONLY GROUP THAT
UNDERSTANDS THE NATURE OF THE
PROBLEM ON SOCIAL MEDIA. OTHER
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
THEMSELVES AND THIS MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE CONSUMERS
TO MAKE EDUCATED DECISIONS OR
EVEN GOVERNMENTS TO STEP IN AND
REGULATE. BUT I THINK IT'S MY
PRESENTATION THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I TRY TO KEEP IT
SHORT DUE TO THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS. THANK YOU I'M A
STRONG VERY VERY INTERESTING-
ALL RIGHT NEXT- DR- WHEN
NEEDING SYLVIA- JOE. YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHAIRMAN LOMBERG
VICE CHAIRMAN GORGEOUS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
ISSUE OF HEALTH MISINFORMATION
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE BUT WE HAVE A
BRIEF. INTRODUCTION I WORK AT
THE NATIONAL CANCER INSTITUTE
WHICH IS PART OF IT AND I H. IN
THE HEALTH COMMUNICATION
INFORMATICS RESEARCH BRANCH
WHEN I COULD IMAGINE THAT
ECONOMIC BACKGROUND INCLUDES A
PHD IN SOCIOLOGY WITH STEAKS
AND A MASTER OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FROM THE BEAUTIFUL UC BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH. IN
ADDITION TO OVERSEEING A
PORTFOLIO OF FUNDED RESEARCH I
ALSO LET LEAD A ROBUST RESEARCH
PROGRAM ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
HEALTH COMMUNICATION AND A OVER
THE LAST FIVE FOUR YEARS WE
HAVE FOCUSED ON UNDERSTANDING
THE SPREAD OF HEALTH
MISINFORMATION RECENTLY I
SERVED AS A GUEST EDITOR FOR A
SPECIAL TEAM ISSUE ON THIS
TOPIC FOR THE AMERICAN JOURNAL
OF PUBLIC HEALTH- OUR BRANCH AT
NCI SUPPORTS RESEARCH THAT AIMS
TO REALLY OPTIMIZE
COMMUNICATION TO FACILITATE.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC STE IF
DECISION MAKING ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH WHETHER IT'S CANCER
SCREENING TOBACCO CESSATION OR
VACCINATION IN RECENT YEARS
THOUGH OUR WORK HAS BEEN
COMPLICATED BY A COMPLEX AND
EVOLVING SOCIAL CULTURAL
POLITICAL LANDSCAPE AND THE
GROWTH OF SOCIAL MEDIA AS WE
ALL KNOW FROM THIS PANDEMIC AND
OUT IT'S BEEN DEMONSTRATED
PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNICATION
STRATEGIES ARE INADEQUATE IN
THE FACE OF POLITICIZATION
POLARIZATION AND
MISINFORMATION. AND WE'RE
SEEING EVIDENCE OF
DISINFORMATION ACTORS TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF A HEALTH CRISIS
AND THE PUBLIC'S HEIGHTENED
EMOTIONS TO FURTHER THEIR
AGENDA IN FACT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF RESEARCH ON NEGATIVE
EMOTIONS SUCH AS FEAR AND ANGER
BEING EXPLOITED TO SPREAD
MISINFORMATION. ESPECIALLY
ABOUT VACCINES. SO THESE ARE.
SUGGEST TO OUR ALLY THAT THE
SPREAD OF HEALTHCARE. WILL
CONTINUE BEYOND THIS PANDEMIC
AND IS SOMETHING THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS TO WRESTLE WITH IN A
LONG TERM. SO MY BRIEF REMARKS
WILL ADDRESS THREE BROADER
POINTS WHITE HOUSE
MISINFORMATION IS A CRITICAL
BUT COMPLEX PROBLEM WHAT DO WE
KNOW. FROM OUR RESEARCH- AND
SOME KEY QUESTIONS WE NEED TO
ANSWER IN ORDER TO EFFECTIVELY
RESPOND. WE KNOW THAT TODAY
SOCIAL MEDIA HAS BECOME A
PRIMARY SOURCE OF NEWS AND
INFORMATION AND USERS ARE
SHARING THEIR HEALTH
INFORMATION ON SOCIAL MEDIA. WE
REALLY THOUGHT OF THIS AS A
VERY EXCITING OPPORTUNITY FOR
HEALTHY FOR MANY WAYS
CONNECTING PATIENTS WITH
SIMILAR HEALTH. CHALLENGES AND
OFFERING SUPPORT ONSTAGE
INFORMATION TO GATHER A HEALTHY
DIET HOWEVER THE SHARING A FULL
SPENT ON PROVEN INFORMATION ON
SOCIAL MEDIA HAS MANY
CONCERNING CONSEQUENCES FOR
HEALTH. IT COULD LEAD PEOPLE TO
MAKE HOW HARMFUL HEALTH
DECISIONS LOSE TRUST IN THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM OR SPEND
MONEY ON USELESS OR EVEN
HARMFUL TREATMENTS. HOWEVER
SOME OF THESE CONCERNS OUR
ASSUMPTIONS AND WE REALLY DO
NEED MORE EVIDENCE ON. THE
EXTENT TO WHICH. MANY. I DON'T
THINK DR JOE HANG ON FOR SECOND
THERE'S SOME INTERFERENCE OKAY.
BUT IT MAY BE IT MAY BE
SOMETHING HITTING THE
MICROPHONE YOUR MICROPHONE. NOW
I UNDERSTAND BECAUSE I'M
PUTTING MY- I PUT MY PRINT IS A
SPEECH ON MY KEYBOARD AND- OKAY
ALL RIGHT THANK. THANK YOU FOR
IT FOR LETTING ME KNOW BECAUSE
I COULDN'T TELL FROM MY END SO
I DIDN'T WANT ANYTHING TO
INTERFERE WITH YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU-
I THINK ANOTHER BIG ISSUE IS
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF RESEARCH
SHOWING THAT DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS CREATE AN IMPRESSION
THAT THERE'S NO CONSENSUS
EXISTING ON TOPICS SUCH AS
VACCINES OR CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN
IN FACT THIS SCIENCE IS LARGELY
SETTLED. SO- IF YOU SEE THAT
THERE'S REALLY A SENSE OF
APATHY OR CONFUSION OR DISTRUST
I COULD BE VERY MUCH TO IT
RESULT OF BEING. EXPOSED TO
MISINFORMATION SO PEOPLE COULD
END UP AVOIDING HEALTHCARE OR
MAKING DECISIONS THAT ARE
DETRIMENTAL TO THEIR HOUSE.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION
IS THE IMPORTANT AND THIS WAS
ALREADY HIGHLIGHTED BY DAVID.
MISTER SEA FREEZE COMMENT ABOUT
THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN REAL
WORLD AND ONLINE WORLD. SOCIAL
MEDIA INTERACTIONS HARMFUL
EFFECTS ARE ESPECIALLY GREAT
WHEN REAL WORLD INFLUENCE
TRANSLATES INTO ONLINE POWER
FOR EXAMPLE WE SAW THIS- THIS
LAST YEAR ATTEMPTS AT USING.
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS TO
EMBOLDEN RACISM AND XENOPHOBIA
ON TWITTER HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
MANY EXPERIENCING ANTI ASIAN
HATE AND VIOLENCE AND I AGE WE
HAVE A LOT OF RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATING THAT SUCH
EXPERIENCES HAVE DOCUMENTED
NEGATIVE HEALTH CONSEQUENCES.
FINALLY THE SPREAD OF
MISINFORMATION IS A COMPLEX
PROBLEM THE MORE WE GET INTO IT
THE MORE WE SEE THAT SO MUCH IS
NUANCED A LOT OF CONTENT IS NOT
PROVABLY FALSE BUT SIMPLY
MISLEADING. A BASED ON
INSINUATION OR CHOICE OF
VISUALS OR AT PERSONAL
ANECDOTES THAT ARE HARD TO
REFUTE. SO WHAT DO WE KNOW VERY
BRIEFLY I'M GOING TO SUMMARIZE
A FEW KEY TAKE AWAYS FROM
RESEARCH. THERE IS A LOT OF
RESEARCH ASSESSING THE ACCURACY
OF HEALTH. INFORMATION ON
VARIOUS HEALTH TOPICS TWO
EXAMPLES A RECENT PAPER LOOKED
AT COMMON CANCERS- BEING
COVERED ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
FOUND OVER 30% CONTAINED
MISINFORMATION AND EVEN HARM
BILL INFORMATION. AND ARE
CONTAIN MR. GARNER MORE ENGAGE
THAN THOSE WITH ACCURATE
INFORMATION. ANOTHER YOUTUBE
BASED ANALYSIS FOUND THAT
PROSTATE CANCER INFORMATION-
THE VIDEOS ON PROSTATE CANCER
AT INFORMATION AT UP 277% THAT
CONTENT BOX CONTAINED BIASED OR
FALSE CONTENT- OBVIOUSLY WE
DON'T NEED TO- I DON'T NEED TO
ELABORATE ON KOPET NINETEEN
RELATED MISINFORMATION BECAUSE
IT RUNS. FROM ORIGINS OF VIRUS
TO PROMOTING OF- PROMOTION
ABOUT IMPROVEMENT TREATMENTS.
SO I THINK THE IMPORTANT PART
IS TO MOVE BEYOND ANALYZING
CONTENT TO I INVITE. TO
IDENTIFY MAJOR SOURCES OF
MISINFORMATION AND ONES THAT
ARE MOST LIKELY TO COST HEART.
THANK SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
THE BEST PERSONALITY THE
CREATION AND MAINTENANCE OF
INFORMATION SILOS AND ECHO
CHAMBERS- WHETHER IT'S BY
RECOMMENDING SIMILAR CONTENT TO
WHAT USERS HAVE ALREADY SEEN OR
MAKING IT EASY FOR USERS TO
SELF CURATE THEIR FEET. THESE
FEATURES ARE DESIGNED TO
MAXIMIZE ENGAGEMENT AS WE KNOW
BUT THEY DO REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT INDIVIDUALS
WILL BE EXPOSED TO CONTENT THAT
CONTRADICT THEIR EXISTING VIEWS
WHICH THEN IN THE LONG RUN
MAKE. EXPOSURE TO
MISINFORMATION THAT MUCH HARDER
TO COME BACK. SALI SOME
RESEARCH SHOWING THERE ARE SOME
WAYS WE CAN ADDRESS IT. UP
WE'VE SEEN LITERATURE ON
BANKING OR CORRECTING FALSE
MISINFORMATION. IN THE REALM OF
HEALTH CAN BE EFFECTIVE HOWEVER
OUR RESEARCH AND OTHERS HAVE
SHOWN THAT CORRECTIONS ARE NOT
AS EFFECTIVE WHEN THE ISSUE HAS
BECOME POLARIZED AND VIEWS. OF
THE TOPIC HAS BECOME
ENTRENCHED. ANOTHER SOLUTION IS
MORE OF A LONG TERM ONE AIMING
AT BROADENING HEALTH LITERACY
EFFORTS TO INCREASE HEALTH
SCIENCE AND MEDIA LITERACY FOR
EXAMPLE RAISING AWARENESS THAT
THERE ARE COMMON TECHNIQUES
COMMONLY USED BY AGENTS OF
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION. USING PUBLIC'S
UNDERSTANDING THAT SCIENCE IS
INHERENTLY COMPLEX AND
EVOLVING- OR CONSIDERING
INDUCING A HEALTHY SCRATCH
SKEPTICISM TOWARDS CLAIMS THAT
ARE OVERLY SIMPLISTIC IT COULD
ALSO HELP TO DECREASE PEOPLE'S
VULNERABILITY. FINALLY WHAT ARE
SOME RESEARCH NEEDED NOW WE
NEED RESEARCH TO INFORM
MEASURES OBVIOUSLY AND I THINK
A FEW I'M JUST GONNA COME AND-
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS HI. YES I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT NUMBER ONE MORE WORK
NEEDS TO UNCOVER THE
MOTIVATIONS AND TECHNIQUES
BEHIND MISINFORMATION EFFORTS
AND REFLECT THESE KNOWLEDGE IN
ALGORITHMICS DESIGNS AND
PRACTICAL CHANGES IF WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE ROOT CAUSES OF
MISINFORMATION WE WILL CONTINUE
TO PLAY A GAME OF WHACK A MOLE
WHERE EVERY WITH EVERY PIECE OF
NEW MISINFORMATION THAT
EMERGES. SO IN OTHER WORDS AND
WE'VE PROBABLY HEARD THE SHOTS
THROUGHOUT THE TESTING-
TESTIFIED MONIES THAT WE NEED A
SYSTEMIC STRUCTURAL APPROACHES
INSTEAD OF PATCHWORK BANDAID
SOLUTIONS I'M PART OF THIS
APPROACH INCLUDES WORK TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND MOVEMENT. OF
MISINFORMATION ACROSS PLATFORMS
AND ACROSS DIFFERENT. LANGUAGES
AND SORT OF THINKING ABOUT
SOCIAL MEDIA AS AN ECO SYSTEM
THAT'S BOTH DECENTRALIZED. BUT
INTERCONNECTED. MOREOVER WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF CONTENT
MODERATION EFFORTS DONE BY
PLATFORMS. TO THE STATE THERE
IS SO LITTLE KNOWN ABOUT
OUTSIDE THE COMPANIES SO MORE
ACCESS TO DATA AND TRANSPARENCY
WOULD ENABLE RESEARCHERS TO
EVALUATE THE DIFFERENTIAL
EFFECTS OF CHANGING PRACTICES.
IN FACT ACTUALLY MITIGATION
MEASURES COULD LEAD TO SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS
CREATING AN INFORMATION VACUUM
AND WE SEEN THIS WITHOUT ONE
STUDY LOOKING AT HPV VACCINE
INFORMATION ON PINTEREST. AFTER
CONTENT MODERATION POLICIES
WERE IN PLACE BOTH- CREDIBLE
AND NON CREDIBLE INFORMATION
WERE REDUCED. THE OVERALL
AMOUNT OF HPV VACCINATION
CONTENT WAS WAS BASICALLY ARE
GREATLY REDUCED SO I THINK THIS
IS ALSO A REMINDER WE CAN JUST
REMOVE BAD COUNT CONTENT BUT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
PROVIDING. EVIDENCE BASED
INFORMATION ON THE SIDE- THE
LAST POINT IS I THINK WE NEED
TO AND I AND I AGE WE FOCUS SO
MUCH OF OUR WORK ON ADDRESSING
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
PROMOTING HEALTH EQUITY. SO WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT
OF EXPOSURE TO MISINFORMATION
ESPECIALLY ON THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES- WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN MISINFORMATION AND
HEALTH DISPARITIES IT COULD BE
THAT BY ENDORSING
MISINFORMATION AND BEHAVING IN
SUCH A WAY. IN ONE COMMUNITY
FOR EXAMPLE WOULD ENSURE TO
MIDDLE CLASS INDIVIDUALS
REFUSING VACCINATIONS FOR
CORBETT AND NOT WEARING MASKS
INDOORS COULD STILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY HURT THE
POOR OR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
SO YOU THINK ABOUT A VACCINATED
CUSTOMER MARKET CLERK WITH
CHRONIC DISEASE WORKING IN THAT
AREA WITH LOW VACCINE UPTAKE
FOR EXAMPLES. SO MY FINAL
THOUGHT TO END IS THAT
MISINFORMATION IS A COMPLEX
CHALLENGE AND HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO CAUSE GREAT HARM TO THE
PUBLIC'S HEALTH- I'M CITING THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL'S
ADVISORY. WE DO NEED A WHOLE OF
SOCIETY APPROACH TO
SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESSED HIS
PROBLEM. THANK YOU I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. AND I. FOR MY
SHUFFLING OF PAPER ON OVERLY
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU DR-
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THE CENTER
STONE YES. BERMAN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MAYBE FOR- THE
PREVIOUS PANELIST- DOCTORED
SHOW AND THEN PERHAPS FOR
MISTER SEA FREE AS WELL. EIGHT
EIGHT SIMILAR QUESTION THAT I
ASKED OF THE PREVIOUS PANELS IN
TERMS OF QUANTIFYING- OR IN
SOME WAY PROVIDING SOME
ESTIMATE OF THE OVERALL SOCIAL
COST- DOCTOR CHOU IN THE IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONTEXT. ARE
THERE ANY EFFORTS TO ACTUALLY
SCOPE OUT WHAT THE IMPACT OF
THIS MISINFORMATION- HAS BEEN
ON OUR PANDEMIC AND WHAT THE
ADDITIONAL COSTS ESSENTIALLY OF
HAVING THESE PLATFORMS AS- AS
NETWORKS FOR SUCH
MISINFORMATION IN OTHER WORDS
THE- WITHOUT. THAT SPEED OF
TRAVEL OF INFORMATION FLOW
WOULD WE HAVE LOST. FEWER
PEOPLE TO COVERT AND HOW MANY
FEWER PEOPLE MIGHT WE HAVE LOST
AND HOW HOW MUCH MORE LIFE
MIGHT WE'VE SAVED HAVE YOU HAVE
YOU LOOKED INTO. THAT SORT OF
SCOPE OF INQUIRY. THANK YOU-
FOR YOUR QUESTION- I CAN'T GIVE
YOU A SPECIFIC NUMBERS
UNFORTUNATELY BUT I DO WANT TO
SAY THIS IS A BIG BIG AREA
EMERGING AREA OF RESEARCH I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF DATA AND
WHAT THE WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE
IS TO CONNECT THE DOTS SO WE
HAVE THE EVIDENCE OF
MISINFORMATION EXPOSURE WE CAN.
QUANTIFY YOU KNOW ON THIS
PLATFORM ON THIS TOPIC THERE IS
A LOT OF MISINFORMATION THIS
AMOUNT. NOW WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH THAT EXPOSURE TRANSLATES
TO INDIVIDUALS BEHAVIORS-
THERE'S DEFINITELY SOME
NATIONAL DATA THE PEW DATA-
TIZER FAMILY FOUNDATION AND ANY
OTHERS THAT HAVE BEEN SAY
LOOKING AT IN THE SPECIFIC
CONTEXT OF THIS PANDEMIC.
LOOKING AT AXING HESITANCY AND
MEASURING KIND OF ENDORSEMENT
OF SIR TEN MINUTES AND YOU KNOW
CLAIMS THAT ARE NOT A FALSE
CLAIMS ARE LINKED TO A
HESITANCY OR REFUSAL OF
VACCINATION- SO I DO THINK
THERE ARE DIFFERENT WAYS WE
CONNECT THE DOTS WHERE WE SEE
THAT MISINFORMATION DUST.
TRANSLATE INTO HOLES AND DOG
IMPACTS AND LIVES LOST AND LYFT
SAVED- BUT I DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC NUMBERS I DO THINK
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT PRIORITY
FOR US FOR US AT NIH AS WELL AS
YOU KNOW MANY MANY OTHER
YOU IN THE RESEARCH COMMUNITY
NEEDED CURRENTLY ISN'T BEING
DISCLOSED TO PROVIDE THAT. THAT
SORT OF RESEARCH BASED THAT.
THE DOT CONNECTING EXERCISE HE
SPOKE OF. I THINK NUMBER ONE-
WE LOOK AT HOW DO WE DO INVITE
SCANS SO WE CAN SAY ON FACEBOOK
WE COUNT YOU KNOW A LOT OF
COUNTING AND EVALUATION. WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE DATA ON WHO
IS ACTUALLY SEEING IT AND
HOUSING AND AFFECTS THE
BEHAVIOR SO I THINK WE NEED TO.
OBSTACLE MORE SURVEYS THAT'S
LOOKING AT EXPOSURE AND LINKING
IT TO OUTCOMES WE ALSO NEED-
YOU KNOW DATA FROM OTHER
SOURCES SUCH AS YOU KNOW
PLATFORM DATA WHICH I'M A
SOCIAL SCIENCE RESEARCHERS
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO- YOU KNOW
TO UNDERSTAND THE MOVEMENTS ON
THESE DIFFERENT PLATFORMS SO
YOU CAN ACTUALLY LINK. EXPOSURE
TO OUTCOMES. UNDERSTOOD LAST
QUESTION AS- FOR THERE ARE
FIRST HAND PANEL SITTING
MISCHIEF REEF WITH THE DEAL
YOU'D MENTIONED IT A FEW OF
THE- PROACTIVE INITIATIVES OUT
THERE TO- TRY TO MITIGATE SOME
OF THESE EFFECTS. DO YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF WHETHER THE- TECH
INDUSTRY WRIT LARGE- SOCIAL
MEDIA. THE COMPANY'S READ
LARGER EVEN INDIVIDUALLY ARE
ASSISTING- WITH ANY OF THESE
EIGHTY L. OR OTHER EFFORTS OUT
THERE TO. COMBAT HATRED OR SORT
OF DEAL WITH SOME OF THESE.
SOCIAL EXTERNALITIES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR I YES OF.
LISTEN MY DAY JOB I SIT AND I
TALK TO SENIOR EXECUTIVES AT
ALL OF THE MAJOR LARGE
PLATFORMS RIGHT THEY THEY THEY
ARE CONCERNED- THE PROBLEM HERE
IS INCENTIVE SYSTEMS. AND ALSO
THE YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT
THESE BUSINESS MODELS ARE TUNED
IN SUCH A WAY THAT CONTENT
MODERATION IN REDUCING THE HEAT
RIGHT WHAT I DON'T BELIEVE
ANYBODY AT ANY OF THESE MAJOR
PLATFORMS GOES INTO WORK SAYING
GEE HOW CAN I CREATE MORE HEAT
OR SEE MORE GENOCIDES. OCCUR
BUT WHAT REALLY IS GOING ON
HERE IS THAT THE INTERNAL
INCENTIVE SYSTEMS ARE DIS
INCENTIVIZING INCLUDING THE
RIGHT RESOURCES ON TO SOLVING
THE PROBLEM AND IN FACT. ARE
CREATING INCENTIVES THAT
EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM MORE
DEEPLY AND SO THE REAL
CHALLENGE HERE IS YOU KNOW HOW
DO WE CHANGE THE INCENTIVE
SYSTEM SO THAT. THESE
INCREDIBLE COMPANIES WILL
ACTUALLY BE ABLE. IN THE
RATIONAL MANNER TO. BE ABLE TO
FIGHT THIS KIND F HATE TO YOU
KNOW REDUCE AND REMOVE THESE
PEOPLE FROM THEIR PLATFORMS BUT
RIGHT NOW THERE IS NO
DISINCENTIVE IN IN FACT. YOU
KNOW THE VETERANS THIS IS WHY
TRANSPARENCY IS SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND WHY TRANSPARENCY
AT THE LEVEL OF AGGREGATE
STATISTICS RIGHT WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT FINDING OUT WHAT
WHAT'S GOING ON ONE PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUAL INVESTIGATION HERE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. WHAT
ACTUALLY ARE YOUR POLICIES. YOU
KNOW WHO THEM OUT CLEARLY AND
THEY HOW DO YOU ACT IN. THAT
POLICY WHAT WERE THE DIFFERENT
BEHAVIORS AND ACTIONS THAT YOU
TOOK AND HOW EFFECTIVE WERE THE
EIGHT. AND YOU KNOW THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY NUMBER ONE. COULD PUT
THE COMPANIES IN A PLACE WHERE
THEY CAN'T HAVE SECRET POLICIES
THEY CAN'T HAVE JUST SORT OF
EXCEPTIONS THAT THEY CHOOSE TO
ME FOR A PARTICULAR CELEBRITY
OR POLITICIAN OR RELIGIOUS
LEADER. YOU KNOW WHAT WE FOUND
INTERESTING LEVY TOOK A WHISTLE
BLOWER IN THE- RIGHT TO FIND
OUT THAT FACEBOOK HAD. A SORT
OF SHADOW POLICY SYSTEM CALLED
CROSS CHECK. WHERE YOU KNOW IT
WAS INTENDED ORIGINALLY TO HELP.
THAT THAT THERE WOULDN'T OVER
ENFORCEMENT OF CERTAIN KINDS OF
BEHAVIORS- WHERE THEY SAID OKAY
WELL YOU KNOW FOR CELEBRITIES
ARE CERTAIN POLITICAL
INFLUENCERS LIKE. THAT THEY
WOULD- THAT THEY WOULD- IT GET
MANUAL REVIEW HERE'S WHAT
HAPPENED FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION PEOPLE. ENDED UP IN
THAT SYSTEM ACCORDING TO THESE
DOCUMENTS AND SO THAT'S JUST
COMPLETELY UNTENABLE IT
ESSENTIALLY MEANT THAT THESE
CELEBRITIES AND POLITICIANS WHO
BY THE WAY DRIVING GAUGE MEANT.
RIGHT THESE RELIGIOUS FIGURES
THAT YOU HELP EVEN PEOPLE'S
PETS WHO ARE POPULAR THAT THE
WORD IN MANY CASES ALLOWED TO
COMPLETELY FREE RIDE. AND THAT
THERE IS NO NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ENFORCE WHERE THERE WAS NO ONE
FORCED ME. OF THEIR POLICIES
THAT THEY HAVE SO STEP ONE IS
WE NEED TO GET SOME REALLY
CLEAR TRANSPARENCY ON WHAT'S
ACTUALLY GOING ON. AND THEN
NUMBER TWO WE CAN LOOK AT WHAT
ARE THOSE BEHAVIORS WHAT ARE
THE DIFFERENT KINDS OF. CHANGES
THAT THEY'RE MAKING TO THEIR
INCENTIVE SYSTEMS AND TO THE
PRODUCTS THAT ACTUALLY HELP TO
MITIGATE THIS HATE SO I DO
THIS. AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
COMPANIES THEMSELVES ALL OF
THEM HAVE TO MEET THIS MINIMUM
BAR THEY'LL ACTUALLY BE
INCENTIVIZED TO COMPETE ON HOW
WELL THEY'RE PROTECTING US ON
HOW WELL THEY ARE ACTUALLY
IMPROVING THEIR SYSTEMS. AND
THAT NO ONE WANTS TO BE THE ONE
WHO IS DOING A WORSE JOB BUT
TODAY THERE'S NO INCENTIVE
BECAUSE- IF I GO I'VE BEEN TOLD
YOU KNOW IF ONE COMPANY GOES
OUT AND SAYS ONE THING THERE'S
NO INCENTIVE OR OR NEED FOR
ANOTHER COMPANY TO DO THE SAME.
SO THEY ALL LOOK BAD I DON'T
WANT TO JUST PRESENT A FACE.
AND THAT IS A PROBLEM SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S REALLY AT THE
CORE IF WE NEED. TO UNDERSTAND
BETTER WHAT'S GOING ON. THANK
YOU- THANK YOU MISTER SIR. AND
THANKS TO ALL OF ALL OF YOU FOR
PULLING OUT CHANNEL. THAT EXIST-
THE MISINFORMATION EXPLOITATION
HARASSMENT I I'VE GOT A
QUESTION. FOR MR JONG- CENTER
STERN AND I ARE BOTH FORMER
CHAIRS ELECTIONS COMMITTEE AND
IN THE- EVENT THAT YOU POINT
OUT OF. REGARDING AZERBAIJAN
ARE REALLY FRIGHTENING- IN ANY
COMMENT ON. WHAT WE CAN DO HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES OR OR WHAT
THE- ATTENTION HERE'S AND I
STATES TO HAVE A SIMILAR
INSTANCES OCCUR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE QUESTIONS AND
FUNDAMENTALLY FUNDAMENTALLY THE
WAY I WOULD DESCRIBE IT IT'S
THAT IT'S THAT'S THE SITUATION
IN AZERBAIJAN AND ON THE REST
OF THE NATION'S A CARBON
DICTATE CHRIS ESSENTIALLY HAVE
THE NATION AT THE PLAYGROUND
THE USE REPRESSIVE TOOLS TO
HARASS AND EXPLOIT THE ONSET
THE CITIZENRY AND OF COURSE THE
CONFINED SPACE TO BRING THAT.
INTO THE DIFFICULT ROAD. AND
SPEND BUT AND SO THEY SITUATION
AND SO THERE IS THIRTY. THE
SITUATION UNITED STATES ITS
SEARCH NOT THAT WE ARE NOT A
RISK SEEN OUR ON THE GO. RUN
TAKE SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS
THANK. A CALL. UP TO THIS
ANYMORE THAN BE AT RISK OF MASS
ARRESTS OF ALL PUT THIS LEADERS
AS OCCURRED AS A- OR IF AS A
BETA IS EFFECTIVE A BAND KEEP
IT. AND BUT IT BUT AND SPENT
THIS POINTS TO AS AT SIX I
THINK OF THE ROLE FACTORS. THE
CULTURE. IN THE SENSE THAT IN
THE SENSE THAT. IT AMERICA'S
DEMOCRACY WITH THE IN SEE
RUSSIA IS A FASCINATING BUT
THESE ARE NOT DEMOCRACIES IN
THE SAME BAY AND SO BOTH LINES
CAN DOES MAYBE COMMON SOME
DEMOCRACIES. IN OTHERS THAT
CLEARLY STATES IT WOULD BE A
MASSIVE SCALE AND- AND
UNSINKABLE IF IT IF IT
OCCURRED. AND SO ULTIMATELY.
WHEN IT'S NOT. OF LIKE THE
MEETING IT IN IT THAT'S THE
VICE OTHER BY. OTHERWISE THEY'D
GET BRAKE THEY OPEN CASE AT AND
FOR AND FOR THE MARI MOTORISTS
WILL BE BOENNING KIDDING POSE A
POLITICAL. ON THOSE WHO COMMIT
IT CRIMES IN THE IN THE. ALL MY
AND SO THAT'S WHY IT'S THE IT
SO. TO IN THE UNITED STATES. TO
TREAT CASE OF THAT SORT OF A
HARSH THE LIKE FOR INSTANCE IN
THE IN THE IN U. S. CUT EIGHT
IT LOOKS I WILL ONE I WAS ONE
OF. THE FEW ONE OF MANY PEOPLE
ACTUALLY WHO'VE ON WEST TO GET.
APART AS HE PUT THAT GROUP THAT
WAS THAT WAS RUNNING ADVERTISE.
IF US SO PARTY KIT SPADE. IT TO
SPLIT THE VOTE AND THIS AND
THIS ITEM GROUP CLAIMS TO BE AT
LEAST ADVERTISING TO BE ON THE
AS OF A SEARCH PARTY. BUT
FACEBOOK AND THE INVESTIGATOR
NEW PROOF VALID IT WAS AT. IT
BATES BATES BATES MAKE A MAJOR
PUSH PARTY WITH SUPPORTERS OF
MAJOR POLITICAL WO HOPING JUST
COULD IT WILL HELP YOU THE
QUOTE AND- FOR TO ACT BEFORE
EXAMPLE OF A KEY THAT WOULD. TO
AS VERY CONCERNING WHAT FOR
MYSELF AS TO HOW YOU CAN AVOID
DOWN THE ROAD THAT SNAKES SUCH
AS- AS IT RAGED. BECAUSE WHEN
THE RULE OF DAHLE NOT A- FORCED.
IN KENYA FOR THE INFO TO AND
JUSTICE FOR EVERYONE ELSE THAT
IS NOT TO SIT. IT IS A HIGH.
THAT DECATUR SUCH THE PEOPLE
REPUBLIC OF CHINA. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU TO ALL
THREE ALL THE OF YOU FOR. THAT
AND FOR- THIS IS A CONTINUING
PROCESS AS YOU KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT. UP
IS A LEGISLATION THAT HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU. OUR NEXT PANEL WHAT
IS BEING DONE TO ADDRESS. THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE JUST BEEN-
ELUCIDATED DURING THE COURSE OF
THE HEARING AND WHAT CAN BE
DONE IN CALIFORNIA- SO- WE HAVE.
STATE ILLUSTRIOUS PANEL HERE OF
FIRST WE HAVE OF MISTER DYLAN
HOFFMAN- MISTER HOFFMAN ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. FROM THE- INTERNET
ASSOCIATION. YES I AM ME MR YES.
IT WAS A GREAT PLEASURES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
STILL IN HOSPITAL DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR- INTERNET ASSOCIATION- WE
REPRESENT OVER FORTY OF THE
WORLD'S LEADING INTERNET BASED
COMPANIES- AN ARMADA MISSION IS
TO FOSTER INNOVATION PROMOTE
ECONOMIC GROWTH- EMPOWER PEOPLE
SHOULD IT'S FREE AND OPEN
INTERNET. HE REPRESENTED OF-
MEMBERS INCLUDING MANY OF THE
LEADING SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS-
AND EVEN WITHIN THOSE COMPANIES
THERE'S TREMENDOUS VARIATION-
AMONG SOME- IN TERMS OF- THE
MEDIUM OF THE CONTENT ON THE
SIZE AND OTHER BUSINESS MODELS-
BUT I WILL JUST ALSO POINT OUT
THAT. MODERATION IMPACTS MORE
THAN THAN SOCIAL MEDIA AND A
VERY BROAD SENSE THERE ARE A
LOT OF- WEBSITES PUBLICATIONS
FORUMS BLOGS THAT HAVE TO
MODERATE THEIR CONTENT- SO JUST
WANTED TO QUICKLY POINT OUT
THAT- WHILE WE ARE SPEAKING
ABOUT THE SOCIAL. MEDIA
CONTEXT- THAT WHEN WE'RE
DESIGNING RULES AROUND CONTENT
MODERATION I CAN BLEED OUT AND
SAID THE INTERNET ECOSYSTEM-
AND THANK YOU FOR. ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT TODAY- PEOPLE ARE
USING IT AND SOCIAL MEDIA.
CONNECT AND TRYING COMMUNITY
LIKE NEVER BEFORE- AND TODAY'S
WORLD HAS SHOWN BOTH THE
TANGIBLE BENEFITS OF ONLINE
SERVICES. AND THE CRITICAL ROLE
PROVIDERS PLAN ENSURING THAT
THEIR SERVICES ARE NOT
UNDERMINED- AND MISUSED IN WAYS
THAT THREATEN INDIVIDUAL LIVES
ARE THE PUBLIC CRIED. OUT
SOCIAL MEDIA HAS A LOT OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE GLOBE TO STAY
CONNECTED DURING THIS I'M GOING
TO MAKE. THAT'S ALSO HELP
FACILITATE THE ORGANIZATION OF
UNPRECEDENTED PROTESTS FOR
SOCIAL JUSTICE NOT JUST AND
CALIFORNIANS NATION BUT- OUR
WORLDWIDE- HOWEVER A NUMBER OF
OUR USERS CONTINUE TO MISUSE
OUR PLATFORMS TO MISLEAD.
HARASS AND EXPLOIT OTHERS
ENGAGE IN ILLICIT CONDUCT. I A
MEMBER COMPANIES RECOGNIZE THAT
IN ORDER TO REALIZE THE FULL
BENEFITS OF THE INTERNET IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THEY TAKE ACTION.
TO PREVENT AND RESPOND TO
HARMFUL ONLINE ACTIVITIES HI
THIS IS ESSENTIAL TO BUILDING
AND. MAINTAINING BOTH USER AND
PUBLIC TRUST. OUR BEFORE
GETTING IN OUR- CONTENT
MODERATION AFTER AND FIRST LIKE
TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT ABOUT SOME OF THE- ARE
COMPANIES- WHEN MODERN CONTENT
THE LAST. CONTENT MODERATION IS
CHALLENGING COMPLEX AND
NECESSARY WORK. EVERYDAY USERS
POST BILLIONS OF PIECES OF
CONTENT ONLINE- OVERWHELMINGLY
OUR USERS POST PICTURES VIDEOS-
BRITAIN IDEAS THAT ARE
INFORMATIVE EDUCATIONAL
INSPIRING HEARTWARMING.
OFTENTIMES VERY FUNNY- IF YOU
FOLLOW A LOT OF MEME PAGES- BUT
GENERALLY- THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF CONTENT IS. A
POLITICAL EVEN IN AN ELECTION
YEAR- BUT EVERY MINUTE- AND
IT'S ALL SPEAK FOR TEN MINUTES
ARE YOU CAN DO THE MATH HERE
BUT EVERY MINUTE. OTHER FOUR
HUNDRED HOURS OF VIDEO UPLOADED
TO YOUTUBE- THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TWEETS-
THAT WILL BE SENT- AND SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND PHOTOS AND
VIDEOS. WILL BE UPLOADED ON
INSTAGRAM. AND LIKE I SAID
WHILE MOST OF THE CONTENT ON
OUR PLATFORM JUST FUNNY OR
INFORMATIVE- OUR DIGITAL WORLD
REALLY TENDS TO MIRROR THE REAL
ONE- IN OTHER WORDS. ILLEGAL
HATEFUL AND ABUSIVE CONTENT
DIDN'T START ONLINE BUT AS
INTERNET COMPANIES WE RECOGNIZE
THAT OUR PLATFORMS CREATE NEW
CHALLENGES FOR CITIZENS.
PARENTS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
POLICY MAKERS. THE INTERNET
INDUSTRY TAKES SERIOUSLY ITS
RESPONSIBILITY TO MITIGATE THE
SPREAD OF ILLEGAL HARMFUL AND
UNWANTED CONTENT. TO BE VERY
CLEAR WE DON'T TOLERATE MORE
ONE ILLEGAL CONTENT OR CONTENT
THAT VIOLATES OUR RULES ON OUR
PLATFORMS FOR THAT HARMS OUR
USERS. I REMEMBER COME TO TERMS
OF SERVICE DO NOT PERMIT
CONTENT THAT IS ILLEGAL AND
EAST PLATFORM ESTABLISHES
COMMUNITY GUIDELINES ABOUT
HARMFUL CUTS. FOR COMPANIES
CONTENT VIOLATES THEIR POLICIES
THEY WILL ACT. IN MANY CASES
ILLEGAL AND HARMFUL CONTENT IS
BLOCKED BEFORE IT'S EVER POSTED.
OR QUICKLY TAKEN DOWN. OUR
COMPANIES HAVE COM JUST- SO AS
A LOT OF SYSTEMS ARTIFICE
INTELLIGENCE AND MACHINE. WE'RE
JUST SHUFFLING WITH WATER FOR
MY VERY USED CONTEXT NECESSARY
CONTEXT I WINNER VALUED IN GRAY
AREAS- WITH OF HARMFUL CONTENT.
ROSSI'S USER COMPLAINTS TO HELP
SCREEN AND REMOVES CLOSE-
IMAGES VIDEOS. OR OTHER CONTENT
THAT VIOLATES THE LAW OR OUR
COMMUNITY STANDARDS. ARE ONE
USEFUL EXAMPLE- IS SPAM. AND
SCAMS. SPAM AND CAMS WERE
AMONG THE EARLIEST TARGETS OF
PROACTIVE CONTENT MODERATION
EFFORTS I'M AN EXAMPLE OF SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE
IN KEEPING PACE WITH BAD
ACTORS. ACCORDING TO THE COURT
DETERMINED TO MISUSE OUR
SERVICES- TRANSACTION HAS
EVOLVED OVER TIME- FROM VERY
SIMPLE TECHNIQUES SUCH AS BLOCK
WEST. AND RATE LIMITING ON
CERTAIN ACCOUNTS. TO MORE
SOPHISTICATED AUTOMATED SYSTEMS
BY MANY OF THE EARLY TECHNIQUES
REMAIN IMPORTANT TOOLS I NEW
ALGORITHMIC APPROACHES- THAT
WHOLE SIGNALS FROM A VARIETY OF
SOURCES ARE CENTRAL TODAY TO
KEEP UP. THE BATTLE BETWEEN
SPAMMERS AND APART FROM CAN BE
CHARACTERIZED AS ARMS RACE-
ESTIMATES QUICKLY ADAPT TO
DETECTION TECHNIQUES AND
PROVIDERS MUST CONTINUALLY
RESPOND- OUR COMPANIES HAVE
APPLIED MANY OF THE TECHNIQUES
AND LESSONS LEARNED FROM
PROTECTING PEOPLE FROM BEING
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF IN THIS
CONTEXT. TO OTHER FORMS OF
HARMFUL CONTENT. SO I WILL JUST
PAUSE TO NOTE THAT MODERATION
IS MUCH EASIER FOR ISSUES AND
TOPICS THAT FALL INTO AN EASY
DICHOTOMY. BY FORMS OF ILLEGAL
CONTENT AND EVEN- SPAM. HOWEVER
INCREASINGLY ARE ONLINE
DISCOURSE FALLS INTO VARYING
SHADES OF GRAY I'M PARTICULARLY
IN AND MISINFORMATION. AND
IDENTIFYING AND REMOVING
VIOLATIVE CONTENT CAN BE
INCREDIBLY SUBJECTIVE WORK.
GIVEN THE ENORMOUS VOLUMEOF
CONTENT ONLINE AND THE
OFTENTIMES NUANCED DISTINCTIONS
ABOUT WHETHER CONTENT VIOLATES
COMMUNITY STANDARDS- I IS
MEMBER COMPANIES WORK HARD TO
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN FACILITATING SPEECH-
AND MITIGATING HARM. OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES RECOGNIZE THAT THEY
DO NOT ALWAYS ACHIEVES THE
PERFECT BALANCE- BUT THEY'RE
CONSTANTLY LEARNING AND ACTING
NOT GETTING THEIR APPROACHES-
WE ARE BY NO MEANS FIRST- AND
THEY'RE ALL. BE ROOM FOR
IMPROVED- WITH BILLION OF
PIECES OF CONTENT EVERY DAY
THERE WILL BE NO OF MISSED-
INSTANCES WHERE WE- MISS CLASS.
OR TO MAKE IT CHOI. ARE BOUND
HAPPEN. WITH THE IMMENSE. OF
CONTENT ON OUR PLATFORMS I JUST
ON ONE PLATFORM ALONE IN ABOUT
AN HOUR THE FIRST HOUR OF THIS
PRESENTATION FOR EXAMPLE. THERE
WERE ABOUT ONE POINT TWO
MILLION PIECES OF CONTENT
REMOVED FROM THE PLATFORM THAT
VIOLATED RULES AND THAT'S- THAT
DOESN'T SPEAK TO THE NUMBER OF
DECISIONS THAT HAD TO BE MADE.
ABOUT THINGS THAT WERE LAST UP.
AND SO EVEN IF WE WERE NINETY
NINE POINT 9% ACCURATE. THAT IS
REMEMBER REMOVED NINETY NINE
POINT 9% OF ALL CONTENT WE
SHOULD HAVE REMOVED- AND WE
LEFT AT NINETY NINE POINT 9% OF
ALL CONTENT WE SHOULD'VE LEFT
UP. I WE WOULD STILL BE MAKING
MILLIONS OF MISTAKES EVERY
WEEK. AND SO I SAY THIS TO JUST
REINFORCE THAT BALANCING THE
JUST INTEREST IS DIFFICULT- AND
ESPECIALLY SO WHEN IT COMES TO
MISINFORMATION ANOTHER
SUBJECTIVE CATEGORIES.
UNIVERSALLY X. THAT'S- OF HATE
SPEECH MR. DON'T NECESSARILY
EXIST AND IT CAN BE REALLY
DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY- AND
PEOPLE WILL DISAGREE- OFTEN
AND- AS TO WHAT- WHETHER IT'S
ALLOWED OR NOT UNDER OUR RULES-
AND EVEN IF THERE WERE- UNIFIED
DEFINITIONS BUT IS OFTEN VERY
DIFFICULT TO OPERATIONALIZE-
THESE VALUE JUDGMENTS
ESPECIALLY AT THE SCALE. BOB AS
NOTED BY PREVIOUS PANELISTS A
SECTION TWO THIRTY IN THE FIRST
AMENDMENT ENABLE ONLINE
COMPANIES THE FLEXIBILITY TAKE
ACTIONS AGAINST HARMFUL AND
ILLEGAL CONTENT WITHOUT HAVING
TO CHASE SIGNIFICANT
LITIGATION. OR REGULATORY
BURDENS WHICH WOULD DISCOURAGE
INNOVATION AND INVESTMENT. AND
THOSE INVESTMENTS WOULD
CONTINUE MAKING THE INTERNET A
BETTER SAFER EXPERIENCE FOR
EVERYONE. IN THIS FLEXIBILITY
ISSUE TO COMBAT IN CONSTANTLY
EVOLVING- THREATS AND SO WITH
THAT IN MIND I WOULD LIKE TO
DISCUSS A FEW CONSIDERATIONS
FOR THIS COMMITTEE- IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED ALREADY BUT
TRANSPARENCY REPORTING THIS IS
JUST ONE ISSUE WITH AND CONCEPT
MODERATION THAT THIS COMMITTEE
HAS CONSIDERED- IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION- AND MANY
OF OUR PLATFORMS RECOGNIZE THE
BENEFIT. OF INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY. ABOUT THEIR
CONTENT MODERATION EFFORTS- AND
ALREADY REALLY SUBSTANTIAL
TRANSPARENCY REPORTS AND HERE
LIKE TO PAUSE AND JUST- SHARE A
COUPLE QUICK SLIDES JUST AS A
VISUAL- SO THAT EVERYBODY CAN
SEE- SOME OF OUR OUR CURRENT
EFFORTS AND IT WILL JUST CARRY
OUT THIS- THESE ARE ONLY TWO OF
OUR OUR COMPANIES. OUR RECORDS-
AND THAT THERE IS A VARIETY
BETWEEN WHAT IS BEING REPORTED-
AND THE INFORMATION. ON THIS
REPORT- SO HERE WE HAVE-
FACEBOOK'S I'M STUCK QUARTER TO
TWENTY ONE. THREE SAN AND FORCE
THAT RIPPLE I'M THIS USUALLY
FROM ON THIS WEBSITE BY. A
GOOGLE SEARCH- YOU CAN FIND
LINKS TO DOWNLOAD IT AT THE
TOP- YOU'VE GOT LINKS TO ALL OF
THE COMPANY'S POLICIES-
THEREFORE SPENT WITH
EXPLANATIONS ARE APPROACH ON
HOW THEY'RE DOING THIS. DATA AS
WELL TO- SHOW- STE SURE THE
WORK THERE- YOU CAN ALSO BREAK
OUT- THE AMOUNT OF MODERATION
BY- POLICY AEA. AND WITHIN
EACH THERE ARE DEFINITIONS. OF
HOW THEY'RE CATEGORIZING
CONTENT AS WELL AS THE DAY OF
THE FALL LINE UP- HERE'S JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF HONEST WHEN YOU
CLICK CONTINUE- ADULT NUDITY
AND SEXUAL ACTIVITY. I'M
SHOWING THE PREVALENCE AND ON
FACEBOOK- AND SO- HERE'S A
QUICK EXAMPLE OF TWITTER'S-
TRANSPARENCY REPORT. SURE AND-
YOU KNOW THE FAR GROUSED AND
HOW MANY- CANCER ACTION. AND AS
YOU GO INTO IT THERE'S
NARRATIVE EXPLANATION- OF THEIR
EFFORTS- AND THEY ALSO BREAK IT
OUT BY BY EACH AREA. AND SO-
THERE IS. YOU KNOW NATURALLY
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
VARIATION. AMONG SOME BUT
REALLY OUR COMPANIES ARE TRYING
TO. INVEST VERY HEAVILY AND-
THESE REPORTS ARE AIMED AT
INFORMING OUR USERS- WE HAVE NO
INTEREST IN AND- I'M NOT
INFORMING OUR USERS WE WANT
PEOPLE TO KNOW AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS. ALLOWED AND ACCEPTABLE
ON OUR OUR PLATFORMS. AND SO
WE'VE BROKEN UP INTO HEADERS
THEY'RE SEARCHABLE- YOU CAN
DOWNLOAD THE DATA FOR YOURSELF-
A LOT OF THEM INCORPORATE CRAFT
SOME OF THEM ARE ARE MORE
INTERACTIVE THAN OTHERS BUT- WE
ARE WORKING TO IMPROVE. THE
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION THAT WITH
EVERY REPORT- AND SO WE'VE
ENGAGED WITH THIS COMMITTEE TO
DEVELOP A WORKABLE TRANSPARENCY
BILL. WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING NOT OUT FOR- I WILL
DISCUSSION THAT YOU KNOW
OFTENTIMES ONE SIZE FITS ALL
BROUGH- LEAD TO SOME. ISSUES AS
FAR. AS THE INFORMATION THAT'S
THAT'S PRESENTED- COME HAVE
VERY DIFFERENT CAPABILITIES AS
FAR AS- THE RESOURCE THAT THEY
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THESE F.
AND ALSO TRYING TO COME. ACROSS
PLATFORM CAN ALSO BE TRICK AND
MAY LEAD TO- SOME FIRST. AS FAR
AS WHAT. IMPLICATIONS YOU CAN
GLEAN- SETS OF- I WILL SAY
THOUGH THAT WE'VE BEEN WARY OF-
PREVIOUS REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
COULD FORCE US TO DISCLOSE TOO
MUCH. INFORMATION ABOUT OUR
PROCESSES LIKE I MENTIONED
WE'RE COMBATING- A LOT OF VERY
SOPHISTICATED ONLINE ACTORS ON
PEOPLE TRYING TO TRAFFIC DRUGS
OR RECRUITS FOR TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION ORGANIZATIONS- AND
IT DOESN'T SERVE ANYBODY TO
PROVIDE ROAD MAPS TO THESE
KINDS OF PEOPLE- I'D ALSO
CAUTION AGAINST. A SPECIALIZED
RULES FOR SPECIFIC CONTENT
CONTENT OR I KIND OF FIND
PERFORMANCE TARGETS. ON THINGS
LIKE TIME LIMITS OR SPECIAL
HANDLING RULES AND ACTUALLY
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES-
IN TERMS OF- ALLOCATING
RESOURCES BUT ALSO- AS IT AS I
MENTIONED THIS IS A BALANCING
INTERESTING WHEN YOUR-
INCENTIVIZE TO TAKE DOWN MORE
CONTENT YOU'RE GOING TO- AND-
RETHINK IT RESULT. IN A DRASTIC
OVER REMOVAL- AND THE COURTS
AND OTHER JURISDICTIONS AND
FOUND THAT AS WELL- SO. I'LL
CLOSE BY REITERATING THAT THAT
CONTENT MODERATION AT SCALE IS
AN IMMENSE CHALLENGE BUT ONE
ARE COMPANIES ARE TACKLING HEAD
ON- AND- SERIOUS ABOUT
CONTINUING TO IMPROVE. UPON BUT
POLICY PROPOSAL SHOULD BE
NARROWLY TAILORED WITH AN
EXISTING LEGAL. FRAMEWORKS OVER
ABILITY TO ADAPT. TO EVER
CHANGE- THREATS AT AN ADDRESS
NEWS ON IN. AND THANK YOU- FOR
ALLOWING ME PARTICIPATE TODAY
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER. ANY THANK
MISTER HOFFMAN ON NEXT JEFF
ALEX. OF INTO IN. A FORMER
SENIOR LEVEL DATA SCIENTIST IT
AT FACEBOOK. BOB DR ALAN. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR LETTING
ME PARTICIPATE- AND SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE INTEGRITY
INSTITUTE- I'M GOING TO SHARE A
FEW QUICK SLIDES A HOPELESS
WANTED TO ALL. I'M SO. YOU SEE
BACKGROUND ON THE INTEGRITY
INSTITUTE IN WHO WE REPRESENTS-
WE ARE A GROWING COMMUNITY OF
INTEGRITY PROFESSIONALS- WHICH
MEANS PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY HAVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING ON THE
PLATFORMS FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES TRYING TO MITIGATE
THE HARMS THAT CAN OCCUR ON THE
PLATFORMS OR BECAUSE BY THE
PLATFORMS- WE ARE OPTIMISTIC WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A SOCIAL
INTERNET THAT CAN HELP
SOCIETIES DEMOCRACIES AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHTS- CAN WE ARE
TRYING TO USE OUR COMMUNITY WE
ARE POWERED BY OUR COMMUNITY-
HAS WE TRY TO HELP ALL
STAKEHOLDERS- IN IN SOCIAL
MEDIA. I'M TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS- SO I WOULD LIKE TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT- ARE WHAT
REPRESENTS THE CONSENSUS VIEW
OF OUR COMMUNITY- OF INTEGRITY
PROFESSIONALS. MEANING THESE
ARE ALL POINTS THAT WE HAVE MET
AND DSCUSSED IN DETAIL- AND
THERE'S BROAD CONSENSUS AMONG
OUR MEMBERS WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY HAVE AGAIN PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY TRIED TACKLING THESE
PROBLEMS FROM WITHIN THE
PLATFORMS THEMSELVES- WE
BELIEVE THAT INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY. IS THE EXTREMELY
VALUABLE TOOL AND WHEN
EMPLOYMENT IT COMPREHENSIVELY
AND WELL. THE SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES AND ALSO TO VALIDATE
THAT AND ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
USING BEST PRACTICES ARE
RESPONSIBLY BUILDING OUR
PLATFORMS. AND WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT THE RIGHT TRANSPARENCY CAN
HELP ELEVATE THE INFLUENCE OF
THE INTERNAL TEAMS THAT ARE
TRYING TO MINIMIZE THE HARMS
THAT OCCUR ON THE PLATFORMS-
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WE
THINK THAT TRANSPARENCY IS A
VERY IMPORTANT STEP BUT IT'S
ALSO NOT THE- ONLY STOP- AND
THEN YOU KNOW OUR ORGANIZATIONS
DURING NEW AND THIS IS SORT OF
LIKE THE FIRST CONCEPT THAT WE
HAVE TACKLED. FOR PUBLIC. I'M
TRANSPARENCY CAN TAKE MANY
DIFFERENT FORMS I'M AND ONE
THING TO STRESS IS THAT WE NEED
AT MANY DIFFERENT FORMS.
IMPORTANT FOR TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS TO BE VERY
COMPREHENSIVE TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S NO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FROM FROM VARIOUS-
IN CENTER UNINTENDED INCENTIVES
CREATED WITHIN THE COMPANY- WE
WANT TO CREATE AN ACTUAL
INCENTIVE STRUCTURE THAT YOU
KNOW LEADS TO BETTER BUSINESS
DECISIONS- AT LEAST CELESTE
FARMS ON THE PLATFORMS AND SO
WE REALLY NEED TO BE
COMPREHENSIVE AND WIDE RANGING
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
TRANSPARENCY NEED. TO DO THAT-
SO ON THAT FRONT THERE ARE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT FORMS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE PLATFORMS-
UTILIZE WHEN THEY'RE WHEN
THEY'RE MAKING THEMSELVES MORE
TRANSPARENT. THE FIRST IS
AGGREGATED AND SUMMARY DATA.
AND SO ON THIS IS SIMILAR TO
THE TRANSPARENCY REPORTS- THAT
WERE JUST SHOWN BY THE- THE
PROCEEDING- SPEAKER HI AND CAN
INCLUDE DATA SUCH AS- THE
NUMBER OF USERS WHO WERE
EXPOSED TO HARMFUL CONTENT- AND
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE THE
FREQUENCY OF EXPOSURE SO HOW
OFTEN ORDER USERS REPEATEDLY
EXPOSED TO HARMFUL CONTENT. OR
OUR COMMUNITY STANDARDS
VIOLATING CONTENT. I'M
TRANSPARENCY CAN ALSO NEEDS TO
COME IN THE FORM OF CONTENT
BASED DATASETS- AND SO THESE
WOULD BE PUBLIC RELEASES OF
CONTENT ON THE PLATFORM. AN
EXAMPLE THAT WE WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO SEE AND WE THINK WOULD
UNLOCK A LOT OF VALUABLE
RESEARCH- IS A RANDOM SAMPLE OF
YOU KNOW THOUSANDS OF
IMPRESSIONS ON PUBLIC CONTACT-
THIS WOULD CREATE A-
STANDARDIZED DATASET- THAT
EVERYONE COULD AGREE- AGREE
UPON AND AS REPRESENTATIVE OF
WHAT USERS ARE SEEN ON THE
PLATFORM AT LEAST IN THE PUBLIC
CONTENT SPACE- AND INTEGRATE
MORE. MORE STRUCTURED
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN BUT THE
PLATFORMS- AND EXTERNAL BECAUSE
HE WORKS- WE'D ALSO LIKE TO SEE
DETAILS AND DESCRIPTIONS OF
ALGORITHMS THAT ARE USED ON THE
PLATFORMS AS WELL AS THE
OVERALL PLATFORM DESIGN. AND AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS COULD BE YOU
KNOW WHAT CLASSIFIERS WHAT
MACHINE LEARNING MODELS ARE
BEING USED IN THE RANKING OF
CONTENT IN FEEDS- YOU KNOW AND
IS PARTICULARLY INTERESTING
EXAMPLE WOULD BE YOU KNOW WHAT
USER ENGAGEMENT ACTIONS ARE THE
PLATFORMS TRYING TO PREDICT.
AND HOW DO THOSE PREDICTIONS-
CHANGE THAT THE ORDERING OF
CONTENT IN THEIR FEEDS. AND
FINALLY AND VERY IMPORTANTLY
WE'D LIKE TO SEE DETAILS AND
DESCRIPTIONS OF INTERNAL
COMPANY PROCESS SEATS AROUND%
DECISION MAKING- AN EXAMPLE
HERE COULD BE A DISCLOSURE OF
THE METRICS THAT COMPANIES USE
IN THEIR EXPERIMENTATION
PROCESS AND FOR GOALS. SO WHAT
ARE THE METRICS THAT INTERNAL
TEAMS ARE USING WHEN THEY MAKE
DECISIONS YOU KNOW IN AB TEST
WHETHER OR NOT TO SHIP A NEW
FEATURE OR NOT- COMPANIES VERY
REGULARLY USE METRICS- IN KEY
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS- TO TELL
IF IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO SHIPPING
TO FEATURE- AND WE'D LIKE TO
SEE TRANSPARENCY FROM COMPANIES
ON WHAT ARE THE METRICS THAT
THEY USED TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS. AND WHAT ARE THE
METRICS THAT THEY USED TO SET
GOALS FOR TEAMS LIKE WHAT IS
THE COMPANY ACTUALLY TRYING TO
DRIVE- THIS WAS JUST A BRIEF
TASTE LIKE. TRANSPARENCY REALLY
NEEDS TO BE CAUGHT-
COMPREHENSIVE THERE'S A LOT OF
TECHNICAL DETAILS- AND AT THE
INTEGRITY INSTITUTE WE ARE A
COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING ON. WORKING
ON THE PLATFORMS ON THESE
PROBLEMS. AND WE WOULD VERY
MUCH LIKE TO HELP ALL
STAKEHOLDERS WHICH INCLUDES THE
COMPANIES THEMSELVES AS WELL AS
POLICYMAKERS. UNDERSTAND ALL
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A DOCTOR ALLEN. A NEXT-
PROFESSOR KATE. KLONDIKE ST
JOHN'S FROM SAINT JOHN'S
UNIVERSITY LAW SCHOOL AFFILIATE
FELLOW AT THE INFORMATION
SOCIETY PROJECT AT YALE LAW
SCHOOL. PROFESSOR CLONIC. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME- I'M
GOING TO KEEP HIS PRETTY SHORT
BECAUSE THINGS HAVE KIND OF
BEEN A LITTLE BIT LONG AND I AM
EAGER TO TRY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF I CAN BE HELPFUL
AND ALSO I WAS DEFINITELY NOT
INVITED TO THIS- PICKED TO BE
PART OF THIS PANEL BECAUSE I AM
A BARD CALIFORNIA LAWYER WHICH
I AM NOT A PRACTICE IN NEW YORK
AB AND I'VE NEVER DONE SO I
JUST TAUGHT AND- AND NOT
BECAUSE I'M A CITIZEN OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I'M ALSO NOT
THAT SO I JUST WANT TO STATE
THAT- MY ADVICE HERE IS GOING
TO COME FROM BASICALLY MY
EXPERIENCE AND IT WHICH IS WHY
I THINK I WAS INVITED HERE
TODAY. WHICH IS AS A RESEARCHER
AND A SCHOLAR AND ACADEMIC AND
I THINK WHAT I REALLY KIND OF
WANNA BE THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO TAKE AWAY AS A
SCHOOL AS A AS A SCHOLAR OF
TRANSLATING BETWEEN TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS AND TECHNOLOGISTS
AND- LAWMAKERS IN A REALLY
UNIQUE TIME IN HISTORY WHERE
THERE NEEDS TO BE A LOT OF HARD
TRANSLATED TRANSLATED WORK- TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THESE COMPANIES
WHICH ARE VERY COMPLEX AND
LEARNING IN MUCH DIFFERENT WAYS
THAN OIL COMPANY IS OR EVEN
AUTO MANUFACTURERS- TO IMPACT
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND TO IMPACT
THEIR RIGHTS- IN CRITICAL WAYS.
AND I THINK THOSE TYPES OF
UNDERSTANDINGS ARE ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY TO CRAFTING GOOD
LEGISLATION- IN THE LONG TERM
AND INTERVENTIONS. SO I WOULD
SAID I SPENT A LOT OF TIME BOTH
INSIDE. TALKING TO FORMER
MEMBER FORMER EMPLOYEES AT
TWITTER FACEBOOK GOOGLE YOUTUBE
PINTEREST AIRBNB A LOT OF. THE
MAJOR AND MINOR- FIRMS THAT
TRAFFIC AND KIND OF MAKING-
SPEECH AVAILABLE TO. THEM AS
MOST AS MANY USERS AS POSSIBLE
AND I WOULD ALSO ENDEAVOR TO
FIND OUT. HOW MANY OF THOSE
USERS FALL OUTSIDE THE U. S.
NEVER MIND CALIFORNIA- AND SO
ACTUALLY ONLY ONLY 79% OF USERS
ARE BASED IN THE US. MOST OF
THEM ARE IN FACT BASED. OUTSIDE
OUR BORDERS AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT'S JUST THE IMPORTANT THING
TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT AS
WORK. I'M SITTING HERE TODAY
DISCUSSING KIND OF HOW. TO
POTENTIALLY HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THESE PLATFORMS AND CHANGE HOW.
THEY THEY RUN THEIR COMPANY IS.
THAT THE IMPACT THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE IS NOT GOING TO
JUST BE I'M ON U. S. CITIZENS
JUST AS THE GDPR WAS NOT JUST
ON YOU SAID A SENSE- AND THAT
THERE ARE FACTS THAT. THAT IN
CALIFORNIA HAS THAT CARRY FAR
OUTSIDE. ITS BOUNDARIES I'M
STILL REALLY QUICKLY I'VE SPENT
TIME INSIDE FACEBOOK AND MOST
RECENTLY- I WAS EMBEDDED AS
BOTH THE JOURNALISTS AND
ACADEMICS COVERING ITS-
DEVELOPMENT- THE FACEBOOK
OVERSIGHT BOARD AND I BRING
THIS UP BECAUSE- THAT THE
PATENT THE PANEL. THAT I'M
SPEAKING ON. IS ASKING THE
QUESTION WHAT IS BEING DONE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND I THINK THAT- I COULDN'T.
TESTIFIED TO THIS TWO YEARS AGO
I COULD HAVE SAID THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING BUT I COULDN'T SAID
WERE MEDICALLY WHETHER HOW IT
WAS GOING BECAUSE THAT DIDN'T
EXIST YET. AND HADN'T BEEN SET
UP- AND HADN'T BEEN TESTED BUT
I CAN THINK I CAN SAY NOW THAT
THE FACEBOOK OVERSIGHT BOARD SO
FAR HAS BEEN I'M A PRETTY I'M-
INCREDIBLE SUCCESS. IN TERMS OF
STARTING TO CREATE A CULTURE OF
TRANSPARENCY- CONSOLIDATED
SIGNALS BACK TO FACEBOOK. ON
WHAT USERS WANT TO HEAR AND
HOLDING IT HUMAN RIGHTS
PRINCIPLES WHICH IS WHAT USERS
ALL BASED AND A- COMMITTEE IT
CAME UP. WHEN THE OVERSIGHT
BOARD AND PLACE- THAT IT WANTED
AND SO JUST. IF YOU'RE NOT
FAMILIAR THE FACEBOOK FOR IT'S
KIND OF BEEN CO. REFER TO AS-
FACEBOOK'S A CREAM COURT SHOULD
HEAL OR HERE'S APPEALS- BOTH
DIRECTLY FROM FACEBOOK FACEBOOK
REQUESTS THAT IT HERE BUT ALSO
FROM USERS AND ALLOWS THEM TO
APPEAL TAKEDOWNS AND- A K. NOW-
KEEP OPS. OF MATERIAL THEY
THINK SHOULD COME DOWN- TO A
HIGHER BODY OF TWENTY GLOBAL-
ACADEMICS LAWYERS JOURNALISTS
SCHOLARS- TECHNOLOGISTS. THAT
ALL KIND OF LOOK TO- IT TO
PRINCIPLES OF HUMAN RIGHTS THE
FOCUS BOOKS OWN COMMUNITY
STANDARDS AND VALUES. AND TRY
TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT-
CERTAIN KIND OF OBJECTIVE
MEASURES OF THREE CONVICTS
RUSSIAN AND OTHER HUMAN RIGHTS
ARE BEING. TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION WITH SOME OF
THESE DECISIONS AND THE
POLICIES OF FACEBOOK I'M MOST
RECENTLY HE PROBABLY BECAME
AWARE OF THEM BECAUSE- THEY
WERE. THEY WERE GIVEN THE
DECISION ON WHETHER DONALD
TRUMP'S PLATFORM SHOULD NOT
REMAIN DOWN. AND THEY WROTE. I
THINK A VERY INCREDIBLY ELEGANT
AND- THOUGHTFUL AND LEGALLY
BASED- OPINION. THAT BASICALLY
KICKED THE QUESTION BACK TO
FACEBOOK SAYING THAT THEY WERE
NOT GOING TO CREATE CONTENT
BASED SUBSTANTIVE TYPES OF
ROLES FOR FACEBOOK ON HOW TO
POLICE PUBLIC FIGURES OR TRY TO
DEFINE PUBLIC FIGURES OR TRY TO
DEFINE EACH THESE COMPLETELY
NEBULOUS IDEAS OF
NEWSWORTHINESS- A FOR FACEBOOK
AND- TO DO THAT HARD JOB FOR
IT- THEY WERE JUST GOING TO
DEMAND. THAT FACEBOOK HAVE
TRANSPARENT POLICIES MAKE
CLEAR- CONCENTRATED DECISIONS
AND THOSE DECISIONS BE
PROPORTIONAL I'M FROM A HUMAN
RIGHTS PERSPECTIVE- IN TERMS OF
THE PUNISHMENT. METED OUT TO
THE ADDED TO THE CRIME. AND SO
I THINK THAT- I THINK THIS IS A
ROOM. KIND OF NEW YORK. IT IS
IN FUNDED THROUGH A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT HI EXCUSE
ME A HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT THE FACEBOOK MADE.
YOUR AVAILABLE TO YOU- I TRUST
THAT IT SET UP THAT IS MANAGED
BY INDEPENDENT TRUSTEES- AND
THAT GOVERNS THE OVERSIGHT
BOARD WHICH IS MANAGED ITSELF
THE BOARD OF. THE TWENTY PERSON
BOARD THAT I MENTIONED IS
MANAGED BY A AND AN LLC IS
BASED IN DELAWARE. AND ACTIVELY
IT SET UP TO RUN RIGHT NOW FOR
SIX YEARS- SO FAR BY PLACING
KIND OF THE REPUTATIONS OF ALL
OF THE BOARD MEMBERS- MOST.
WHICH RANGE FROM NOBEL PRIZE
WINNERS TO THAT FORMER PRIME
MINISTER OF DENMARK YOU ARE YOU
AND YOU DROP IT TOWARDS YOU-
THE FORMER EDITOR IN CHIEF OF
THE GUARDIAN AND ATTEND CIRCUIT
JUDGES. THERE IS. A JUST A WIDE
RANGE OF EXPERTISE AND
REPUTATION AND WHAT YOU'VE SEEN
AS BUT WHEN MANY PEOPLE THOUGHT
THAT THIS WAS GOING TO PROVIDE.
A SCAPEGOAT FOR FACEBOOK. BUT
INSTEAD WERE YOU SEEN AS ALL OF
THE IN THE- ARE VERY MUCH STEP
UP AND SAID WE ARE NOT WILLING
TO PLACE OUR REPUTATION LIES IN
FOR THIS KIND OF GOAL. AND
INSTEAD WE'RE GOING TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT WE WERE MANDATED
TO DO BY- HE'S FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS. I'M WE ARE GOING TO
HOLD FACEBOOK ACCOUNTABLE IN A
SMALL WAY- TO TRY TO MAKE THIS
SPACE BETTER AND TO TRY TO GET
YOU BACK SIGNALED THE HOW TO
MAKE YOUR PLATFORM BETTER FOR
YOUR USERS. AND THAT AND WHILE
HOLDING KIND OF INTERNATIONAL
HUMAN RIGHTS AND- THE STANDARD
FACEBOOK'S AS FAR. SO THAT
BEING SAID- THERE HAS BANNED I
THINK JUST GENERALLY MUCH MORE
INDEPENDENT AND MUCH MORE
ROBUST THAN MANY OF US IMAGINE
INCLUDING ME I WAS CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC- BUT I DON'T THINK I
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT IT'S
GOTTEN TO THIS POINT THERE'S A
LOT OF INSTITUTION BUILDING
THAT JUST NEEDED TO GET DONE AT
LIKE A VERY FOUNDATIONAL LEVEL.
OR SOMETHING OF THAT SCALE TO.
PLAY EVEN HEAR APPEALS FROM A
GLOBAL AUDIENCE THEY KIND OF
THEY HAVE TO SELECT- CASES THAT
ARE. I LIKE IT ASTRONOMICALLY
LIKE AT AN ASTRONOMICAL LEAVES
SMALL AMOUNTS ARE GIVEN THE
AMOUNT THAT APPEALED THROUGH
THEM AND THAT'S INCREDIBLY HARD
WORK AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THAT AND EVERYTHING ELSE. SO I
JUST I THINK IT'S ONE EXAMPLE
OF THE KIND OF EIGHT EIGHT
YOURSELF REGULATORY MECHANISM
BUT IT DOESN'T NEED TO BE SELF
REGULATORY. FACEBOOK DID THIS
ON ITS OWN. BUT THERE IS NO
REASON THAT THIS COULD NOT BE
MANDATED. BY BY GOVERNMENT IN
FACT CANADA IS IN THE PROCESS
OF BASICALLY WRITING A MANDATE
INTO- INTO A BOX THAT WOULD
REQUIRE- SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
A CERTAIN SIZE TO HAVE THIS
TYPE. OF A BOARD- AND SO IT IS
ONE MECHANISM OF GOVERNANCE
THAT KIND OF GIVES POWER BACK
TO USERS WHICH I THINK IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING- A FOR ANY
TYPE OF GOVERNMENT INTERVENTION
TO DO. IS TO NOT NECESSARILY
SPEECH THE CONTENT ITSELF BUT
THE ABILITY OF THE USER
CONTENT TO THAT. I WILL JUST
SAY THAT I OUT ON. EVERYONE'S
PLATE- DESIRE FROM-
TRANSPARENCY COME. ARE ALREADY.
THAT THEY COULD DO MORE OF IT
AND THEY GIVE MORE OF A
DISCUSSION SCIENCES. THANK ME
AND A LOT OF. AND THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE KIND OF MORE PEOPLE
THAT ARE WORKING IT YOU'VE SEEN
A LOT OF THEM TODAY THAT ARE
DOING THE VERY HARD WORK OF
TRANSLATING BETWEEN. THE
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES UNDER
SPEAK THE LANGUAGE OF SILICON
VALLEY. AND YOU KNOW AND THE
AND- A VERY DIFFERENT TYPE OF
LANGUAGE THAT. WERE YEARS
TWENTY C. OR NEW YORK OR
ANYWHERE ELSE. AND TRANSLATING
IT BACK LAWMAKERS AROUND THE
WORLD AND THAT IS- THE MORE OF
THAT WE CAN HAVE THE BETTER AND
I'M REALLY APPRECIATIVE THAT I
GET SAYS COME HERE TODAY. AND
KIND OF SHARE SOME OF THAT
KNOWLEDGE AND PROVIDE THAT
ROLLED. TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
THANK YOU PROFESSOR IN AND JUST
A HEADS UP TO YOU AND THE OTHER
PANELISTS I'M GONNA COME BACK
AT THE END. AND ASK IN LIGHT OF
THE TESTIMONY OF. OF MISS
KELLER IN PROFESSOR GOLDMAN
WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO IN TERMS OF
TRANSPARENCY WHAT CAN WE DO IN
TERMS OF MODERATION. WHAT CAN
WE DO- IN TERMS OF.
TRANSPARENCY REGARDING THE
AMPLIFICATION OF CERTAIN
MESSAGES SO WHAT WILL COME BACK
TO THAT BUT JUST GIVING YOU ALL
A HEADS UP. NEXT IMRAN AHMED
THE CEO OF THE CENTER FOR
COUNTERING DIGITAL HATE. THANK
YOU MR AHMED FOR JOINING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS IMRAN
AHMED I'M CHIEF EXECUTIVE THE
SCENT OF THE COUNTRY AND
DIGITAL LIGHT BASED IN
WASHINGTON DC- ALL OF THE
EVIDENCE OF THE GENTLEMAN FROM
SILICON VALLEY I DON'T KNO
ABOUT YOU BUT- I'M STILL NOT
PERSUADED. I MEAN YOU GOT
GENOCIDE IN MYANMAR ALL. AN ACT
OF DOMESTIC TERRORISM WHICH
ENDED WITH THE CAPSULE BEING
STORMED. AND YET APPARENTLY
DROPPED ON HIS ALL ABOUT.
NOTHING TO SEE HERE YEAH. MY
ORGANIZATION THE CENTER FOR
COUNTERING DIGITAL HEIGHT WAS
SET UP TO DISRUPT THE WORK OF
MALIGNANT ACTORS NLINE. BUT
ALSO TO ACCELERATE THE MOMENT
WHEN BIG TECH HAS TO FINALLY
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY. FOR THE
FACT THAT AT THE SAME TIME IT
CONNECTS FAMILIES LOVED ONES
FRIENDS AND YOU COMMUNITIES OF
INTEREST. IT ALSO HAS POWERED
MODERN EXTREMISM. SCIENCE
DENIAL HATRED. BULLYING
TERRORISM A HOST OF REAL WORLD
HARMS. LOOK IN THE PAST YEAR
THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES HAVE
FACED THREE TESTS. ONE WAS THE
ELECTION MISINFORMATION THAT
MOB THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION I
LEAD TO THE STORMING OF THE
CAPSULE. FAILED ANOTHER WAS TO
DO SOMETHING TO STOP THE CRISIS
MENTAL HEALTH PARTICULARLY
AFFECTING OUR YOUNG WOMEN.
FAILED I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU
BUT I'D RATHER TRUST MY KIDS
WITH PRINCE ANDREW BUT
INSTAGRAM'S ALGORITHMS FRANKLY.
BUT THE CALVET CONDEMNING IN
PARTICULAR HAS LAID BAD THE
EXISTING REAL WORLD HARMS
CAUSED BY ONLINE MISINFORMATION
ON THE SYSTEMATIC FAILURE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS TO
PROTECT THAT USES FROM THOSE
HARMS. AND THERE HAS BEEN A
QUANTIFIABLE DEATH TOLL.
MULTIPLE STUDIES INCLUDING OUR
OWN HAVE SHOWN THAT THOSE WHO
ARE MOST RELIANT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA FOR INFORMATION ALL MORE
VACCINE HESITANT. BIG TECH IS
PROVEN ITS POTENTIAL
DETRIMENTAL TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND IT REQUIRES SCRUTINY. IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY I PIVOTED
THE SENSES RESEARCH IS AN
IMPACT STUFF TO FOCUS
EXCLUSIVELY ON CORONAVIRUS AND
PRESCIENTLY. ANTI VACCINE
MISINFORMATION ACTIVES IN THAT
TIME CCH HAS REPEATEDLY
DEMONSTRATED BUT THE PLATFORM
SYSTEMS FOR PREVENTING THE
SPREAD OF HARMFUL
MISINFORMATION I'M NOT WORKING.
THE SAME IS TRUE OF THE SYSTEMS
THEY HAVE DESIGNED TO PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF HATRED SUCH AS
THE ANTI BLACK RACISM. ANTI
SEMITISM MISOGYNY. IN SHORT
WHAT CCH IS FOUND IS THAT
PLATFORMS WHEN GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN MY
FAILURES OR EVEN CORRECT THE
HOMES THEY SAID- COMPANIES
CHOOSE TO EMPLOY A PLAYBOOK OF
DENY CULPABILITY DEFLECTS
CRITICISM AND DELAY ANY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE. WE SEE HOW
MUCH THE CLASS OF THAT IN THE
PAST FEW MONTHS BOTH IN THE U.
K. E. I'M IN THE US WITH THE
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY SPENT
ON LOBBYING TO STOP REGULATION
FROM HAPPENING OR AT LEAST BEND
IT TO THEIR INTERESTS. IT FOR
EXAMPLE PLATFORMS OFTEN CLAIM
THAT THEY REMOVE HARMFUL
CONTENT WHAT IS REPORTED TO
THEM BUT THIS IS SIMPLY UNTRUE.
ALL REGULAR ORDER IS A PLATFORM
ACTION ON REPORTS OF HARMFUL
HATE MISINFORMATION SHOW THAT
THEY FAILED TO ACT ON AROUND
EIGHTEEN TEN POSTS THAT ARE
REPORTED TO THEM USING THEIR
OWN TOOLS THAT BOUGHT IT LAST
ON. IT'S NOT JUST VACCINE OKAY
MISINFORMATION OR EVEN HATE
THAT'S THE PROBLEM. ALL RECENT
FAILURE TO PROTECT REPORT
SHOWED THAT FACEBOOK INSTAGRAM
TICTOC TWITTER AND YOUTUBE
FAILED TO ACT ON IT 84% OF USER
REPORTS OF **** LEVEL ANTI
SEMITIC CONTENT. SO YOU
REPORTED TO THEM ON. THE
EIGHTEEN TEN TIMES THEY FAILED
TO DO ANYTHING. FACEBOOK WAS
THE WORST OF ALL FAILING TO
ACTUAL NINE IN TEN REPORTS
DESPITE CLAIMING TO ADOPT
STRONGER POLICIES ON THE ANTI
SEMITIC CONSPIRACIES. IN
HOLOCAUST DENIAL IN THE LAST
YEAR. BUT LOST. AS COUNTRIES
THE WORLD AND IN THE SECOND
WAVE INDICATED PANDEMIC
INSTAGRAM SIGNED IT TO START
PLACING OUT WITH ME RECOMMENDED
POSTS. AT THE BOSTON OF USERS
FEEDS. THEY HAVEN'T TAKEN EVEN
THE MOST BASIC STEPS TO PREVENT
THIS FEATURE HOWEVER FROM
PROMOTING HARMFUL HATE
MISINFORMATION. ALL REPORT
MELDRICK THEN ESTABLISHED A
SERIES OF INSTAGRAM PROFILES
FOLLOWING THE ACCOUNTS OF
WELLNESS INFLUENCES WHICH
RECEIVED RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
DISINFORMATION FROM LEADING
ONLINE ON TWO TRACKS IT'S-
ALREADY BEEN REPEATEDLY FLAG TO
INSTAGRAM ADVANCE OF ITS
ROLLOUT. INSTAGRAM WAS ALSO
SHOWN TO BE DRIVING A DANGEROUS
CONVERGENCE OF DIFFERENT TYPES
OF COMPLICATED MISINFORMATION
SO FOLLOWS ON TO FAX ACCOUNTS
WERE RECOMMENDED ANTI SEMITIC
CONTENT SHE WENT ON
CONSPIRACIES AND ELECTION
MISINFORMATION AND IN RETURN
FOLLOWS A FAR RIGHT ACCOUNTS
RECOMMENDED CONVENE AND MAX
UNCONFIDENT VACCINE
MISINFORMATION. SO THIS PURPOSE
PROBLEM IS NOT UNIQUE TO
INSTAGRAM IT'S TRUE FACEBOOK AS
WELL AND ALL THE OTHER
PLATFORMS. THE FRONT OF THE
PLATFORMS WHAT I'M TRYING I'M
TO TAXES ON THE DISINFORMATION
THEY SPREAD HELPS EXPLAIN RAPID
UNCHECKED GROWTH DURING THE
PANDEMIC. TRACKING A HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN ACCOUNTS FOR WHICH
EASIER IT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN HISTORICAL FIGURES
SHOWING THAT THEY'VE GROWN BY
TEN POINT ONE MILLION FOLLOWERS
SINCE THE END OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. ANTI BREXIT COUNCIL
INSTAGRAM REFRESHED IS ADDING
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
FOLLOWERS. MARIMBA DESPITE
HAVING DENIED IT WILL REVEAL AS
THIS WAS ALL CONFIRMED BY THE
FACEBOOK WHISTLEBLOWER FRANCIS
WHO. LEAKED DOCUMENTS PROVED
FACEBOOK STUFF NEW THEIR
ALGORITHMS COULD SEND USERS
DOWN A RABBIT HOLE CONSPIRACIES
IN THIS LIST LIST TWO DATES. TO
BE CLEAR. MAINSTREAM SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS THE ONE WE USE
THE WHAT KIDS USE NAMELY
FACEBOOK INSTAGRAM TICTOC
ETCETERA I'M GONNA FIND THE
PROBLEM OF HAITIAN
MISINFORMATION. AND AIDING AND
ABETTING THOSE WHO BREAK THE
RULES. BIG TECH CONTINUALLY
SHIFT RESPONSIBILITY OF CONTENT
MODERATION TO USES. AN
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH IS NOT THE
CENTER WITH LIMITED ACCESS TO
THE PLATFORM AND THEN
AGGRESSIVELY COUNTERS ANY
CRITIQUES OF FINDINGS THAT
RESEARCHERS ON A- CONTENT
CIRCULATING ON THE LARGEST
PLATFORM. PLAYS AN OUTSIZE ROLE
IN SHAPING THE TERMS OF PUBLIC
DISCOURSE IN SOME OF THESE
PLATFORMS HAVE A SPECIAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT THE CONTENT
THAT IS MOST VIEWED AND MOST
ENGAGED WITH. ESPECIALLY IF
IT'S HARMFUL CONTENT SUCH AS
MEDICAL MISINFORMATION
MISOGYNIST ABUSE OR RACIAL
HATRED. BUT IN REALITY
PLATFORMS IT DENIED IN SOME
CASES DIRECTLY CHALLENGE SEASON
YET FOR OUR FINDINGS NOT WITH
THE COMPLICATION OF HUMBLE
CONTENT ON THE PROLIFERATION OF
COVERED IMPACTS THE
MISINFORMATION ON THE SITES.
INTERNAL LEAKS FROM FACEBOOK TO
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL CONFIRM
THAT A SMALL NUMBER OF. WHALES
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE BULK OF
ANTI VACCINE CONTENT ON THE
PLATFORM WHAT. WE FOUND LIKE
MANY PROBLEMS AT FACEBOOK THE
THIS IS A HEAD HEAVY PROBLEM
WITH A RELATIVELY FEW NUMBER OF
FACT IS CREATING A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF THE CONTENT
RIGHT. ANOTHER QUOTE TOP
PRODUCES A MOSTLY USES SERIALLY
POSTING CONTENT TO FEET. AND
QUOTES. A C. C. H. I. TEND TO
FOR THOSE BIG WHALES THE
DISINFORMATION DOESN'T FIRST IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. A
REPORT ON THE DISINFORMATION
DOESN'T WHICH I KNOW I SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND PIECES OF ANTI VACCINE
CONTENT POSTED OR SHARED TO
FACEBOOK. OVER A PERIOD OF TWO
MONTHS FOUND THAT 73% ABOUT
CONTACT ORIGINATED FROM JUST
TWELVE INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS. PRESIDENT
CLINTON WAS REFERENCING OUR
RESEARCH WHERE HE SAID FACEBOOK
CELLISTS. HE SUBSEQUENTLY WAS
PERSUADED TO- COOL HIS JETS BUT
FEELS LIKE SOMETHING YOU WOULD
SAY. ON FACEBOOK AND REINFORCED
THE DOZEN KILLING PEOPLE BUT HE
DID FOLLOW IMMEDIATELY WITH THE
MORAL PEACH PLEA TO THE
PLATFORMS THIS IS WHAT HE SAID
PUT. THESE TWELVE PEOPLE AROUND
THAT GIVING MISINFORMATION.
ANYONE LISTEN TO IT IS GETTING
HURT BY IT IT'S KILLING PEOPLE
I'M TRYING TO MAKE PEOPLE LOOK
AT THEMSELVES LOOK IN THE
MIRROR. THINK ABOUT THAT
MISINFORMATION GOING TO YOUR
SON YOUR DAUGHTER YOUR
RELATIVES. AND QUITE. DID
FACEBOOK ACT. NOTE THEIR TAX
THE- SHE ALSO FACED WITH A FROM
HOGAN AS FORTY REVIEW OVER THE
SEVERAL WEEKS INSULARUM AND OF
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS IS
INEXCUSABLE. IN LIGHT OF
MANEUVERS TO HAMPER IN SOME
CASES COMPLETELY SILENCE
RESEARCH IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST
WE BELIEVE IT IS UNSUSTAINABLE
TO CONTINUE DOWN A PATH OF SELF
REGULATION AND TRANSPARENCY BY
CHOICE. RESEARCHERS NEED
PROTECTIONS FROM COMPANIES THAT
CAN REVOKE ACCESS. AND CAN
CHERRY PICK AVAILABLE DATES AT
WILL. WE S. INDEPENDENT
RESEARCH ISN'T CONCERNED
SEVERAL SOCIETY ORGANIZATIONS
MUST BE ABLE TO SEE THE EXTENT
OF THE PROBLEMWE KNOW WE
CONTRAST THE PLATFORMS WE MUST
BE ABLE TO TRUST OUTSIDE
RESEARCH AND PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF USERS IN THE
PROCESS. WELL IT'S NOT REPORTS
THAT FACEBOOK FANS YOUR MORE
THAN THE UNITED STATES WHEN IT
COMES TO REGULATION I ACTUALLY
HAVE TWO MEMBERS OF STAFF TODAY
GIVING EVIDENCE THE
INTERNATIONAL BROWN COMMITTEE
ON DISINFORMATION IN BRUSSELS.
I GAVE EVIDENCE THIS MORNING TO
A FOREIGN OFFICE EVENT IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM I WAS THE FIRST
WITNESS BEFORE THE ONLINE
SAFETY BILL COMMITTEE.
MENTIONED BY SAFETY SHANGO YET.
YOU IN THE U. K. ALL. AHEAD OF
THE U. S. TO THEIR RESPECTIVE
DIGITAL SERVICES ACT. ON ONLINE
SAFETY BILL INITIATIVES. THE
ONLINE SAFETY BILL HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO HOLD PLATFORMS TO
REDUCE OF CARE. TO PROTECT THAT
USES FROM ILLEGAL AND HARMFUL
CONTENT. BRING REAL PENALTIES
TO PLATFORM TO PROFIT FROM THE
PROLIFERATION OF HARMFUL
CONTENT IMPACTS TO KEEP WHAT
THEY PROFIT THESE OFFICES IS
THESE AREN'T THE PUBLIC SQUARE
AT. THESE ARE BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE MADE UNTOLD AMOUNTS OF
MONEY. BY REORDERING
INFORMATION TO RIDICULOUS I'M
THERE IS A QUANTIFIABLE DEATH
TOLL. MY FRIEND PETER HOTEZ
TALKS ABOUT HOW THE DELTA. IT
TOOK. SUCH A PROFOUNDLY DEADLY
WHITE HUNDRED THOUSAND DEBT
ONLY BECAUSE OF THE
UNCONSCIONABLE DELAYS AND
VACCINATION. GENERALLY THE SIX
HAVE A DEATH TOLL CAPITOL
POLICE OFFICER BRIAN SICKNESS.
BUT ALSO YOU KNOW ACTUALLY
BOBBITT WHOSE MIND WAS POISONED
BY THE LIES FED TO HER
RUTHLESSLY BY SOCIAL MEDIA
ALGORITHMS. SHE WENT FROM BEING
A VETERAN OF THE U. S. MILITARY
TO DOMESTIC. TERRORISTS SHOT TO
DEATH. NO I WAS OUTAGE GOES IS
OF COOL GOES GOES THE- THIS IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO SET THE
STANDARD. TO MAKE THE PLATFORM
ADULTS ARE VERY RICH USE. TO
FINALLY BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK TO A COMMITTEES TODAY I
SINCERELY HOPE THIS WILL SPARK
A REAL CHANGE WAS LEGISLATION
FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK YOU MR
RAHMAN. OUR NEXT LAUREN OF.
ROTH THE TECHNOLOGY POLICY AND
ADVOCACY COUNCIL AT THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE. AFTERNOON
THANK YOU TARANA BURKE VICE
CHAIR GORGEOUS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LORN CROP
AND I SERVICE ADL'S TECHNOLOGY
POLICY ADVOCACY COUNCIL IT IS
MY HONOR TO SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ABOUT HOW
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS CAN TAKE
ACTION AND ADDRESS THE HATE AND
DISINFORMATION RUNNING RAMPANT
ON THEIR PLATFORMS. THE WAY
NEWS AND CURRENT EVENTS
REVERBERATE ONLINE MATTERS WHAT
WAS ONCE ON THE FRINGES OF
SOCIETY IS NOW FRONT AND CENTER
IN OUR PLATFORM NEWSFEEDS FAULT
ALLEGATIONS OF VOTER FRAUD
HOSTED AN AMPLIFIED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA LED TO THE VIOLENT
INSTRUCTION AT OUR NATION'S
CAPITAL. THE MOST PREDICTABLE
TERROR INCIDENT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY WAS LITERALLY PLANNED
AND PROMOTED OUT IN THE OPEN ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. UNTIL NOW. IT'S
NOT JUST CARDS MEMBERS OF
EXTREMIST GROUPS THAT COMMIT
ACTS OF VIOLENCE. ACCORDING TO
ADL RESEARCH OVER 70% OF THE
PEOPLE WO STORMED THE CAPITOL
ON JANUARY SIXTH WE'RE NOT SELF
IDENTIFIED EXTREMISTS. THESE
INDIVIDUALS WERE MOTIVATED FOR
A STEADY DIET OF LIES AND
MISINFORMATION THAT SOCIAL
MEDIA ALGORITHMS PUMPED OUT
BECAUSE THIS CONTENT IS HIGHLY
ENGAGING. ADL'S CENTER FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND SOCIETY HAS ALSO
ENGAGED FROM REPORTING ON
CONTENT MANAGEMENT PLATFORMS
HOLOCAUST DENIAL POLICIES AND
RESPONSE TO ANTI SEMITISM WE
PUT OUT REPORT CARDS. THE HELP
CONSISTENT PLATFORMS ENFORCE
THEIR POLICIES WHEN IT CAME TO
ANTI SEMITISM YOU TOO AND WHAT
ABOUT THE HIGHEST RATES WITH A
B. MINUS. TAKE TALKING FACEBOOK
GOT A C. MINUS WHEN IT CAME TO
HOLOCAUST DENIAL YOU TO TWITTER
AND TAKE TALK ABOUT SEIZE
FACEBOOK GADDI. THIS IS
ALARMING AND DEEPLY TROUBLING
IN ADDITION TO MISINFORMATION
AND EXTREMISM AGL HAS BEEN
TRACKING THE GROWING THREAT OF
ONLINE HARASSMENT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. AS MY COLLEAGUE DAVID
JFFREY DISCUSSED EARLIER
ACCORDING TO ADL'S LATEST DATA
ONE IN THREE AMERICANS WHO ARE
HARASSED ONLINE TRIBUTE AT
LEAST SOME HARASSMENT TO A
PROTECTED CHARACTERISTIC. THIS
IS ONLY TAKING PLACE ON DARK
WEB MESSAGE BOARDS. 75% OF
THOSE HARASSED THAT AT LEAST
SOME HARASSMENT HAPPENED ON
FACEBOOK 24% ON TWITTER 21% ON
YOUTUBE 15% ON SNAPCHAT. WELL
RESOURCE HIGHLY PROFITABLE
PLATFORMS. MAJOR SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES WILL TELL YOU THAT
IT'S TOO HARD TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES THAT THE LEGAL FRAMEWORK
WILL PREVENT US FROM REGULATING
THEIR PLATFORMS IT'S SIMPLY
RIDICULOUS. AUTOMOBILES. FOOD
XIN DRUGS AND SECURE A- HI MY
TIME AGAIN LAMI HAVE CRAFTED
GOOD. TO AND INTO ALIKE THERE'S
A LOT WE CAN AND MUST. TO PUSH
HATE EXTREME. BACK TO THE
FRINGES OF THE DIGITAL WORLD
AND REPAIRING OUR INTERNET
STARTS WITH TRANSPARENCY.
TRANSPARENCY IS ABOUT SHINING
THE LIGHT ON SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES CONTENT MANAGEMENT
POLICIES AND PRACTICES. IT IS
ABOUT GETTING ACCESS TO
CONSISTENT AND REGULAR DATA TO
ENSURE THAT BIG SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS ARE TAKING THE
NECESSARY STEPS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS. MUCH LIKE THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRACKING AND
DOCUMENTING HE CRIMES TRACKING
DISINFORMATION EXTREMISM HATE
HARASSMENT AND FOR INTERFERENCE
ON SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS FOR
TRANSPARENCY REPORTS WILL
PROVIDE CRITICAL DATA THAT CAN
BE USED TO INFORM POLICY. AND
PROTECT TARGETED GROUPS.
PARENTS REFORM MOTOR PLATFORMS
TO BE MORE EXPLICIT ABOUT THEIR
POLICIES ON HATE HARASSMENT AND
MISINFORMATION AND APPLY THE
RULES CONSISTENTLY. IT WOULD
ACT AS A DETERRENT FOR MAKING
CHANGES EXCEPTIONS AND OTHER
DECISIONS THAT END UP
AMPLIFYING HEAT. IT WOULD
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES CAN
COMPETE ON HOW WELL THEY ARE
PROTECTING USERS NOT ON HOW
THEY CAN OPTIMIZE THE MOST
CORROSIVE CONTENT TO KEEP US
ROLLING FOR AS LONG AS POSSIBLE
TO SELL AS MANY EYES AS
POSSIBLE. TODAY MOST MAJOR
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES ONLY
PUBLISH LIMITED INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR CONTENT POLICIES
AND ENFORCEMENT. EFFORTS BY
THESE COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
OPAQUE ARBITRARY BIASED AND
INEQUITABLE WHY IS THIS THE
CASE. CURRENTLY SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES HAVE LITTLE TO NO
LEGAL OR FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
TO GIVE CONSUMERS COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION THEIR REPORTS AND
OF SERVING AS A DEFLECTION AWAY
FROM THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT
CONTENT PROLIFERATES ON
PLATFORMS. RECENT REVELATIONS
FROM LEAKED DOCUMENTS SHOW THAT
THIS ISN'T JUST A THEORY
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE FACEBOOK HAD
AN UNANNOUNCED PROGRAM CALLED
CROSSCHECK THAT ALLOWED OVER
FIVE MILLION CELEBRITIES
POLITICIANS AND INFLUENCERS TO
EFFECTIVELY SCORED ALL OF THE
PUBLISHED RULES AND POLICIES.
THAT MEANT THAT NONE OF THE
POSTS BY MILLIONS OF PUBLIC
FIGURES WONDER AUTOMATED
SYSTEMS NORMALLY FLAG BY
LEADING CONTACT. THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL ACCOUNTS GOT A FREE
PASS FOR POSTING ALMOST
ANYTHING THEY WANTED WHENEVER
THEY WANTED. WE ONLY KNEW ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE OF A WHISTLEBLOWER
NONE OF THIS WAS DISCLOSED IN A
SINGLE PLATFORM REPORT. WHAT
OTHER BAD BEHAVIORS WHAT THEY
THOUGHT IF THEY KNEW THEY HAD
TO REPORT ON THEIR POLICIES AND
ENFORCEMENT CONSISTENTLY. THERE
ARE CLEAR ISSUES WITH THE WAY
PLATFORMS CRRENTLY SHARE THE
LIMITED INFORMATION THEY DO
PUBLISH. FIRST THE INFORMATION
PLATFORMS TO SHARE IS MISSING
CRUCIAL. CONTACTS FOR EXAMPLE
BASICALLY THAT LAW SCORE IT
THIRTY ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
PIECES OF CON. BUT DOT
UNCOVERED BY WAS FOR HOW CAN
SHOW THAT THE COMPANY TO ACTION
ON AS LITTLE AS THREE TO FIVE
PER. OF ALL HE CON ON PLATFORM.
THAT MEANS BASICALLY MISSED
OVER A BILLION PIECES OF HATE
CONTACT. HOW CAN WE RECONCILE
THESE NUMBERS IT'S BASICALLY
INTENTIONALLY DECEPTIVE IN
THEIR REPORTING WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS NUMERATORS WITHOUT
DENOMINATORS. SECOND PLATFORMS
ARE CHERRY PICKING INFORMATION
THEY SHARE RESULTING IN AN
INABILITY TO MEANINGFULLY
COMPARE PLATFORMS AND HOW
THEY'RE RESPONDING TO HATE
EXTREMISM AND MISINFORMATION.
THIRD INFORMATION IS HARD TO
FIND MANY BIG SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS HAVE ESTABLISHED
MICROSITES SOMETIMES KNOWN AS
TRANSPARENCY SANDERS HOWEVER
TRANSPARENCY CENTERS ARE
INACCESSIBLE AND NOT USER
FRIENDLY. A FEW EXAMPLES WELL
MISTER HOFFMAN MAY HAVE SHOWN
THE MOST UP TO DATE BASIC
REPORT IT IS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO FIND AND COMPARE PAST. IF
SOMEONE DOWNLOADS TWITTER'S
REPORT THE EIGHT PAGE PDF ONLY
SHOWS HOW THE TEXT OF THE PAGE
AND HALF. OF THE TAX IS BLANK.
WHERE SHOULD NOT TO SO MUCH
TIME OR AND- SEARCHING FOR A-
THAT SHOULD BE READILY
ACCESSIBLE. TODAY WE ARE IN THE
DARK THESE TRANSPARENT YOUR
SUPPORT REPORTS ARE EXERCISES
IN OBSERVATION. CONSISTENT AND
COMPREHENSIVE TRANSPARENCY WILL
FINALLY CLARIFY PLATFORM
POLICIES AND REPEAL DATA
REGARDING ENFORCEMENT OF THOSE
POLICIES WILL UNDERSTAND RULES
CHANGES TO RULES EXCEPTIONS TO
RULES AND CATEGORIES OF
VIOLATIONS WE WILL ALSO GET
HIGH QUALITY DATA. NOT JUST
PUBLISHING NUMBERS BUT
EXPLAINING THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THOSE NUMBERS. PARENTS HE IS.
SAT TO CREATING A SAFER AND
MORE EQUITABLE INTERNET TO BE
CLEAR TRANSPARENCY IS NOT
FORCING COMPANIES TO REVEAL
TRADE SECRETS IT'S NOT ABOUT
REQUIRING COMPANIES HAVE
SPECIFIC GUIDELINES IT IS NOT
ABOUT RESTRICTING PLATFORMS
EDITORIAL DECISIONS OR
SUPPRESSING FREE SPEECH. IT IS
NOT ABOUT REFORMING SECTION TWO
THIRTY TRANSPARENCY IS ABOUT
COMPANIES BEING HONEST WITH
CONSUMERS ABOUT THE RULES OF
THE ROAD AND HOW THEY ENFORCE
THOSE RULES. ADDITIONALLY
TRANSPARENCY REPORTS ARE NOT
OVERLY BURDENSOME OR EXPENSIVE
ESPECIALLY FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES THAT MAKE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS BILLIONS OR TRILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN GROSS REVENUE.
CURRENTLY MOST SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS ALREADY TRACK MUCH OF
THE INFORMATION YOU'RE SEEKING
REFORM TRANSPARENCY THE
RELATIVELY SMALL QUARTERLY COST
OF COMPLIANCE WOULD BE OFFSET
BY THE ENORMOUS BENEFIT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. FINALLY INFLATED
CLAIMS THAT BAD ACTORS AND
EXTREMISTS WOULD SOMEHOW TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS IF THEY WERE MORE
TRANSPARENT IS A STRONG
ARGUMENT. BAD ACTORS AND
EXTREMISTS ARE ALREADY
EXPLOITING SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM CAPABILITIES
ANONYMIZED AGGREGATED DATA
ABOUT CONTENT MODERATION WOULD
MAKE THIS WORSE RATHER IT WOULD
GIVE US TOOLS AND TOOLS TO
RESEARCHERS CIVIL SOCIETY AND
POLICY. MAKERS TO COUNTER THE
THREAT. TRANSPARENCY IS NOT NEW
WE WERE FOR THAT TO THEIR SHARE
IN THE MARKET. WE REQUIRE FOR
COMPANIES THAT SELL FOOD AND
COSMETICS WE SHOULD DEMAND THE
SAME FOR SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
THAT HAVE THE POWER TO SHAPE
THE WAY WE DIGEST INFORMATION.
UNTRACKED HE FULL AN EXTREMIST
CONTENT PUSHES WOMEN PEOPLE OF
COLOR LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE AND
OTHER MARGINALIZED GROUPS OUT
OF ONLINE SPACES IT HAS
FRACTURED OUR DEMOCRACY AND
SPREAD HEALTH MISINFORMATION.
WE KNOW THESE HARMS EXIST BUT
WE DON'T KNOW THE EXTENT OF
THEM WHAT WE DO NOW IS THAT THE
PROBLEM IS TOO SEVERE AND THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE TOO GREAT.
TRANSPARENCY REGULATION REFORM
IS THE NECESSARY AND IMPORTANT
STAR TREK HEARING OUR INTERNET
THANK YOU. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT LOVE
PROFESSOR MACKINNON IF
PROFESSOR MACKINNON- VISITING
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT HARVARD LAW
IN AT MICHIGAN LAW IF BOB IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE IF YOU COULD
MAKE YOURSELF KNOWN. AND IF
NOT- WE COULDN'T COME BACK TO
THE PANEL FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AND THEN SEE IF
PROFESSOR MACKINNON HAS JOINED
US- QUESTIONS COMMENTS. YES
CENTER CORTESE. WITH EARTH-
THANK YOU TO REMEMBER- HE HAS
FOR THE LAST THE LAST
PRESENTER- THIS CRAP JUST ON
THE TRANSPARENCY ISSUE- IN THE
PLEASE I HOPE THIS QUESTION
COMES ACROSS THIS- IT'S NOT A
SORT OF A PARTISAN QUESTION
TERMS OF TAKING SIDES ON ON THE
ISSUE I AM INTERESTED IN
INTERESTED IN HEARING MORE. AS
TO- WHERE YOU DRAW THE LINE IN
TERMS OF. SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU. HE WOULD HE WOULD
WANT TO PROTECT FROM A
PROPRIETARY THE SECURITY
STANDPOINT- SO THE PEOPLE CAN'T
MANIPULATE TAKE WHAT THEY'VE
LEARNED FROM THE TRANSPARENCY
AND MANIPULATED- UNIVERSES.
ASSEMBLY THERE IS A CONCERN
WHICH I THINK YOU KNOW ARE ARE
CLEAR AND OBVIOUS AND YOU DID A
GREAT JOB OF RECITING IN TERMS
OF- EXTREMIST BEHAVIOR I THINK
IT KIND OF GOES BACK TO SOME OF
THE EARLIER QUESTIONS. ON A PER
PANEL THAT SOME OF US WERE
ASKING ABOUT. I'M FIGHTING
WORDS OR WORDS THAT WOULD
INCITE RIOTS- YOU KNOW CLEARLY.
A TRANSPARENCY- AROUND THOSE
KIND OF ISSUES- WHEN- PERHAPS
IT'S NOT THE PLATFORM OF. SORT
OF PERPETRATING- THE THAT THAT
KIND OF LANGUAGE OF THOSE KIND
OF CONCERNS- WILL BECOME
CONCERNS IT'S ITS THIRD PARTY
USERS- I COULD I COULD SEE
TRANSPARENCY THAT. THAT HELPS
US NO OR OR UNDERSTAND WHERE
THAT CONTENT IS COMING FROM-
THAT KIND OF TRANSPARENCY- JUST
LIKE A HAD A NEWSPAPER WOULD
WANT TO KNOW WHEN SOMEONE
WRITES A LETTER TO THE EDITOR-
IS A COMMON PRACTICE ALL WAS
ELECTED OFFICIALS I THINK KNOWS
YOU'LL GET A AN EMAIL BACK
SAYING WE NEED TO VERIFY THIS
IS REALLY YOU- IN THIS SORT OF
A FORM OF TRANSPARENCY- BUT BUT
WHERE DO YOU DRAW THAT LINE AND
I GUESS WHAT I'M REALLY ASKING
IF I MISSED IT I APOLOGIZE. IS
THERE A BODY OF WORK THE YOU
CAN INVOLVED WITH THAT YOU'RE
AWARE OF THAT BEGINS TO- SORT
OF THRUST THAT OUT. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR REGARDING
WHERE WE DRAW THE LINE IT'S
ACTUALLY PLATFORMS THAT ARE
DRAWING THESE LINES BECAUSE
WHAT WE'RE SEEKING WHEN IT
COMES TO TRANSPARENCY IS
INFORMATION ABOUT THE POLICIES
THAT ARE PUT OUT BY PLATFORMS
CLEARLY TO THOSE POLICIES HOW
THEY'RE ENFORCED WHAT CHANGES
HAVE BEEN MADE WHAT EXCEPTIONS
HAVE BEEN MADE AND THEN
REGARDING DATA AND METRICS WHAT
WOULD BE INCREDIBLY HELPFUL IS
AGGREGATED ANONYMIZED DATA.
REGARDING THE ENFORCEMENT OF
THESE POLICIES HOW HAS IT
CHANGED OVER TIME CAN WE
COMPARE QUARTER TO QUARTER SO I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY
GET AROUND THAT BECAUSE WHEN WE
SEE MORE INFORMATION REGARDING
PLATFORM POLICIES AND
ENFORCEMENT THEY ARE CREATING
THE RULES AND GUIDELINES THAT
THEY WANT TO HAVE ON THEIR
PLATFORMS WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW
IS WHAT ARE THESE EXACT RULES
AND GUIDELINES HOW HAVE THEY
CHANGED OVER TIME. WHAT ARE THE
EXCEPTIONS AND WHAT IS THE
ANONYMIZED AND AGGREGATED DATA
TO HELP US SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THESE POLICIES ARE BEING FORCED
EQUITABLY AND AT SCALE. IF I
CAN JUST BUY OF PROBLEM A
PRETTY ANALOGY- IN APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT BUT- IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WORK BY BY STATE
LAW THERE'S A THING CALLED THE
BROWN ACT WHICH- IS ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY IT'S ABOUT-
TRANSPARENCY THE PUBLIC IN
TERMS OF THE BUSINESS OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT YOU HAVE TO DO
IT. OPENLY BUT THERE ARE
CERTAIN- EXCLUSIONS TO THAT. IN
AND ONE OF THEM- IT IS. WOULD
YOU HAVE HER THREATS- WHEN YOU
HAVE. TERRORIST ACTIVITY THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS IT'S NOT THAT.
IT'S NOT THAT THE ENTITIES
INVOLVED DON'T WANT TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT. BUT THERE'S
SORT OF A- A LIMITED VERSION OF
TRANSPARENCY WORD THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS ALLOWED TO TAKE.
THAT CONTENT BUT TAKE THAT
ISSUE I'M SORRY TAKE THE ISSUE
INTO A- INTO A MORE CLOISTERED.
THE LESS SAID. PRESIDENTIALLY A
NON PUBLIC ENVIRONMENT AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE ELECTED
OFFICIALS GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS-
AND- THOSE WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PROTECTING THE PUBLIC CAN
STILL. GET THAT INFORMATION
THAT THEY NEED AND GET IT ON
THE TABLE AND FIGURE OUT
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S SOME
ACTION OBVIOUS REASON FOR THAT
IS BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT TO
TELEGRAPH. TO THE VERY
PERPETRATORS- WHAT YOUR NEXT.
PLAN IS GOING TO BE- WE
RESPONSE IS GOING TO BE AN OPEN
PUBLIC ENVIRONMENT. AND SO. I'M
WONDERING IF THERE'S BEEN
THOUGHT IT YOU KNOW FROM. FROM
FROM YOUR SIDE OF THINGS- THE
LEAGUE- YOU KNOW OTHER ALLIES
SO TO SPEAK ABOUT SOME SORT OF
A HYBRID. APPROACH WHERE- YOU
KNOW IT'S THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION IS NOT OFF LIMITS
BUT IT'S SERVER QUEUES FROM THE
PUBLIC UNTIL. APPROPRIATE
GOVERNMENTAL. OVERSIGHT COULD
CAN COME IN IN A MORE
CONFIDENTIAL MANNER AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S REALLY GOING
ON. ABSOLUTELY I THINK WHAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT HERE IS TO
KNOW THAT WELL TRANSPARENCY
ISN'T EASY IT'S CERTAINLY
POSSIBLE SOMETHING'S ACTUALLY
CAN AND SHOULD BE DISCLOSED TO
THE PUBLIC AT LARGE LIKE I
MENTIONED BEFORE WHAT ARE THE
POLICIES HOW ARE HEY BEING
ENFORCED GIVE US SOME
ANONYMIZED AND AGGREGATED DATA
TO BETTER ENFORCEMENT. AND AS
YOU MENTIONED THERE MIGHT BE
OTHER TYPES OF TRANSPARENCY
METHODS AND MECHANISMS THAT
MIGHT HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE WE CAN
ABSOLUTELY GET THIS DONE WE CAN
LOOK THROUGH ADL HAS WORKED
EXTENSIVELY ON IT AND WE'VE
OUTLINED WHAT WE THINK IS
NECESSARY FOR TRANSPARENCY FROM
A PUBLIC VETTING. AND WE
ABSOLUTELY CAN AND SHOULD WORK
TO GET MORE INFORMATION FROM
PLATFORM FOR RESEARCHERS AND
ACADEMICS SO WE CAN BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM AND EXCO
I THINK IT'S A BOTH. ENDS NOT
AN EITHER OR- THANK YOU FOR. TO
PREVIEW THE SHALL. THANK YOU.
SIR STERN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I'M I'M CURIOUS TO GET A
SENSE FROM- THE REPRESENTED FOR
THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION MR
HOFFMAN- THE SOME OF THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
INTEGRITY INSTITUTE FROM DOCTOR
ALLEN- IN TERMS OF THE TYPES
OF. OF INFORMATION THAT WOULD
BE USEFUL TO BE- REPORTED-
TRANSPARENTLY OR WITH
RESEARCHERS AS WELL AS- OUR
LAST PANELISTS FROM EIGHTY L.
IT DOES THAT JIBE WITH WHAT THE
COMPANIES ARE CURRENTLY DOING
WHERE WHERE DO YOU SEE THE
DISPARITY IN IS THERE ANY- OF
VERSION TO THE KIND OF
DISCLOSURE THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT. NO I THINK OUT OF BASE
LEVEL YOU KNOW WE'RE OPEN TO
IMPROVING TRANSPARENCY I THINK
AN IMPROVING OUR METRICS WELL
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE THE
METRICS ARE IMPORTANT SO THAT
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT- WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO ENFORCE OUR
STANDARDS AND SO- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY DOCTOR ALLEN IS THIS
FAR MORE OF THE- THE DATA
ASPECT AND I AM AS FAR AS- HOW
TO COLLECT THOSE AND SO I FOUND
THIS PRESENTATION VERY
INTERESTING THAT'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT ARE THAT ARE
COMPANIES ARE ARE TALKING ABOUT
INTERNALLY- I CAN'T SPEAK TO
HER TO THOSE INTERNAL
CONVERSATION BUT I CAN'T SAY
GENERALLY WE ARE CONSIDERING A
LOT OF WAYS AS A INDUSTRY- TO
IMPROVE THOSE SO. I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE IN THAT INFORMATION AND
TRYTO EVALUATE- WHERE AND HOW
WE CAN- IMPROVE ZONES- YOU KNOW
DATA FLOWS FOR PUBLIC
INFORMATION. THANKS FOR- YOU
KNOW I'M I'M- I'M I'M WRESTLING
WITH THIS SORT OF RESEARCH
CONTEXT WHICH SOUNDS SO
INNOCUOUS AND YET- WHAT WE SAW
HAPPEN TO THE IN THE CASE OF AN
WHY YOU AND THE IS IT CALLED AD
TRACKER. I'M CURIOUS ABOUT
WHETHER ADAM FOR MANY OF OUR
ACADEMICS HERE OR RESEARCHERS
HAVE YOU ALL- DID YOU FOLLOW
THINK THERE ARE OTHER-
INSTANCES WHERE. THIS KIND OF
SORT OF PUBLICLY INTERESTED
ACADEMIC RESEARCH IS BEING-
QUASHED OR OTHERWISE DENIED
UNDER THE AUSPICES OF PRIVACY
CONCERNS. I'LL JUST QUICKLY
MENTION SENATOR THAT- THE CASE
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT-
INVOLVES ONE EDL SULFUR FELLOWS
LARA ADOLESCENT WHO WAS REVOKED
pMORE RESEARCH TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE ADVERTISING
ADVERTISING ECOSYSTEM ON
FACEBOOK AND HOW THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT HAVE IMPACTED THINGS
LIKE THE INSURRECTION AND YES
IT'S INCREDIBLY CONCERNING
ACCESS TO RESEARCHERS. FOR
SPECIFIC TYPES OF DATA IS BEING
REVOKED. SOMETIMES ANY WARNING
AND CERTAINLY WITHOUT ANY
SPECIFIC- JUSTIFICATION
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
JUSTIFICATION WAS THAT THERE
WERE SOME SORT OF FTC BREACH OF
THE ACT YOU SEE CAME OUT AND
SAID THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE NEED
MORE ACCESS TO RESEARCHERS AND
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT IT'S
CONSISTENT AND NOT BEING
REVOKED WITHOUT ANY WARNING.
DOCTOR ALLEN ANY ANY- ANY SENSE
ON THE IF YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE UNDERTAKEN WITHOUT A
CHANGE IN. SAY STATE OR FEDERAL
LAW- DO YOU SEE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR UNDERTAKING. AS THESE
KINDS OF MEASURES. WILL FULLY
OR DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE THE FORCE OF LAW OR
SOME OTHER KIND OF PUBLIC
FRAMEWORK TO. TO BRING. I GUESS
INTEGRITY FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WORD. YEAH I THINK- WE
DEFINITELY SEE PLATFORMS TAKING
STEPS IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION-
YOU KNOW CREDIT WHERE CREDIT IS
DUE RIGHT LIKETHE MAJOR
PLATFORMS HAVE- BEEN PROACTIVE
IN IN DISCLOSING BOTH DATA SETS
AND NUMBERS- I THINK WE NEED A
LOT MORE I THINK THERE'S A LOT
MORE TO BE DONE- AND SO I GUESS
LIKE WE WILL SEE IF WE ARE ABLE
TO GET- COMPREHENSIVE
TRANSPARENCY. ON A VOLUNTARY
BASIS I'M I DO THINK THATYOU
KNOW ONE THING TO CONSIDER IS
THAT WE ARE NOT. WE HAVE NOT
SEEN EVERY SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM THAT WE WILL EVER SEE
RIGHT- TECH TALK IS THAT IS NOT
THE LAST PLATFORM THEY'LL EVER
SORT OF LIKE REACH A BILLION
USERS- WE SHOULD EXPECT NEW
PLATFORMS TO COME UP IN THE
FUTURE- AND WE SHOULD NOT
ALWAYS NECESSARILY EXPECT THEM.
TO PROACTIVELY FOLLOW THESE ARE
LIKE BEST PRACTICES. IN SERVICE
RIGHT I THINK I SAW PROFESSOR.
RAISING HER HAND TO RESPOND TO
YOUR QUESTION. SO PROFESSOR
CLINIC WE WERE YOU RAISING YOUR
HAND OR- OR JUST SAYING HELLO.
NO I WAS RAISING MY HAND I WAS
GOING TO SPEAK TO THE LAUREL AT
LORETTA'S WILL SIMPLY BREAK-
THIS CRAFT WAS. PERFECT IN HER
RESPONSE AND SUMMED UP ALL OF
THE SAME POINTS THAT WAS GOING
TO MAKE. ALREADY THEIR-
SINISTER GO HEAD TO PUT THANK
YOU MR. I DIDN'T KNOW- IF
MISCONDUCT I KNOW YOU ARE OUT
IN NEW YORK OR THEREABOUTS- ARE
THERE OTHER CASES BEYOND THE
NYU RESEARCH THAT. ARE OF
CONCERN TO YOU I MEAN. YOUR YOU
KNOW YOU'RE IT YOU'RE A LAW
SCHOOL YOU'RE DOING-
INFORMATION ANALYSIS. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER EFFORTS- SORT OF
RECTIFY. OR IS IT IS IT'S
CURRENTLY JUST THE. THE
LITIGATION THAT'S UNDER WAY
FROM THE N. Y. U. AGAIN. FOR
THAT SORT OF AN ADDICT. YU
THINK HOW THIS WHOLE. LANDSCAPE
OCCURS I AM IS THERE A BIG
BURDEN THEN TAKE THEM ON- YOU
KNOW WITHOUT SERIOUS LEGAL
COUNSEL BUT- YEAH I'M JUST
CURIOUS YOUR PERSPECTIVE THERE.
YEAH OF COURSE AND REALLY
QUICKLY I KNOW IT'S A REALLY
SMALL POINT BUT I JUST WANTED
TO SAY AS MUCH AS CALIFORNIA
WANTS TO THANK THAT BUT- HERE'S
THE- AS CAL. GOES GOES THE
NATION THAT ACTUALLY THE PHRASE
MEETING FORTY AND IT'S ASKING
GOES SO GOES THE NATION SO LIKE
I JUST. THANKS PANEL ABOUT
MISSING PER. JUST GOT EXTENT
BETTER OUT THERE- ANYWAY. I BE.
THE POINT THAT I WAS GOING TO
MAKE IT YES THERE ARE KINDS
THAT THERE LOTS OF DIFFERENT.
THAT THE COMPANY ARE ENGAGING
WITH RESEARCHERS AND SOCIAL
SCIENCE RESEARCHERS- I'M
LETTING ME INSIDE FACEBOOK
WITHOUT AN NDA. AND ALLOW ME TO
TAKE CONVERSATIONS- A VERY-
UNUSUAL STEP FOR THE COMPANY OF
STEAK AND HADN'T DONE NOT WITH
PRETTY MUCH ANYONE BEFORE AND-
AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S DONE
SO CENTS THERE'S A FEW
REPORTERS I THINK WHO HAVE
LIMITED NDAS OR SOME TYPE OF
THING BUT THERE IS. THAT WAS A
BIG STEP AND THE MAIN REASON
THAT THEY LET ME DO THAT WAS
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A HUGE TRANSPARENCY
INITIATIVE AND SO IS GOING TO
LOOK A LITTLE BIT. SKETCHY IF
THEY WANTED SOMEONE TO COME IN
AND BRING TRANSPARENCY AND
THEN. LIKE SADDLE THEM WITH AN
NDA BUT MORE OF THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
KIND OF ANTHROPOLOGISTS LIKE
KIND AND SOCIAL SCIENTISTS
GOING IN AND TALKING TO THE
COMPANIES THAT SEEING WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE INSIDE AND
BRINGING US OUT. I DIDN'T JUST
OBSERVE OF COURSE LIKE OVER THE
COURSE OF A YEAR INSIDE
FACEBOOK ON AND OFF. JUST
FACEBOOK- AND THAT ONE TEAM I
DEVELOP SOURCES I MET PEOPLE I
LIKE DEVELOP PEOPLE WHO.
CONTINUE TO TELL ME THINGS
TODAY- THAT ARE SIMILAR TO THE
TYPES OF THINGS THAT I FIND
FROM BY IT BUT- LAND CREDENCE
TO EVERYTHING REFERENCES HOW
GOING TO- COME OUT AND SAID-
AND I THINK THAT THOSE TYPES OF
RELATIONSHIPS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT. BETWEEN KIND OF
ACADEMICS AND SCHOLARSHIP
ALWAYS THAT AND JOURNALISTS TO
VOICE SUDDENLY KIND OF THE EDGE
OF GATEKEEPING BETWEEN THAT
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATORS AND-
AND THE FIRMS SO JUST TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT- LARA ADOLESCENTS
WHICH IS. THAT KAIST.
FACEBOOK'S BEEN IT LIKE
DISTRICT OF JUST GIVES A LITTLE
BIT OF CLARITY OF LIKE WHY
WOULD FACE. DO SO LIKE THAT ONE
OF THE REASONS THAT THEY DID
SOME LIKE THIS IS BECAUSE- THE
TYPE OF RESEARCH. THAT EDELSON
WAS ENGAGED IN WAS BASICALLY
USING A PLUGIN OR API TO. GREAT
PERSONALLY. INFORMATION
CONCEIVABLY FROM FACEBOOK- SO
THAT THEY COULD USE THAT THEY
WOULD REMOVE THE K. I. IF THE
PERCENT OF VIOLENT. PATIENT AND
THEN THEY WOULD TRY TO LIKE USE
THAT AND THE REASON THAT
THEY'RE DOING THAT. IS BECAUSE
THERE IS. A FAILURE OF THE
COMPANY IS TO PROVIDE THAT TYPE
OF INFORMATION. ON THEIR OWN
AND THERE IS A LACK OF TRUST.
BETWEEN WHAT THE COMPANIES WILL
PROVIDE RESEARCHERS VERSUS WHAT
THEY THINK THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GET ON THEIR OWN AND I WILL
SAY THAT I THINK THERE NEEDS TO
BE BOTH. YOU HAVE TO HAVE
PEOPLE LIKE LAUREL SAID OUT
THERE SCRAPING AND SEEING
WHAT'S GOING ON PEOPLE ACTUAL
SPEEDS AND YOU HAVE TO CHECK
THAT AGAINST WHAT THE COMPANIES
ARE PROVIDING. THAT IS WHAT
LIKE LITERALLY THE DEFINITION
OF ACCOUNTABILITY THAT COME
THROUGH TWO PHASES OF
TRANSPARENCY- I JUST WILL SAY
REALLY QUICKLY TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY. THIS IS. A
WORD THAT GETS BANDIED ABOUT IS
THIS MAGIC BULLET IT IS SO
COMPLICATED AND IT CHANGES
MEANING ACROSS DIFFERENT
CONTEXTS AND DEFERRED BALANCES-
WE DO NOT EXPECT FOR EXAMPLE.
THE SUPREME COURT TO TELL US
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS IN
CHAMBERS OR IN DARK
CORRESPONDENCE BETWEEN THEM.
THERE IS A CERTAIN AMOUNT THAT
WE ARE ALLOW PEOPLE TO LIKE
HAVE THE PRIVACY OF THEIR IDEAS
AND LIKE. AND HOW THEY MAKE
DECISIONS. BUT HAVING A REAL
ACTS. IN A AT THE END OF THE
DAY. AND SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE
PUT THEIR NAME. AND REFERENCE.
AND LIKE ENTIRE STATURE OF
THEIR OFFICE BEHIND IS WHY WE
MIGHT PUT FAITH IN THE LAW. AND
THAT SYSTEM WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING CLOSE TO THAT RIGHT
NOW. AND YET. THESE COMPANIES
ARE GOVERNING US IN THIS WAY
OVER A HAVING EVEN THOUGH THEIR
PRIVATE COMPANIES I WILL SAY
THEY'RE MORE LIKE A PUBLIC
SQUARE. THAN ANYTHING ELSE- AND
THEY ARE DOING THAT KIND OF
FROM A PRIVATE PERSPECTIVE
WITHOUT WITH LIMITED REPORTS
FOR SOME OF THE THINGS I DO
THINK THEY'VE TRIED TO GET
THERE IN VARIOUS WAYS AND-
SOMETIMES THEY'VE- DONE WELL
AND SOMETIMES THEY HAVEN'T. AND
THIS JUST NEEDS TO KEEP THIS
CONVERSATION JUST NEED TO KEEP
HAPPENING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU JUST A
BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING WE'RE GONNA
TURN TO PROFESSOR MACKINNON IN
JUST A MOMENT. OF FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO'VE BEEN WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT- NOW'S A
GOOD TIME TO QUEUE UP IF YOU
HAVEN'T ALREADY QUEUED UP I'LL
GIVE YOU THE NUMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. THE PARTICIPANT NUMBERS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. EIGHT SIX
SEVEN SIX ONE SIX THREE THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE
FOUR. SEVEN EIGHT TWO FOUR.
WHEN YOU. ARE IN OUR QUEUED UP
TO. PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT IT
WILL JUST SIMPLY BE PUBLIC
COMMENT THATTHE PANEL WILL NOT
BE AVAILABLE TO RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT. SO LET'S
TURN TO PROFESSOR MACKINNON
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU LOUD
AND CLEAR THANK YOU SO
BEAUTIFUL THANK YOU BUT CHAIRED
SENATOR UMBERG OF FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE PART OF THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION AND- ALSO- SENATOR
CABALLERO- IF SHE IS STILL
THERE THANK YOU AS WELL- AND
ENERGY TO BE. TESTIFYING AT AT
YOUR HEARING AS JUST ONE PART
OF THE RANGE OF ISSUES THAT ARE
CONFRONTED HERE IN THIS. REALLY
CRUCIAL A CRITICAL
CONVERSATION- I'M GOING TO BE
DISCUSSING SENATOR CORTEZ IS
TIMELY BILL S. B. FOUR THIRTY
FIVE. OF WHICH RESPONSE TO A
PROBLEM THAT HAS EXISTED FOR A
REALLY LONG TIME- IT HAS NEVER
BEEN ADEQUATELY LEGALLY ADDRESS
DESPITE. SOME WELL INTENTIONED
EFFORTS AND HAS BECOME MORE AND
MORE HARMFUL TO THOSE
VICTIMIZED BY IT AS THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT YOU ALL HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSING WITH SUCH DEPTH
AND NUANCE AND SCOPE OF
INFORMATION TODAY- LEAVING IN.
ISNS OF WHICH THIS BILL WOULD
BEGIN TO BRING INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY- AS YOU ALL
PROBABLY KNOW A SENATOR COLORED
TENNESSEE'S BILL. ADDRESSES OR
CREATES A CIVIL CAUSE OF ACTION
FOR ANYONE WHO IS SEX
TRAFFICKED ONLINE. US THROUGH
NAKED OR SEXUAL PHOTOGRAPHS OF
THEM. THAT ARE COERCED TRICKED
OR STOLEN. FROM THEM OR MADE OR
DISTRIBUTED WITHOUT THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OR THEIR EXPRESSED
FREELY GIVEN PERMISSION NOW
THESE MATERIALS OF COURSE ARE
JUST ONE SEGMENT OF THE
INDUSTRY THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
INTO. IT'S A LARGE SUAVE OF THE
INTERNET- BUT ACTUALLY- ONLY
ONE LIMITED SECTOR OF THE
HARMS- THAT YOU'VE BEEN SO
CAREFULLY INTERROGATING- THIS
BILL IS SITUATED IN THE LEGALLY
ESTABLISHED CONTEXT OF FEDERAL
ANTI TRAFFICKING LAW WHICH
PROHIBITS COMMERCIAL SEX
ADDICTS THROUGH FORCE FRAUD OR
COERCION AND ADVERTISING THOSE
AT THIS BILLS PARTICULAR
CONTRIBUTION ALSO INCLUDES A
STRONG NOTICE REQUIREMENT-
WHICH IS. LAKE CALIFORNIA'S
LIBEL LAW IN PERMITTING
IMMEDIATE CORRECTION WITHOUT
THE PAYMENT OF DAMAGES AND IT
ALSO PERMITS STATUTORY DAMAGES
ALONG WITH OTHER FORMS OF
RELIEF SUCH AS INJUNCTIONS BUT
ONLY IF THIS NOTICE IS IGNORED
AND THE INJURY CONTINUES- WHEN
PEOPLE ARE BEING SEX TRAFFICKED
ONLINE AGAINST THEIR WILL. IT
IS AS JOURNALISTS HAVE RECENTLY
DOCUMENTED A TYPICAL FOR
DISTRIBUTORS OF ABDUCTED SEXUAL
MATERIALS THESE DAYS TO IGNORE
THEIR PLEAS FOR TAKING THEM
DOWN DESPITE THE FACT THAT SOME
OF THESE LATFORMS SAY
OTHERWISE- THIS GOES ON FOR
WEEKS EVEN YEARS OF IT AND IT'S
ALSO FAIRLY TYPICAL OF THEM- TO
REGARD FINES OR DAMAGE AWARDS.
ABOUT WHICH ARE INFORMATION IS
LIMITED- TO. A CENTRALLY A COST
OF DOING BUSINESS. AND
TYPICALLY THE DAMAGE AWARDS
HAVE BEEN LIMITED TO THOSE WHO
ARE VIOLATED IN THESE WAYS WHO
ARE UNDER AGE EIGHTEEN WHO ARE
A CRUCIAL SEGMENT OF THE PEOPLE
HARMED HERE BUT ARE ONLY ONE
PART OF THEM. SO WHAT HAS
HAPPENED HERE IS THAT THE
PURVEYORS OF THESE MATERIALS.
OUR CONTINUE TO PROFIT FROM
STOLEN INTIMATE INVASIONS AND
VIOLATIONS SO THIS PROPOSED LAW
COULD BRING AN END TO THAT. IT
GOES BEYOND EXISTING CALIFORNIA
LAW TO MENTION JUST A FEW WAYS
IN WHICH IT DOES THAT- IN NOT
BEING LIMITED TO CIVIL
OBSCENITY MATERIALS AS THE
EXISTING HUMAN TRAFFICKING LAW
FOR ADULTS IS IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE THE OBSCENITY DEFINITION
IT'S HARM. THAT IS THE IDEA OF
HARM IS NOT PART OF OBSCENITY
LAW- THE HARM USED TO MAKE THE
MATERIALS FOR EXAMPLE. ARE IS
COMPLETELY IRELEVANT TO ITS
LEGAL DEFINITION AND ALSO IT'S
WELL KNOWN THAT IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO PROVE OBSCENITY.
OF SENATOR CORTEZ IS LAW IS
ALSO NOT VOIDED IF THE
MATERIALS WERE MADE IN A PUBLIC
PLACE AS QUITE A LOT. OF THESE
MATERIALS ARE ALTHOUGH BY NO
MEANS ALL AND IT ALSO IS A
VOIDED IF THE MATERIALS WERE
EVER SENT BEFORE BY ANYONE- AS
THE REVENGE PORN LAW IN
CALIFORNIA IS LIMITED. AND HIS
BILL COVERS THOSE WHO ACTUALLY
HAD THE SEX IN THE PHOTOGRAPHS
UNLIKE THE CURRENT CALIFORNIA
DEEP FAKE LAW WHICH ONLY
COVERS. THE PEOPLE IN THOSE
MATERIALS WHO DIDN'T- AND THIS
LAW PARTICULARLY WITH ITS
STRONG NOTICE REQUIREMENT. WHAT
MAKES THE JOB OF SOCIAL MEDIA
NETWORKS AND PLATFORMS EASIER
WHO SAY THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE SELLING THE MATERIALS
MATERIALS THAT ARE COERCED OR
STOLEN. OR TAKEN AWAY FROM
PEOPLE WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE
OR PERMISSION OF THE MATERIALS
MADE ACTIONABLE BY S. B. FOR
THIRTY FIVE. IT WOULD ASSIST
THEM IN IDENTIFYING THOSE
MATERIALS- AT THIS POINT THEY
HIRE THEY SAY A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE TO ATTEMPT TO CREATE THESE
IDENTIFICATIONS WILL THIS BILL
WOULD HELP THEM. A LOT IN THAT
RESPECT. IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING
THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT HAS
NEVER PROTECTED COERCED STOLEN
SEXUAL MATERIALS OR THOSE OF
MADE OR DISTRIBUTED WITHOUT ANY
PERMISSION OF THOSE USED TO
MAKE THEM. THERE IS NO
MOUSETRAP HERE- WHERE MEDIA
PLATFORMS ARE WORRIED ABOUT
BECOMING LIABLE FOR MATERIALS
THEY COULD NOT POSSIBLY HAVE
KNOWN- WERE EITHER OF WHICH IS-
PREVENTING WHICH WAS THE MAIN
GOAL OF FEDERAL SECTION TWO
THIRTY- HERE NOTHING CAN HAPPEN
A WITHOUT NOTICE AND- IT'S ONLY
WHEN THAT NOTICE IS IGNORED-
THAT THE STATUTORY DAMAGES
START TO ATTACH. AND ANY
LIABILITY CAN TAKE PLACE- IT'S
ALSO AGAIN WORTH NOTICING IS
THAT CHILD **** WHICH- IS ARE
PROHIBITED UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
AND ALSO FEDERAL LAW IS ASSUMED
TO BE COERCED OR MANIPULATED OR
STOLEN AND- HARMFUL. TO THOSE
WHO ARE IN IT THEREFORE THERE
IS NO FIRST AMENDMENT
PROTECTION TO IT WHAT THIS LAW
DOES IS MAKES EXPLICIT ALL
THOSE ASSUMED PRECONDITIONS.
FOR ADULTS AND REQUIRES PROOF
OF THOSE ABUSES BEFORE ANYTHING
CAN BE DONE ABOUT THE
MATERIALS- AND I'D ALSO BE
HAPPY TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION.
OF THE IMPOSSIBILITY OF
PROTECTING CHILDREN- WITHOUT
ALSO OF PROTECTING COERCED
ADULTS ARE WHEN IT COMES TO
NAKED AND SEXUAL MATERIALS. ARE
MADE WITHOUT THEIR PERMISSION-
I THINK AS HE IS RECOGNIZED BY-
THIS LARGER CONVERSATION ABOUT.
THE PROBLEMS OF DIGITAL MEDIA-
AND THAT IT IS PAST TIME FOR
THE LAW TO CATCH UP WITH
PREDATORS WHO HAVE LONG BEEN
ALLOWED TO OPERATE IN THE LEGAL
SHADOWS BUT ACTUALLY ON THE
BRIGHT CUTTING EDGE. OF VISIBLE
TECHNOLOGY. OF SEX TRAFFICKING
CHILDREN AND ADULTS MOSTLY
WOMEN AND GIRLS ALSO TRANS
PEOPLE- REAPING GARGANTUAN
PROFITS AND CONTINUING TO EVADE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN WAYS THAT
DAMAGE EVEN DESTROY LIVES WITH
IMPUNITY. SO THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND I
REGRET I WASN'T ABLE TO BE
PRESENT A BECAUSE OF TEACHING.
OF FOR THE LEGAL PAN ALL OF
THAT PRECEDED SURE I HAVE
LEARNED A LOT FROM IT AND- I
WOULDN'T. UP BUT WOULD BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
ARE THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN RISE
TO BY- BOTH OF THE EXPERTISE ON
THAT PANEL AND ANY QUESTIONS.
THAT THE SENATORS ARE OTHERS
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU PROFESSOR
MACKINNON QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THE CORTESE. PROFESSOR IT A
MINUTE BERMAN A RISK PER- SURE
PREFER MISTER FREEZING OR-
RESTATING. SOMETHING THAT WAS
SAID EARLIER THERE PRESENTED
EARLIER AND I APOLOGIZE-
PROBABLY NOT SO MUCH TO YOU. TO
THAT BUT TO THOSE. WHO OF WHO
I'M TRYING TO PARAPHRASE BUT-
WE WERE- EARLIER PRESENTED WITH
A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
INFORMATION ON BOTH THE FIRST
AMENDMENT- CAN SECTION TWO
THIRTY IN TERMS OF WHAT. HE YOU
KNOW I WOULD SAY IN THIS IS A
PARAPHRASE THIS IS MY OWN
TAKEAWAY- WE SEEM TO PRESENT IT
ALMOST- AN IMPENETRABLE
FORTRESS OF. OF OBSTACLE
CREATED- BY PARTICULARLY
SECTION TWO THIRTY- BUT TO SOME
EXTENT OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT-
AND I APPRECIATE YOU SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY TO THE BILL- IN
YOUR PRESENTATION- THAT I HAVE
PENDING- BUT ASIDE FROM AS
BEFORE THIRTY FIVE I REALLY ONE
**** THIS MORE GENERAL QUESTION
OF U. S. AS AN EXPERT- IN THIS
AREA- WHICH I ASKED OF THEM. IT
HE IF YOU KNOW HOW FRAME IT
THIS WAY- I BELIEVE THAT WE
WERE TOLD BY EARLY PRESENTATION
THAT IT IS IT NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
CREATE PRIVATE CAUSES OF
ACTION. IN THE AREAS THAT YOU
WERE JUST DESCRIBING- IN TERMS
OF TRAFFICKING AND SO FORTH-
WITHOUT RUNNING AFOUL OF
SECTION TWO THIRTY IN PERHAPS
EVEN- FIRST AMENDMENT
PROTECTIONS- I THINK THERE
WERE. SEVERAL QUESTIONS ASKED
BY. MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE
DAIS BUT WITH REGARD. TO
WHETHER OR NOT UNPROTECTED
SPEECH IS STILL COVERED BY
SECTION TWO THIRTY OR OR OF
COURSE THE FIRST AMENDMENT AS
WE UNDERSTAND IT- THINGS LIKE
FIGHTING WORDS AND SO FORTH-
INTO THE DESIRE TO INCITE A
RIOT HOPE WE UP HERE. I THINK
MOST OF US UNDERSTAND IS
UNPROTECTED SPEECH- IS IT GOING
BACK TO THE ONLINE TRAFFICKING
ISSUE THAT AS YOU DESCRIBED IT
OR TO IT. IS UNPROTECTED IS A-
ARE IN GENERAL HOW DO YOU COPE
HOUSES POSITION TO ALLOW. ONCE
NOTICED IS DENIED HE'S PRIVATE
RIGHTS OF ACTION IN EUROPEAN WE
HEARD OTHERS OPINIONS ON THAT.
WELL YOU KNOW IN A SENSE IT'S A
GENERAL DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
WHOLE ARRAY OF QUESTIONS THAT
YOU'RE CONFRONTING HERE AS IN
MIS INFORMATION FOR EXAMPLE-
THERE IS NO QUESTION BUT THAT
INFORMATION IS SPEECH- IF YOU
CAN EVEN BEGIN TO THINK ABOUT
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
MISINFORMATION- YOU'RE ALREADY
WAY BEYOND SOMETHING I'M
TALKING ABOUT HERE- BECAUSE
YOU'RE DEFINING WHAT'S ACCURATE
AND WHAT'S NOT ACCURATE- IN
TERMS OF INFORMATION THAT IS
ALLOWED TO BE SPOKEN. OUT
THERE- THIS IN ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT YOU KNOW
ELECTION LIES AND BUT WHATEVER-
AND IS TEMP TO YOU KNOW PRIVATE
COMPANIES OF TAKING IT DOWN
THAT'S NOT IN A FIRST AMENDMENT
ISSUE BUT- MOVING INTO
REGULATION THERE ARE ALSO
REGULATION OF ALGORITHMS WHICH-
OPERATE TO MULTIPLY MULTIPLY-
ACCESS TO. A SIMILAR MATERIALS
ACROSS- THE ACROSS PLATFORMS
AND NETWORKS. IF YOU'RE EVEN
CONSIDERING- LEGAL APPROACHES
TO ANY OF THAT ALL OF THIS. I
YOU KNOW WE HAVE- FRANCES HOGAN
GOING BEFORE CONGRESS JUST TO
SAY TO EXPAND ON THIS
PARTICULAR MORE GENERAL POINT
AND THEN I'LL ANSWER THE MORE
SPECIFIC ONE- ABOUT ABOUT YOUR
BILL SENATOR IS. THAT SHE IS
SAYING THAT OTHER MATERIALS OUT
THERE BIG YOUNG TEENAGE GIRLS
FEEL BETTER ABOUT THEMSELVES
AND THEREFORE PEOPLE ARE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO DO THAT IS THEIR BODY
IMAGE AND SO ON- WHAT WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO DO. TO ADDRESS THAT
HARM REDUCE. REGULATE THE
INDUSTRY SUCH THAT. IT DOESN'T
DO THAT ANYMORE WELL LOOK-
EVERYTHING THAT I AM TALKING
ABOUT IS WAY MORE DIRECT WAY
MORE HARMFUL WAY MORE DRAMATIC.
WE'RE TALKING I'M IN THIS IS
ABOUT MATERIALS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE BY FORCING PEOPLE TO MAKE
THEM OR THEY HAVE BEEN MADE BY
SPYING ON PEOPLE- BY UP THROUGH.
BROUGHT US THROUGH SAYING ONE
THING AND HAVING IT BE ANOTHER
AND THEN STEALING PEOPLE'S
ACTUAL OWN OF MATERIALS OF
THEMSELVES IN A WAY. THAT
PRODUCES DRAMATIC HARMS THAT
ARE PROVABLE IN NO WAY
SPECULATIVE NOT A GROUP BASED
HARM EVEN IT'S A PRIVATE CAUSE
OF ACTION FOR DIRECT PROVEN
HARM AND THE HARM IS THE HARM
OF BEING SEX TRAFFICKED ON
EIGHTEEN ON A NETWORK OR
PLATFORM OUT THERE- AND- IT.
SOMEHOW. THE NOTION THAT WILL
AND CAN CONSIDER- CUTTING BACK
ON MISINFORMATION AND MAKING
YOUNG TEENAGE GIRLS FEEL BAD
ABOUT THEMSELVES BUT ABSOLUTELY
WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
COURSE MATERIALS MATERIALS
CREATED THROUGH FRAUD STOLEN
MATERIALS MATERIALS THAT
PEOPLE- A THAT WERE EITHER
CREATED OR DISTRIBUTED
ABSOLUTELY WITHOUT THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OR PERMISSION. THAT
IS INTRUSIVE VIOLATING AND
DESTRUCTIVE OF THEIR LIVES
GOING FORWARD- IN EXACTLY THE
WAYS THAT- ARE ACTUALLY CHILD
**** IS A CHILDREN UP BUT IN
FACT. MOST PEOPLE- YOU KNOW A
LOT OF A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
VIOLATED AS CHILDREN AND THEN
CONTINUE TO BE VIOLATED AS
ADULTS IN A LOT OF CASES A LOT
OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SEX
TRAFFICKED ONLINE IT WAS DONE
TO THEM AS CHILDREN EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE NOW ADULTS- AND- A LOT
OF THEM. WERE MATURE AS
CHILDREN AND THEREFORE APPEAR
TO BE ADULTS AND THEREFORE THE
CHILD **** LAWS DON'T PROTECT
THEM BECAUSE- YOU HAVE TO HAVE
KNOWN THAT THIS WAS A CHILD IN
OTHER WORDS THEY ONLY
ESSENTIALLY APPLY TO PRE
PUBESCENT CHILDREN- AND- THE
OTHER THING TO POINT OUT IS
THAT. IT IS ALREADY A FEDERALLY
ILLEGAL TO ADVERTISE OF. PEOPLE
FOR WHAT IS THAN SEX
TRAFFICKING WELL THIS IS ALL.
SEX TRAFFICKING BY THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION OF WHAT SEX
TRAFFICKING IS WHICH IS FORCE
FRAUD COERCION. AND NOW WE'RE
SAYING IT CAN'T YOU KNOW WHEN
THERE IS NOTICE OF THIS IT
CAN'T BE SOLD- THE IDEA OF IT I
MEAN. IT OBVIOUSLY ISN'T THE
FIRST AMENDMENT PROTECTED
SPEECH OF THE PEOPLE IN IT
BECAUSE- THAT ISN'T THEIR
SPEECH. IT IS BEEN STOLEN BY
SOMEONE THEY HAVE BEEN COERCED
INTO MAKING IT IT HAS BEEN.
THEY HAVE BEEN VIOLATED IN IN
WAYS AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
VIOLATED FURTHER OF WHEN%
NOTHING CAN BE DONE ABOUT IT
WHEN MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
CERTAINLY ARE SEEING THEIR
SEEING THEM AND THEN CAN
DOWNLOADED AND SALAS SO YOU
KNOW THE NOTION THAT THERE IS
ANY. ESTABLISHED FIRST
AMENDMENT BLOCK TO THIS IS NOT
ACCURATE AS TO THE FIRST
AMENDMENT- AND AS THE SECTION
TWO THIRTY AS I SAID THE WHOLE
POINT OF IT. IS TO. PRE VENT.
OF PLATFORMS THAT COULD HAVE
HAD NO IDEA THAT THIS WAS
HAPPENING ON THEM AS IT TURNS
OUT PORN HUB IN OTHERS. UP HERE
YOU KNOW WE MAY WELL HAVE HAD
QUITE A GOOD IDEA OF WHAT WAS
OUT THERE BECAUSE THE MINUTE
THEY REALLY STARTED LIVING UP
TO WHAT THEY SAY THEY DO. AND
LOOKING INTO AFTER THEY WERE
SUED. BY PEOPLE WHO SAY HEY-
THERE ON YOUR ON YOU AND- I WAS
A CHILD I WAS COERCED I WAS
RAPED. WHEN THIS WAS MADE I
NEVER GAVE PERMISSION FOR THIS
TO BE OUT THERE SUDDENLY THEY
DISCOVERED THAT THERE'S
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS. OF
MATERIALS OUT THERE WHERE. THEY
WERE RAPED- THEY WERE CHILDREN-
THAT HAS BEEN THE CASE ALL
ALONG- BUT NOTHING WAS DONE
ABOUT IT NOT BY THEM NOT BY
ANYBODY. AND YOU KNO SO NOW-
THAT CASE IS SETTLED WE DON'TKNOW ON WHAT TRMS- BUT- THERE
WAS NO BLANKET FIRST AMENDMENT
PART. THERE APPARENTLY WAS NO
BLANKETS- SECTION TWO THIRTY
PART OF THAT- IN ANY CASE- YOU
KNOW THAT AS AS WE HAD TO. OF
THE FOR THAT THERE WAS NO
EXPRESSED. LEGAL CLAIM SUCH AS
SB FOUR THIRTY FIVE WOULD
PROVIDE- ALLOWED IT TO GO ON
AND IT IS STILL GOING ON. SO- I
YOU KNOW I JUST THINK PEOPLE
ARE LAWYERS ARE. NOT ACCURATELY
REPORTING BUT FIRST AMENDMENT
LAW IS OR WHAT THE POINT OF
SECTION TWO THIRTY IS- YOU KNOW
IF SECTION TWO THIRTY WAS DOING
WHAT THEY SAID IT DOES- THE
FEDERAL LAW AGAINST TRAFFICKING
PEOPLE FOR SEX BY ADVERTISING
WHAT IS SEX TRAFFICKING ONLINE
ITSELF WOULD BE ILLEGAL- I MEAN
I DIDN'T HEAR THE CONVERSATION
BUT- NEITHER NEITHER OF THOSE
IS RIGHT. THE PROFESSOR I'M
SORRY GO AHEAD- JUST CAN SAY
THANK YOU FOR RESPONSE AND-
PROFESSOR MACKINNON YEAH AND
THE- EARLIER TO WITNESSES MISS
KELLER AND PROFESSOR GOLDMAN
TESTIFIED AS TO THE CHALLENGES
FIRST AMENDMENT AS WELL AS
SECTION TWO THIRTY CHALLENGES-
FOR A STATE TO BE LEGISLATING
IN THIS SPACE. WHILE WE ARE
LIMITED IN TERMS OF TIME I
PERSONALLY AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE WOULD WELCOME ANY
KIND OF WRITING OR THINKING
YOU'VE DONE ON THIS SUBJECT AS
TO HOW WE CAN- ADDRESS THIS
HARM AND IF THERE'S ANY DEBATE
THAT. THERE'S SIGNIFICANT HARM
THAT CAN BE DONE ON THE NET AND
I DON'T THINK IT'S A DEBATE
THAT WE AS ELECTED OFFICIALS
HAVE SOME RESPONSIBILITY TO
ADDRESS THAT HARM SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
LET ME CHANNEL OF SENATOR
PANDAS CENTER STERN MENTIONED
AWHILE AGO CENTER P. AND
COULDN'T BE HERE- BUT A
QUESTION TO. MR HOFFMAN WITH
RESPECT TO NOT CONTENT
MODERATION BUT TO TRANSPARENCY
IN TERMS OF AMPLIFICATION AS
TO- WHEN IT APPEARS. AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO THE- READ THAT
I'VE DONE THAT THERE IS AN
INCENTIVE FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO- PROMOTE THE
SALACIOUS AND SOMETIMES THE
HARMFUL MATERIAL BECAUSE IT IT
DRIES UP- CLICKS. SO IN TERMS
OF THAT MISTER HOFFMAN I'D BE
INTERESTED IN YOUR THOUGHTS IS
TO- WHERE WE GO TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY. AS TO THE
ALGORITHMS AND THE METHODS
USED. TO AMPLIFY THAT THAT SORT
OF MATERIAL. YES CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO TRY TO SPEAK TO THAT-
YOU KNOW I THINK. WHILE
ABSOLUTELY I THINK THERE'S MORE
ENGAGEMENT- RESOURCES CONTENT I
DON'T THINK THAT CAN BE DIVIDE-
I THINK THE REASON THAT THERE
IS MORE ENGAGEMENT ON CERTAIN
POSTS OR OTHERS- AND THE REASON
IS THE LINE THAT CAN BE
SOMEWHAT COMPLICATED I'LL GIVE
YOU A QUICK EXAMPLE- A LOT OF
STE SOME OF THE TOP PERFORMING
MAKES ON OUR OUR SOCIAL MEDIA
SITES- ARE POLITICAL- AND- DID
ENGAGEMENT. FOR THOSE CAN BOTH
BE COMING FROM IF IT'S A CAR
RIGHT POWER STARTS A ROAD LAST
POST I CAN BE COMING FROM BOTH
SIDES WHERE- IF IT'S
MISINFORMATION OR AGENTS SOME-
OUTRAGEOUS COMMENT FROM A
POLITICAL LEADER- YOU'VE GOT
FOLKS TRYING TO DEMAND TO AND-
AND DOWN FLAT AND SO. YOU KNOW
I THINK WILD YES THAT DOES
DRIVES ENGAGEMENT AND KEEPS
PEOPLE ENGAGED IT'S NOT THE
ONLY REASON THAT PEOPLE USE OUR
SITES EITHER- I'M SORRY YOU
KNOW WHEN. SUCH HAVE
IMPLEMENTED- DIFFERENT
MARRIAGES FOR EXAMPLE- WE FIND
RATES THAT PEOPLE ARE USING
ANGRY BUT THEY'RE ALSO USING
OTHER EMERGES TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES WHILE IN A WHILE YOU
KNOW I I'VE NOTED BEFORE. OUR
OUR SITES TO- THE REAL WORLD-
YOU KNOW I THNK THE- ANGRY
AND- MAYBE MORE VITRIOLIC AND
OUTRAGEOUS- POST GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION- THE ONES THAT- DON'T
EXHIBIT THAT DON'T GET AS MUCH
ATTENTION WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS. AS FAR AS
TRANSPARENCY INTO THE
ALGORITHMS- YEAH I THINK YOU
KNOW WE CAN START TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WE
CAN- PROVIDE I THINK YOU KNOW
WE START TO RUN INTO WHERE-
WHERE SOME OF THESE ALGORITHMS
THAT THEY ARE PROPRIETARY ITS
POWER COMPANIES- ARE VALUED-
THAT'S WHY THEY COMPETE WITH
EACH OTHER- TO DEVELOP BETTER.
ALGORITHMS- AND SO YOU KNOW
THERE THERE WILL SOME WOMEN AS
TO WHY ARE WE ARE WILLING TO DO.
AND BUT YOU RETURN BEFORE
STATUS. I THINK APPROPRIATE
GUARDRAIL WERE NOT- WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT TYPE OF. I
WILL BE AB CRUCIAL. THANK YOU-
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION THERE ARE NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT MEASURES THAT ARE
PENDING- WE BEGAN THIS. HEARING
WITH TESTIMONY THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY
THAT. PROVIDES SOME SORT OF
CONTENT MODERATION THAT THAT'S
A CHALLENGE- GIVEN BOTH SECTION
TWO THIRTY IN THE FIRST MOMENT
IN A NUMBER OF OTHER ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE. THAT
HAVE BEEN GREAT FOOD FOR
THOUGHT OF THIS CONVERSATION IS
GOING TO CONTINUE INTO- THE
NEXT. YEAR AS THESE BILLS COME
BEFORE THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
BUT I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR THEIR EXCELLENT
EXCELLENT PRESENTATION. AND
WE'RE NOT SHY- WILL BE REACHING
OUT TO YOU FOR MORE INFORMATION
AND WE WOULD BE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR ASSISTANCE. LET ME- LAST
ESTAS CENTER COURT TO BEFORE
YOU TURN TO PUBLIC COMMENT
CENTER CORTESE IF YOU HAVE ANY.
REMARKS I JUST WOULD ARGUE
REMARKS THANK YOU- LOOK FORWARD
TO. OF THE SEAT TO DR TOPPING A
VERY CHALLENGING- AREA OF THE
LEGISLATIVE AND BUT AGAIN AS I
SAID THE OFFICE OF THE OF THE
COMMITTEE MEETING TODAY- I
DON'T KNOW HOW ELSE WE COULD
HAVE GATHERED THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION. AND- PROS AND CONS
IF YOU WILL. WITHOUT HIM YOU
THE COMMITTEE HAVING HAVING
CONVENE THIS- THIS HEARING
TODAY SO THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M
SURE WILL INFORM- THE REST OF
THE WORK WE NEED TO DO OVER THE
COMING YEAR. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SECRETARY THANK YOU FLAWS
IN THE CORTESE FOR THOSE WHO
AREN'T HERE EARLIER IT IS- A
SPECIAL POINTED JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FOR PURPOSES THIS
HEARING- ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
TURN TO PUBLIC COMMENT HERE- WE
ARE SOMEWHAT LIMITED- AND I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
FOLKS THAT ARE QUEUED UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. SO WHAT WE WILL
DO IS WE'RE GOING TO. LIMIT
PUBLIC COMMENT TWO ONE MINUTE.
FOR EACH INTERVENTION SO MADAM
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
THE FIRST PERSON WHO WISHES TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WELL LET
ME BEFORE WE DO THAT LET ME LET
ME FIRST. COME TO. OF ROOM THE
ROOM WHERE WE'RE HAVING THIS
HEARING OF FORTY TWO OR THREE
ANYONE HERE- ANYONE IN THE
INSULAR ROOM IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY I DON'T SEE ANYONE.
WISHING TO PROVIDE LIVE
TESTIMONY SO LET'S GO TO THE
PHONES MAN MODERATOR. DO WE
HAVE CONNECTIVITY.
FROM DOES
ANYONE HEAR MY VOICE. ALL RIGHT
SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE I THINK
MOMENTARILY.
ALL RIGHT
MODERATOR WE READY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THEY'RE NOT. ARE YOU
THERE. HARDER. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO MAY BE LISTENING OR
WAITING- WE ALSO- THIS MAY BE
SURPRISING TO SOME WE CAN READ
SO YOU CAN SEND US WRITTEN
COMMENTARY THAT THAT WE WILL
READ. EVERYTHING IS ALSO. HI
BOB DECHIARA YEAH I'M LOCKED
OUT. I JUST TURN THE PHONE- CAN
YOU COMMUNICATE WITH THEM. YEAH.
AB RIGHT. THE LITTLE. MERMAID-
YEAH MOREOVER YOU OVER THE NEW
HEARING ROOM. NO WE'RE NOT
LOCATED ON THE SAN FRANCISCO.
YOU ARE MEETING ON- THE HOBBIT
WE LIVE IN. MINNESOTA. RIGHT.
EVERYTHING ON THE- WALKING BACK
IN AND. THE NEWS YEAH. YEAH.
BOB EVANS. ORDERS. YEAH. BRUCE.
THEY ARE. AND SOME. I. YOU SEE
A DOCTOR HOW MANY CALLERS
EARLIER BERNIE WILSON A- EIGHT
EVEN. LOS ANGELES. IN OKAY SO
YOU SEE- THERE ARE. AND WHILE
RIDICULOUSLY. FROM THE CHEST OR
SOMETHING AND. WHAT BOB C.
MOBILE PHONE NUMBER- THIS ONE
OVER MEMORIES. THE REST OF THE
WEEK WE HAVE. TO THIS IS ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT MAURICE- BOTH
ARE. AND THEN THERE'S NO OTHER.
RIGHT. WE CAN- YEAH. PUBLIC
COMMENT THE LITTLE. YOUR DOLLAR.
WE YEAH WE HANG UP THAT'LL IF
WE DISCONNECT FROM EIGHTEEN
ANTI. WE. GOOD EFFECT ON FIXING
THE CONNECTION EVERYTHING LOOKS
GOOD. OKAY HELLO YEAH. THANK
EVERYTHING LOOKS. YEAH RUSSIAN
FOREIGN OF ALL I DON'T KNOW
OKAY RIGHT. WITH YEAH IT WAS.
RIGHT BOB. WE HAVE ALL OKAY.
YEAH. OKAY SO I JUST A. OKAY
THE MARKET OFFERED CHAIRMAN.
NEXT OKAY MMHM MYSTERIES. RIGHT
WE LIVE IN A LITTLE. UHHUH
RIGHT HE'S DROPPED IT- THANK
YOU- THE IS A JUSTICES ONE
MOMENT TESTING IS. FILE ON. THE
ROOF A FIFTY TALKING. BUT A-
THEY WENT OUT THE COMING BACK
IN THE OF THE FIFTEEN NON. BE
RECESSED. I NEED A COPY THAT WE
MIGHT YOUR GIVE A FIVE MINUTE
GIVE US MINUTES SIR. LOS OR-
OR- CALL THE OFFICE AND SEE YOU
WANT THEM WELL YEAH AND IT ALL
RIGHT. POSTERS OF. YEAH THE-
HE'S HERE HE'S HERE. THE FINAL.
I WAS. CORTESE'S BECAUSE MIGHT
BE RIGHT. YOU CAN OKAY MAN.
THURMOND NOT ACCEPT SO I
APOLOGIZE THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
TO PER PUBLIC COMMON WE'RE
GOING TO RESET TO SOME
TECHNICAL CHALLENGES AND WILL
BE BACK IN FIVE MINUTES. THANK
YOU SIR.
MADAME MODERATOR ALL
WE'RE PREPARED FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IF YOU WOULD TO UP THE
FIRST CALLER. ONE MINUTE EACH
THANK YOU. OKAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU HAVE NOT
ALREADY QUEUED UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY DO SO BY
PRESSING ONE ZERO WE WILL
RESUME WITH MY NUMBER THIRTY
ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. AND I CALLED TO OPPOSE
ANY- BURDENSOME REGULATION ON
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS-
INCLUDING TRANSPARENCY RELATED
LEGISLATION- AND OF COURSE
CONTENT REGULATION- WHEN THE
STATE- IMPOSES BURDENSOME
REGULATION AND REGULATES THE
CONTENT ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS I FEEL THAT THEY ARE
THAT SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS. I
HAVE ESSENTIALLY BECOME STATE
ACTORS AND ARE BOUND BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT AND I DON'T I AM.
HAVE A LAW DEGREE AND A
MASTER'S IN PSYCHOLOGY AND I
DON'T WANT MY- LIST I RECOGNIZE
THAT THE STATE HAS A HISTORY OF
INFRINGING ON CIVIL LIBERTIES-
THE THIRTY FOOT ROLE WAS
RECENTLY STRUCK FROM SB. SEVEN
FORTY TWO BY A DISTRICT JUDGE.
AS INTENTION ON THE FIRST AND
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENTS- I JUST
CALLED- I FEEL THAT THE ONLY
STANDARD ANY BODY SHOULD BE
HELD TO WOULD BE BRAND AND YOUR
REAL HIGH L. AND LEGITIMATE.
LAW ASSIGNMENT FOR IMMINENT
LAWLESS ACTION- SPEECH SHOULD
NOT BE- INTENDS TO FIND RIGHT
AND AFTER SECTION TWO THIRTY
THANK YOU CALL- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. THE NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN IF YOU WOULD
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND THEN
PROCEED. EVERYONE AT. I HATE
EVERY SOCIAL MEDIA USER HAS THE
CHOICE TO BE ON SOCIAL MEDIA OR
NOT EVERY USER SHOCKED TO HAVE
THE TWIST YOUR RESEARCH TOPIC.
RIGHT FORMS SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO CREATE YOUR OWN
GUIDELINES AFTER GOVERNMENT.
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD PROTECT.
INFORMATION WE DON'T NEED THE
GOVERNMENT MONITOR.
MICROMANAGED WE CAN THE
INTERNET. AND UNDERSTOOD BY
QUOTING FRANKLIN HERE WITHOUT
FREEDOM OF THOUGHT. DOWN IN OF
PUBLICLY. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI AND
MY LINE THIRTY SIX IT'S BEEN
VERY CONFUSING THERE WAS A
RESEARCH- AND I HEARD MY FRIEND
DON SPEAKING BUT THE CHAIR
CRANK YOU HEAR ALL OR CALL YOUR
ON THE GO AHEAD AND IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND- GO AHEAD WITH
ASSEMBLY COMMON IN THE
COMMITTEE. YOU KNOW I FOR
FASCINATING THAT OVER FOUR
HOURS IN YOUR LIMITING PUBLIC
COMMENT BUT AT LEAST YOU'RE
TAKING COMMENT AT ALL.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE PORT-
HEARING DID LAST WEEK WHICH WAS
NOT TO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
ALL SO THAT BEING SAID SIXTY
SECONDS IS NOT ENOUGH
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU PONTIFICATE
FOR FOUR HOURS WITH YOUR
SUPPOSED EXPERTS BUT I'LL LEAVE
YOU WITH THIS. THOSE WHO
ALREADY WALKS OF MISTER BILLY
WILL SAY THERE IS NO CAUSE FOR
ALARM WHICH OF MISDIAGNOSIS NOT
OUR HERITAGE THE FIRST
AMENDMENT WAS DESIGNED TO ALLOW
REBELLION TO REMAIN OF OUR
HERITAGE THE CONSTITUTION WAS
DESIGNED TO KEEP GOVERNMENT OFF
THE BACKS OF THE PEOPLE. THE
BILL OF RIGHTS WAS ADDED TO
KEEP THE PRECINCTS OF BELIEF
AND EXPRESSION THE PRESS OF
POLITICAL AND SOCIAL ACTIVITIES
FREE FROM SURVEILLANCE THE BILL
OF RIGHTS WAS DESIGNED TO KEEP
AGENTS OF GOVERNMENT AND
OFFICIAL EAVESDROPPERS AWAY
FROM ASSEMBLY THE PEOPLE THE
AIM WAS TO ALLOW MEN TO BE FREE
AND INDEPENDENT. AND TO ASSERT
THEIR RIGHTS AGAINST COOPER
ALREADY GOVERNMENT THANK YOU
MAN LATER IDENTIFIED WHAT THE
NEXT. CALLER NO MODERATOR.
LINEUP EIGHTEEN YEAR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN WE CAN. MY NAME CABINET
RIGHTS PROJECT COUNTY THE
BACKGROUND PAPER STATES THE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM TO
RESPONSIBLE FOR GREAT SOCIETAL
HARM SOCIAL MEDIA MAKES IT EASY
TO SPREAD MISINFORMATION THAT
LED TO DIRE CONSEQUENCES FOR
ACCOUNT COUNTRY OLITICAL AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH IS SUGGESTING
THAT QUESTIONING ELECTION
RESULTS IN A SIGNIFICANTLY IN
THE COMING NINETEENTH ACTING AS
A RESULT OF MISINFORMATION TAKE
A LOOK AT THEBEARS DEATH RATES
IN THE- COMING NINETEEN ACTING
IN THE MINISTRY OF TRADE. I AM
VERY PROUD OF THE LOG REDUCING
GOVERNMENT PROPAGANDA THE
PURVEYOR OF TRUTH LISTEN TO THE
SO CALLED PROBLEM
MISINFORMATION INCLUDES
INCREASED RISK TOUGH REGULATION
BY THE PLATFORM EXEMPTS. THEM
FROM LIABILITY UNDER SECTION
TWO THIRTY PROBLEMS ARE NOT
EXEMPT FROM LIABILITY WHEN IT
CONCERNS CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING
TO THE STOP ENABLING SEX
TRAFFICKERS ACT ENACTED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP. WHEN EVERYBODY HERE AND
GENERATE. REALLY DOESN'T THE
BUGS ON MATTERS THE AS SHE WILL
ON AND THE ACTOR. YOUR
LEGISLATIVE GET INSIDE WHICH
OPTION. HELP THE TENTH
DESCENDING VOICES THANK YOU ANY
SOCIAL MEDIA OR- IF WE GO TO
YOUR CALL PLEASE. BACK. THE
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER THIRTY YEAR
IS NOW. YES MY NAME IS NICOLE
YOU AND I'M NOT SURE CARE.
PATRICK COUNTY AND WAS
WONDERING IF I WAS TO THE
ALLEGED OR THE MINISTRY TRUTH.
WE DO NOT NEED. EIGHT HOW
LEADING TO OUR BUT- TROOPS ARE
DID IT LIKE WHAT. CAN'T CANNOT
ARE YOU WE HAVE BRING. I WILL
GO BACK AND RE READ BACK AFTER
YOU TO AN OATH I'M DOT COM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. LINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. NINE THIRTY
EIGHT- I CAN HAVE A LITTLE
QUICK TO- BECAUSE I IT'S REALLY
AND- BIG AND FAN- QUESTION IN
HEARING BY WAY A PRESS. BUT HE
DOES. THE APPEAR ENCOURAGE TO
UP IN PERTH. AND YOU WANT ONE
PEACE WHO WANT TO MAKE THEIR
OWN MEDICAL CHOICES IN WITH.
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO. YOUR
LITTLE. YOU KNOW. MY NUMBER
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. IF YOU TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND THEN PROCEED WITH
COMMON. THAT WOULD BE GREAT-
RIGHT MY NAME IS MICHAEL. AND-
FROM THE FATHER'S MY JUST LIKE
TO SAY THAT- ESPECIALLY TO
CORTESE IS THAT THAT LAST-
SPEAKER. TALKING ABOUT COERCION
ON. MAKING PEOPLE DO STUFF
UNDER COERCION AND THE STATE IS
CURRENTLY MAKING PEOPLE. IT
JOBS UNDER THE COLORS OF
ACCESS- BY FOURTEEN BANDAIDS
UPON NURSES AND HEALTHCARE
WORKERS. GARBAGE MAN OVER A
HUNDRED PEOPLE AND JOB SAFE WAY
ANYWHERE WHO- ACTUALLY HAVE
READ THAT THE SCIENCE HERE TO
YOU- THINK THAT THE STATE IS
GOING TO BE THE ARBITER OF
SCIENCE THAT'S HOW WE GOT INTO
THE INQUISITION AND- IF YOU
THINK THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
NEEDS TO. WIPE OUT THE
CONSTITUTION OF THIS COUNTRY.
THANK YOU HAVE BEEN PAINTED
HISTORY- YOU CAN COME BACK AND
BITE US ALL ON THE BUT- IN A
WON'T FEEL GOOD. I'LL BE FILLED
WITH POISON IN ORDER THANK YOU
MICHAEL THOUGH NEXT GALLAGHER.
ENJOY YOUR ENJOY YOUR DAY THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOU DO IT YOU JUST
DO LAST THANK YOU. AND NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER FORTY YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. I'M I'M FORTY YES
COLOR PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
I DIDN'T KNOW I WAS GOING FORTY
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MOST
PLAYERS I AM MEASURING I'M
CALLING FROM US ACCOUNTING. ME
VERY. THE CONCERNED. I FEEL
LIKE. WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO.
JUDGE WHAT WHAT WHAT IS
CONSIDERED MISINFORMATION BUT
YOU. A LITTLE HISTORY LESSON.
I'M NOT THE GERMAN THE ****
WANTED GERMANS TO SUPPORT NOT
TO DICTATORSHIP THE BLAZE OF
NOT THE IDEOLOGY THAT I TALKED
ABOUT. THE CALL WAS INSTALLED
THEY TRY TO CONTROL FORMS OF
COMMUNICATION FOR CENSORSHIP
AND PROPAGANDA. AND I'M LOOKING
TO DOCTOR DONOVAN EXPRESSED IN
SUPPORT IT'S VERY IDEOLOGY
SHOULD APPARENTLY PREACHING
AGAINST ONE OF TO WONDER. WHAT
HOMEOWNERS POLITICALLY DRIVEN.
WHAT NOT GERMANY HAS CONTROLLED.
OF ALL COMMUNICATION PAPERS
HERE TO COMMIT GENOCIDE. DR
DONOVAN OPENLY ADMITTED THAT
THEY OPENED UP DUMMY ACCOUNTS
TOGETHER FIVE THANK YOU
GATHERED COLLAR UNEXPLODED THAT
SOUND. AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
THAT CONCLUDES PUBLIC COMMENT
THANK YOU THE PANELISTS THANK
YOU FOR THOSE WHO TUNED IN- WE
ARE GOING TO BE IN RECESS WILL
BE BACK IN JANUARY THANK YOU.